GOOD MORNING AND
LET'S SEE IF WE COULD TURN DOWN
THE VOLUME ON THIS LITTLE BIT.
IN THE MEANTIME I'LL BACK AWAY
FROM THE LACK. SO STARTING AGAIN
GOOD MORNING WELCOME TO BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE THREE- FEWER HERE
YOU'D SEE ON THE ONLY MEMBERS
THERE RIGHT NOW WILL BEGIN AND-
AS A SUB COMMITTEE. BECAUSE WE
ALREADY ARE SUBCOMMITTEE OF BUT-
WILL- I BEGIN NOW AND THE- I
TAKE ROLE WHEN WE ACHIEVEDA
QUORUM. TODAY WE'RE HAVING AN IN
PERSON HEARING IN THE STATE
CAPITAL WERE IN ROOM FOUR FORTY
SEVEN BACK IN ORIGINAL HOME. THE
PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY THOSE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN PERSON MAY DO SO
WHEN WE OPEN PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE END OF THE HEARING. AFTER
THOSE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM OF
SPOKEN WILL ALLOW PHONE
TESTIMONY. AND IF YOU WISH TO
GIVE TESTIMONY BY PHONE THE
PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD
ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. BUT
THAT NUMBER IS. 1-576-928-9578.
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN YOU'LL NEED AN
ACCESS CODE THAT CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR SEVEN
AGAIN IT'S ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR FOUR SEVEN. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2099 THE
STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU.
ALL COMMENTERS WILL HAVE UP TO
ONE MINUTE TO SPEAK WE'LL SEE
HOW THE MEETING GOES OF THINGS
MOVE ALONG QUICKLY- WE MAY BE
ABLE TO EXPAND THAT- A SOMEWHAT
. WILL NOT BE TAKING ANY VOTES
TODAY. BUT WE WILL START WITH
OUR- SEVEN DISCUSSION ITEMS AND
FIRST WILL THAT ALL OF THE
PANELISTS GIVE THEIR TESTIMONY
AND THEN OPENED- OF THE FLOOR TO
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. AFTER SEVEN DISCUSSION
ITEMS ARE COMPLETE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MAY ASK QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ABOUT THE NON
DISCUSSION ITEMS I KNOW I HAVE
AT LEAST ONE QUESTION AND WE
WILL AND AFTER THAT WITH PUBLIC
COMMENTS. SO WE WILL BEGIN WITH
ISSUE ONE AND THE SECRETARY
CROWFOOT I ASSUME YOU'RE OUT
THERE SOMEWHERE GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR BLUE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANKS SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO FRAME OUR
DISCUSSION TODAY ABOUT WATER IN
DROUGHT AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN RECENT
YEARS ALLOCATING IMPORTANT
FUNDING TO BUILD OUR DROUGHT
RESILIENCE. WE KNOW THAT CLIMATE
DRIVEN EXTREMES CLIMATE CHANGE
DRIVEN EXTREMES ARE TESTING
CALIFORNIA'S WATER SYSTEM. AT
TWO YEARS FOLLOWING JULY TWENTY
TWENTY RANK AMONG THE HOTTEST
AND DRIEST IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY. WE ARE EXPERIENCING A
REMARKABLE WINTER WINTER WEATHER
HAS SEE SAWED BETWEEN POWERFULLY
WET STORMS IN OCTOBER AND
DECEMBER AND THEN EXTREMELY DRY
WEATHER THE REST OF THE MONTH.
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
JUST CONDUCTED THEIR MOST RECENT
SNOW SURVEY IN THE SIERRA NEVADA
AND SHARED WITH US THAT IT IS
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY IS THE
DRIEST IN OVER A CENTURY OF
RECORD KEEPING. THE EXTENDED RUN
OF DRY DAYS HAS OBVIOUSLY
STRONGER SIERRA SNOW PACK THAT
WE RELY ON FOR WATER SUPPLY FROM
WELL ABOVE AVERAGE TO BELOW
AVERAGE. AND NOW MOST MAJOR
RESERVOIRS FALL BELOW AVERAGE
STORAGE SO IT IS VERY CLEAR THAT
WE ARE PREPARING FOR A THIRD
CONSECUTIVE YEAR UP DROP. WE ARE
PREPARED TO RESPOND TO DROUGHT
EMERGENCIES FROM SMALL ISOLATED
COMMUNITIES WITH WATER SUPPLY
ISSUES TO SPECIFIC SPECIES
IMPACTED BY THESE CONDITIONS. AT
THE SAME TIME WHILE WE RESPOND
TO THOSE EMERGENCY SITUATIONS
WE'RE KEEPING OUR EYES FOCUSED
ON HELPING REGIONS ACROSS THE
STATE THE OLD LONG TERM
RESILIENCY. TO DROUGHT AND
ADJUST TO THIS NEW NORMAL WITH
MORE FREQUENT AND HARMFUL DROPS
AND THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THE
NEAR TERM ACTIONS AND THE LONGER
TERM ACTIONS. WHAT YOU KNOW LAST
SUMMER AND FALL WITH YOUR
LEADERSHIP WE ARE ALLOCATED
APPROVEDFIVE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS TO
RESPOND. TO DROUGHT AND FLOOD TO
BUILD WATER RESILIENCE
REMARKABLE HISTORIC AMOUNT OF
MONEY. HE'S INVESTMENTS THAT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TRACK THE
FRAMEWORK OF WHAT WE CALL OUR
WATER RESILIENCE PORTFOLIO IT'S
OUR ROAD MAP IN THE NEW CIVIC
MINISTRATION TO ADDRESS DROUGHT
AND FLOOD. AND BUILD RESILIENCE
WE RECOGNIZE THERE'S NO SILVER
BULLET SOLUTION TO CALIFORNIA'S
WATER CHALLENGES IT'S REALLY A
CASE YOU TO THE REALLY A CASE OF
ALMOST SILVER BUCKSHOT. ALL
SORTS OF INVESTMENTS I AM
CHANGES THAT WE NEED TO MAKE TO
MODERNIZE OUR SYSTEM WITH A
FOCUS ON BUILDING REGIONAL WATER
RESILIENCE WE CANNOT PURSUE A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL SOLUTION IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE'RE SUCH A
BIG AND DIVERSE STATE. DIFFERENT
REGIONS OF THE STATE EXPERIENCED
THESE CHALLENGES DIFFERENTLY SO
WE ARE FOCUSED ON INVESTMENTS
THAT BUILD THAT'S WATER
RESILIENCE I REGIONALLY. B. AS
IN. THAT ARE BEING MADE THIS
YEAR INCLUDING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT'S
ALREADY GOTTEN OF THE DOOR IN
BEING PLANNED FOR THE NEXT TWO
YEARS WILL PUT US IN A BETTER
POSITION. BOTH IN DESTRUCTION
SUBSEQUENT DROUGHTS. I TALK
ABOUT FIVE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLARS AGREED UPON BY THE
LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR TO BE SPENT
OVER THREE YEARS THAT INCLUDES
PROPOSED FUNDING IN THIS BUDGET
OF A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
WATER RECYCLING AND GROUNDWATER.
NOPE EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS TO
IMPROVE REGIONAL WATER
CONVEYANCE. A NINETY MILLION
DOLLAR FOUR DOORS
IN JANUARY PROPOSED AN
ADDITIONAL SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO BUILD OUR
WATER RESILIENCE AND RESPOND TO
DROUGHT. AND I WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT AND FRAME THAT
HOW WE'RE PROPOSING TO SPEND OUT
SOME OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF PROPOSED
FUNDING. YOU KNOW AND MANY OF
YOU HELP LEAD OUT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN LEGISLATION CALLED
MAKING CONSERVATION A CALIFORNIA
WAY OF LIFE. FOCUSED ON ON NOT
ONLY TAKING TEMPORARY ACTIONS TO
REDUCE WATER USAGE BY BUILDING
OR LONG TERM WATER EFFICIENCY
AND WHILE WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS
ON THIS WE RECOGNIZE STATE
INVESTMENT CAN SUPPORT NOT
PROGRESS BUILDING OUR WATER
EFFICIENCY. SO THAT SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS A
PROPOSED FUNDING INCLUDES A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT LOCAL WATER CONSERVATION
EFFORTS IN BOTH LARGE CITIES AND
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN LEGISLATION. AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE AIM OF
HELPING LOCAL AGENCIES REPLACE
ORNAMENTAL TURF. KIND OF A LONG
THAT NO WALKS ON EXCEPT TOMORROW
. ADDITIONAL FUNDING WILL GO TO-
IN AGRICULTURAL EFFICIENCY AND
I'M GLAD TO HAVE MY COLLEAGUE
SECRETARY ROSS HERE TO.
HIGHLIGHT THAT SIMPLY PUT WE
KNOW THAT RESILIENT PLANTS THE
CLIMATE APPROPRIATE TREES USE
LESS WATER. EACH SQUARE FOOT OF
TURF REPLACED SAVE THIRTY SIX
GALLONS OF WATER PER YEAR ON
AVERAGE WE KNOW WE CAN CITY
WATER WHILE I. A BEAUTIFUL
COMMUNITIES BUILDING GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SHADES AND
COOLS US. AT SEVEN FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ALSO INCLUDES THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO CONTINUE
INVESTMENTS HELPING GROUND
RECHARGE WE KNOW PART OF THE
SOLUTION TOWARD BUILDING
RESILIENCE IS GETTING WATER IN
THE WINTER WHEN IT DOES COME IN
THESE BIG STORMS AND STORING IT
UNDERGROUND TO RECHARGE
GROUNDWATER BASINS. AND SO THIS
PROPOSED FUNDING WOULD SUPPORT
PLANNING ENGINEERING ANALYSES
AND CONSTRUCTION THE CAPTURE
THOSE WINTER STORMS UNDERGROUND
AND RECHARGE GROUNDWATER BASINS.
I AM DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES
IS DOING A REMARKABLE JOB
IMPLEMENTING SICK MOM THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT AND MY COLLEAGUE
KARLA NEMETH WHO DIRECTS THE W.
OURS HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. ON THE- BYE IT'S-
THAT NOT ONLY THE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR GROUNDWATER RECHARGE
THAT IT'S FOCUSED ON STAYING ON
SIGNUP- WE CONTINUE TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS. HAVE BEEN
APPROPRIATED IN IN PAST YEARS-
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO HELP LOCAL GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT AGENCIES IMPLEMENT
SIGMA SIGMA. BUT WE KNOW THAT
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE ALONE IS
NOT GOING TO BRING TO STAND UP
THE SUSTAINABILITY OR
SUSTAINABLE YIELD TO BASINS IN
OTHER WORDS BRING BASINS TO. A
POINT WHERE THEY CAN SUSTAIN
WATER USAGE THROUGH UNDERGROUND
OUR WATER USAGE IN COMING
DECADES WE ALSO NEED TO REDUCE
GROUNDWATER PUMPING. AND THIS
BUDGET WOULD HELP COMMUNITIES
PREPARE TO REPURPOSE FARMLAND
WHERE GROUNDWATER USE IS
UNSUSTAINABLE. YOU KNOW THAT
LAST YEAR AGAIN THANKS TO YOUR
LEADERSHIP THE BUDGET INCLUDED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP
COMMUNITIES PLAN FOR CHANGES IN
LAND USE. AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION WITH IN OUR AGENCY
EXPECTS TO AWARD GRANTS IN MAY
ARE TO ALLOCATE THAT FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. GOVERNOR NEWSOM
HAS PROPOSED ANOTHER FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO EXTEND THIS
EFFORT TO HELP RURAL COMMUNITIES
PROSPER EVEN AT SOME OF THIS
LAND GOES OUT OF FARM
PRODUCTION. OUT TO BRING GROUND
USAGE INTO BALANCE. OTHER NEWS
THE ALSO. A SOME FIVE DOLLARS TO
HELP OUR DEPARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE CONTINUE TO RESPOND TO
YOU AND GET AHEAD OF DROUGHT
IMPACTS FOR FISH AND WILDLIFE.
ON IT WOULD WOULD CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE HATCHERIES AND
ECOLOGICAL PRESERVES. ADDRESSED
HUMAN WILDLIFE CONFLICTS
INCLUDING THE BERIKAN BEAR HUMAN
CONFLICTS THAT I'VE GOTTEN SO
MUCH ATTENTION IN TAHOE. HELP
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS TAKE ACTIONS
TO PROTECT FISH AND WILDLIFE.
REMOVE OBSTACLES TO FISH PASSAGE
LIKE OBSOLETE DAMS AND BARRIERS
AND RESTORE HABITAT WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY SO IMPORTANT. AND
CHUCK BONHAM OUR COLLEAGUE WHO
NEEDS AN APARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE IS HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS IT'S REMARKABLE WITH
DFW CONTINUES TO DO. IT IN
ADDITION TO THAT THOSE PROPOSED
FUNDING WITHIN THE SEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION WE
ARE ALSO PROPOSING AN ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO REPLENISH TWO REALLY
IMPORTANT DROUGHT RESPONSE
PROGRAMS. I WANT URBAN LARGER
URBAN WATER AGENCIES WANT A
SMALLER WATER AGENCIES-
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING WAS.
ALLOCATED TO THOSE PROGRAMS IN
THE LAST- LAST FALL AND LAST
SUMMER AND FALL. IN OTHER WORDS
ABLE TO BE SPENT THIS YEAR AND
SO FAR THIS YEAR D. W. R. HAS
RELEASED FIVE ROUNDS OF GRANT
FUNDING. NEARLY A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP SMALL
COMMUNITIES LEAKING PIPELINES
AND STORAGE AND STOP STORAGE
TANKS AND OTHERWISE KEEP
DRINKING WATER FLOWING WHICH IS
REALLY GREAT. NDW ARE HAS
AWARDED AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN MULTI BENEFIT
DROPPED REALLY PROJECTS THAT
BENEFIT WATER LARGER WATER
SUPPLIERS. SO AGAIN THIS
COMBINATION OF FUNDING FOR A
CUTE DROUGHT RESPONSE. ALL
BUILDINGS ARE. RESILIENCE MY
CHAIR THEY SEVEN ON FIFTY DOLLAR
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF CONTINGENCY
THAT WE ANTICIPATE TO BE
ALLOCATED AS PART OF THE SPRING
BUDGET PROCESS OF COURSE WE ARE
PUTTING TOGETHER THE JAN TEN
BUDGET IT WAS UNCLEAR HOW
CONDITIONS WOULD FALL THIS
WINTER AND WE WANTED TO MAINTAIN
A THIRD OF OUR PROPOSED
ALLOCATION THE NEW ALLOCATION OF
SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO. A
CONTINGENCY THAT THEN WILL BRING
FORWARD A PROPOSAL THROUGH THE
SPRING BUDGET PROCESS GIVEN THE
EVOLUTION OF HYDRO PRODIGY THIS
WINTER ARE VERY CLEAR AGAIN THAT
WE ARE HEADING INTO THE THIRD
YEAR OF WORSENING DROUGHT AND
IT'S VERY LIKELY THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WILL BE
QUITE HELPFUL TO HELP US RESPOND
TO DROUGHT. AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S HAS NOTED AND WE AGREE
FUNDS USED TO PROPEL DROUGHT
RESILIENCE ARE GOOD INVESTMENT.
EVEN IF EVEN IF THE SPECIFIC
FUNDS DON'T ALLEVIATE DROUGHT
IMMEDIATELY. IT'S TRULY YEAR
ROUND WORK AND IT'S I WOULD SAY
. OLD WORK WE KNOW THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE HAS CREATED A NEW NORMAL
WITH OUR WATER SYSTEMS AND WE
NEED TO MODERNIZE OUR WATER
SYSTEMS ACROSS THE STATE. BOTH
TO PROTECT PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS NATURE I
AND FISH AND WILDLIFE AND OF
COURSE OUR OUR ECONOMY
INCLUDING. AGRICULTURE SO WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED TO PRESENT THIS
IS BUT- BUT AGAIN BOTH DIRECTOR
NEMETH AND DIRECTOR BONHAM ARE
HERE TO ANSWER SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE FOR THOSE
DEPARTMENTS. THANKS SO MUCH.
GREAT EXCUSE ME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR- PRESENTATION AND
FOR YOUR DEDICATION TO THE MANY
ISSUES THAT YOU'RE- AGENCY NEEDS
TO ADDRESS MANY OF THEM- AND
CRISIS MODE. IF WE COULD GET-
HOLD QUESTIONS I THINK IT TO ALL
THE PRESENTATIONS OF THE DATE
THAT WOULD BE GREAT- SO I THINK
WE HAVE US SECRETARY ROSS SAID
DITA NEXT TO PRESENT. TURNING
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES.
SECRETARY CRAWFORD WHO ALWAYS
DOES SUCH A GREAT JOB OF SETTING
THE FRAME FOR OUR DISCUSSION
HERE TODAY. ON BEHALF OF THE
AGRICULTURE- CDFA IS REQUESTING
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND. FOR THE STATE
WATER EFFICIENCY ENHANCEMENT
PROGRAM ARE SWEET PROGRAM- THIS
IS ONE THAT WAS ONE OF OUR VERY
FIRST CLIMATE SMART AT PROGRAMS
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN IN THE LAST DROUGHT- IT
HAS INVESTED A TOTAL OF EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS OVER THAT PERIOD
OF TIME. AND HAS RESULTED IN AN
ANNUAL WATER SAVINGS OF OVER A
HUNDRED AND SEVEN THOUSAND ACRE
FEET OF WATER IN ADDITION TO
REDUCING ENERGY USE AND REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AS
SECRETARY CRAWFORD HAS POINTED
OUT WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH A
FAIRLY TOUGH WATER HERE- THAT
LAST TWO YEARS IN PARTICULAR AND
IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE HEADING INTO
A PRETTY SEVERE SITUATION AGAIN
THIS YEAR. JUST LAST WEEK THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA MERCED-
ISSUED A PRELIMINARY REPORT THAT
WAS COMMISSIONED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE THANKS TO THE
FUNDING THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR. MADE AVAILABLE TO
US LAST YEAR. ON ITS FINDINGS
FOR THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THE WATER
YEAR. IS THAT THERE WAS
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND ACRES THAT
WORK BALLOT- THE- PRIMARY
BELLOWING FOR CRUDE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT THERE WAS
ALSO CAN. RICE PAPERS THAT WAS
VALID IN THE SACRAMENTO- RIVER
VALLEY. AND THAT RESULTED IN A
ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR
LOSS OF REVENUES ON. FARM
INCOME. WHEN YOU TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES
THAT HAPPEN AS A RESULT OF LEFT
ANTI ACTIVITY AND HARVESTING
ACTIVITY. THE TOTAL OF A HUNDRED
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
IN TOTAL LAST REVENUES. I'M FINE
JOBS THAT LOST BECAUSE OF THE
FOLLOWING. FOR ABOUT EIGHT EIGHT
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED JOBS AND
TOTAL LOST JOBS IS UP OVER
FOURTEEN THOUSAND TOPS. SO THE
PRIMARY- ACREAGE THAT WAS FELLOW
PRESS. COTTON FIELD CROPS THAT'S
A LOT OF THE FORAGE CROPS WITH
THE DAIRY SECTOR. AND THEN
ANNUAL ROW CROPS LIKE MELONS
POTATOES GARLIC AND ONIONS- WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS PROGRAM FOR ON
FARM WATER USE EFFICIENCY HAS
BEEN THE MOST POPULAR PROGRAM.
BECAUSE TECHNOLOGY IS CHANGING
TO REALLY HELP FARMERS USE EVERY
DROP OF WATER AS CAREFULLY AS
THEY POSSIBLY CAN. WATER USE
EFFICIENCY BASED ON THE
TESTIMONY THAT WE HEARD
YESTERDAY ON OUR STATE BOARD OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE- HEARING.
YES PROP A LOT OF THAT THAT
BROWN BUT SYSTEM. AGENCY THEY'RE
FOCUSING ON IMPROVING WATER
EFFICIENCY FIRST AND FOREMOST IN
ADDITION TO THE OTHER ISSUES
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO DEAL WITH
FOR DEMAND MANAGEMENT AND
REDUCING DEMAND ON OUR
GROUNDWATER BASINS. THIS IS FUND
WILL ALLOW US TO CONTINUE A
PROGRAM THAT IS CONTINUALLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED WE HAVE JUST
FINISHED- OF THE GRANT
APPLICATION PROCESS FOR THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
MADE AVAILABLE TO CDFA FOR THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR. WE WERE
OVERSUBSCRIBED WE HAD
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE AND WE HAVE
OVER EIGHTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
AND REQUEST. SO WE EXPECT TO BE
ABLE TO FULLY ALLOCATE NOT ONLY
THE FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
THAT. WERE MADE AVAILABLE AND
THE BUDGETAGREEMENT LAST YEAR
FOR THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR. BUT IF
THE TWENTY MILLION THAT BEEN
PRETTY FOR THIS WEEK PROGRAM.
THE OTHER BECAUSE FROM THIS FIVE
MILLION FOR TO WRAP RELIEF
SOURCE HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
FARMERS. WE KNOW THAT THESE
KINDS OF CRISIS ARE HARDER FOR
OUR SMALLEST. AND ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO HAVE HISTORICALLY NOT
BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS PROGRAMS TO
BE ABLE TO WITHSTAND THIS KIND
OF SHOCK IT'S FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WILL ALLOW FOR US. TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE DIRECT RELIEF TO
THOSE FARMERS WHO ARE ABSORBING
INCREASED WATER COSTS INCREASED
ENERGY COSTS INCREASED INPUT
COSTS. AND SO IT'S PLAN DOLLARS
WILL FOLLOW A PATTERN THAT WE
ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR IT'S OUR
CALIFORNIA UNDERSERVED PROGRAM
THAT REACHES FARMERS AND THE
MOST HARDEST TO REACH
COMMUNITIES. TO DO OUR BEST TO
ENSURE THAT THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO BE PRODUCTIVE. AND
WHAT'S THAT- I WENT. THAT'S WHAT
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE I'LL
HAVE AVAILABLE IF YOU HAVE
TECHNICAL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE NEXT UP WE HAVE- I
LEAN SO BACK THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD- GOOD
MORNING- CHARTWELLS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME AND
TESTIFY TO THAT. COULD I ASK YOU
TO GET A LITTLE CLOSER TO YOUR
MICROPHONE OR FOR SOMETHING YOU
CAN LEARN ABOUT THE VOLUME. AND
COULD YOU ASK THEM TO TURN THE
CAMERA INTO IT'S A LOT EASIER TO
BE TO READ A LOT ALSO- THANK YOU
. WE'VE GOT A REQUESTED TO TURN
YOUR CAMERA AND IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE- LIKE NUMBER IS ON IT'S
SHOWING. IT'S SHOWING MY VIDEOS
BEING ON EITHER YOUR PHONE NOW.
IT CAN YOU HEAR ME BETTER NOW A
LITTLE BIT BETTER IT'S STILL A
LITTLE BIT ON THE QUIET SIDE. I
WILL I WILL SHOUT- THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY- THE HE ASKED- BUT THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES BOARD
TODAY- AND LET ME JUST INTRODUCE
MYSELF I'M EILEEN SUFFOLK
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
ARE ASKED TODAY IS FOR TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN LOCAL
LISTINGS FUNDS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND. AND REGIONAL COUNTY BASED
DROUGHT EMERGENCY PROGRAMS AND
TO SUPPORT INTERMENT PROMINENT
SOLUTIONS FOR DRINKING WATER AND
DROUGHT AND ESPECIALLY. FOR WHAT
IT WATER OUTAGE EMERGENCIES SO
OUR FUNDING REQUEST AT THIS
POINT IS TO- AUGMENT THAT THE
FUNDS THAT WE HAVE TO WORK FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE IN THIS YEAR
OF. WHAT YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE
OTHER SPEAKERS ARE LIKELY IS
LIKELY TO BE ANOTHER- VERY
CHALLENGING YEAR. IT'S MODEL
AFTER OUR EXISTING SUCCESSFUL
FUND AND PROGRAMS RUN BY SELF
HELP ENTERPRISES IN EIGHT
COUNTIES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN. I'M
IN WHICH WE HAVE OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED HOUSEHOLDS- AND ROLLED
WHEN WE HAVE EXTREME DROUGHT
CONDITIONS I'M IT IS OFTEN
INDIVIDUAL HOUSEHOLD WELLS THAT
BEAR THE BRUNT OF THE IMMEDIATE
EFFECT. AND ART- OUR GOAL IS TO-
IDENTIFY THE PLACES THAT THAT IS
MOST LIKELY TO OCCUR IN MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE- HE- NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THAT HOUSEHOLD ABLE
TO. HAVE ACCESS TO STATE THE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER DURING THE
DROUGHT THESE ARE INTERIM
MEASURES- THAT WILL BE FUNDED BY
THIS REQUEST. WE ARE WORKING ON
MORE PERMANENT SOLUTIONS WE'VE
RECEIVED FUND IN THE PAST FROM
THE STATE IT. ALSO FROM FEDEAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDS- WHICH WILL
ALLOW US TO WORK- DILIGENTLY ON
LONG TERM RESILIENCE MEASURES-
SUPPORTING THE. THE CONSTRUCTION
OF- DEEPER WELLS OR- I HAVE
HOMES TO WATER- AND THIS FUNDING
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
IS TO- BRIDGE THE GAP DURING
DROUGHT YEARS UNTIL THOSE MORE
PERMANENT SOLUTIONS ARE IN PLACE. THANK YOU THAT THAT CAN CAUSE
YOUR REPORT. YES SIR I'M HERE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ALONG WITH- MEMBERS OF MY STAFF
EXCELLENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
DOES DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE
FOR A REPORTER ANYTHING TO ADD.
GOOD MORNING CHURCH MEMBERS
BRYAN FULLER DEPARTMENT FINANCE
AT NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AT
THIS POINT BUT PROVIDENCE HELP
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU I'M FINALLY
WE HAVE- RACHEL ELLERS- WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. ON
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RACHEL EHLERS WITH THAT.
ANALYST'S OFFICE NICE TO SEE YOU
ALL- WE THINK IN THINKING ABOUT
THIS PACKAGE IT'S REALLY HELPFUL
TO USE THE FRAMING THAT
SECRETARY CROWFOOT SET UP ABOUT.
HOW MUCH IS FOR IMMEDIATE URGENT
DROUGHT RESPONSE AND THEN HOW
MUCH IS FOR KIND OF LONGER TERM.
I DROUGHT RESILIENCE SO CLEARLY
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
THAT WAS SET ASIDE. BY THE
GOVERNOR IN HIS PROPOSAL IS.
SEEMINGLY KIND OF MORE TARGETED
THAT IN. TERM BACK IN JUNE AND
WE WEREN'T SURE WHETHER THAT
WOULD EVEN BE NEEDED I GUESS ONE
SILVER LINING WE CAN FIND IN
CURRENT CONDITIONS IS BUT AT
LEAST BY THE TIME YOU NEED TO
MAKE YOUR FINAL BUDGET DECISIONS
WE DO HAVE MORE CLARITY
TYPICALLY ABOUT WHAT THE
HYDROLOGY. IT'S GOING TO BE FOR
THE COMING YEAR AND IT'S- AS THE
SECRETARY NOTED NOT LOOKING
GREAT SO KIND OF KEEPING YOUR
EYE ON THAT ON THAT FUNDING SET
ASIDE FOR FUTURE DECISIONS IN
THE COMING MONTHS PROBABLY THAT
WILL BE MERITED. BUT OF THE FIVE
MILLION IN SPECIFIC PROPOSALS
THAT YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU IT'S
REALLY IN OUR CHARACTERIZATION
OF PRETTY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
THAT THAT IS FOR THE IMMEDIATE-
URGENT. WE HAVE. AROUND SIXTY
FIVE. OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION WOULD BE FOR MORE.
SENATE URGENT. BUDGET YEAR. THE
BEST MY- OF IT IS FOR A LONGER
TERM. DRIVERS ON. THAT NOT A BAD
THING AS THE SECRETARY NOTED I
MEAN IS THAT THE BEST TIME TO.
PREPARE FOR A DROUGHT AND
RESPOND TO DROUGHT IS BEFORE IT
HAPPENS BECAUSE THE PROJECTS
TYPICALLY DO TAKE. PART IN SOME
KEY YEARS TO DEVELOP AN PERMIT
AND CONSTRUCT OR IF THERE ARE
POLICY CHANGES THAT NEED TO BE
MADE- THAT SAID THAT YOU MADE A
VERY SIGNIFICANT. INVESTMENT AND
DROUGHT AND WATER RESILIENCE IN
THAT TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET PACKAGE INCLUDING FUNDING
EIGHT HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION
THAT WILL BE FOR THAT UPCOMING
BUDGET YEAR. SO EVEN IF YOU
APPROVE NONE OF THESE NEW
PROPOSALS THE STATE WOULD STILL
BE MAKING REALLY SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS ON THAT GOAL. TOWARDS
BUILDING GREATER DROUGHT
RESILIENCE. SO WE WOULD JUST
ADVISE YOU TO WEIGH THIS AMONGST
ALL OF YOUR OTHER BUDGET
PRIORITIES. SHOULD YOU DECIDE
THAT YOU WANT TO MAKE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN THESE GOALS. THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PACKAGES THE ONLY A BRIBE.
OPTION AVAILABLE FOR YOU YOU CAN
ALSO MAKE MODIFICATIONS TO THAT
TO REFLECT YOUR PRIORITIES. IN
PARTICULAR- WE WOULD SUGGEST YOU
THINK ABOUT GROUNDWATER RECHARGE
IT'S A PRETTY MODEST AMOUNT IN
THIS PACKAGE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THAT- KIND OF
ACTIVITY. WHICH AS THIS IS A
VERY PROMISING FOR BOTH THE
WATER SUPPLY AND WATER STORAGE.
APPROACH BUT ALSO FOR OTHER
BENEFITS LIKE FLOOD CONTROL SO
THINKING ABOUT IF YOU WANTED TO
DO PERHAPS GREATER INVESTMENT IN
GROUNDWATER STORE AT RECHARGE
PROJECTS. IN CONTRAST YOU MIGHT
WANT TO THINK ABOUT A SMALLER
INVESTMENT IN WATER CONSERVATION
GIVEN HOW MUCH WORK THE STATE
HAS DONE. EIGHTY THREE POLICY
CHANGES AND HOW MUCH PROGRESS.
WE HAVE SEEN IN REJECT AND IN
WATER USE AND IN. EFFICIENCY IN
THE URBAN. AND GIVEN THAT THE
URBAN SETTING IS ROOM IS ABOUT.
SMALL SHARE OF OVERALL WATER USE
AS COMPARED TO AGRICULTURE FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE STATE. OF THE
LABOR PURPOSING PROGRAM THAT THE
SECRETARY MENTIONED IT SHOWS A
LOT OF PROMISE BUT WAS JUST
STARTED LAST YEAR WE STILL DON'T
HAVE A SENSE OF. HOW THAT
PROGRAM WILL SHAPE UP WITH THE
DEMAND IS SO YOU COULD THINK
ABOUT KIND OF WAITING TO SEE HOW
THE FIRST ROUND AND FIRST YEAR
ON THAT PROGRAM GOES BEFORE
MAKING FURTHER INVESTMENTS. SO
IS IT REALLY A LOT OF OPTIONS
BEFORE YOU AS YOU THINK ABOUT
WHAT THE HIGHEST PRIORITIES FOR
ACHIEVING THESE IMPORTANT GOALS
ARE. WE WOULD OF COURSE ALSO
REMIND YOU THAT THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT OR GAN
LIMIT IS GOING TO BE AN
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION AGAIN
THIS YEAR SO THINKING ABOUT IF
YOU DIDN'T MAKE IT CATIONS TO
THE GOVERNOR'S PACKAGE. HOW THAT
WILL FOCUS AFFECT YOUR OVERALL
GAN OR SELL THEM THE PACKAGE AND
REQUIREMENTS. AND THEN THE FINAL
POINT THAT WE WOULD MAKE IS JUST
THE IMPORTANCE OF OVERSIGHT. AT
WHEN THE STATE HAS IN THE PAST
PASSED A LARGE WATER BONDS
THERE'S A LOT OF OVERSIGHT AND
REPORTING AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT'S BUILT INTO THE LANGUAGE
TYPICALLY. THIS WAS ALMOST LIKE
A FIVE BILLION DOLLAR WATER BOND
THAT WAS PASSED. IN IN THE MOST
RECENT YEAR BUT DIDN'T HAVE ALL
OF THAT KIND OF ACCOUNTABILITY
AND REPORTING LANGUAGE BUILT IN.
SO THAT'S WHY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BEEN REALLY
HELPFUL ABOUT PROVIDING A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW MUCH
FUNDING HAS HAS BEEN COMMITTED
ALREADY BUT THOSE ARE THE KINDS
OF REPORTS THAT WE WOULD.
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
REQUESTING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION NOT JUST BECAUSE
GOOD OVERSIGHT OVER SPENDING IS
GOOD GOVERNMENT TO AND
ACCOUNTABILITY BUT ALSO BECAUSE
THAT INFORMATION CAN REALLY HELP
GUIDE YOUR FUTURE DECISIONS NOT
JUST FOR THIS YEAR BUT IN THE
COMING YEARS ABOUT. WHERE
THERE'S A LOT OF DEMAND WHERE
THERE MAY BE SOME CHALLENGES
WHERE IT'S HARD GETTING FINDING
OUT THE DOOR- WHERE THERE MAY BE
VERY OR REAL SUCCESS. AND I
CAN'T IT. AS YOU'RE MAKING
FUTURE. SPENDING DECISIONS. SO
WITH THAT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
REPORT AND- LET ME BEGIN BY
AGREEING WITH YOU I THINK THAT
HAVING THAT- INFORMATION. FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION IS EXTREMELY
HELPFUL AND IMPORTANT. AND-
LET'S JUST- PUT IT OUT THERE
THAT I'M TAKEN THAT REQUEST. NOW
A SECRETARY CROWFOOT I DO HAVE A
COMMENT- ABOUT THE TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION. ORDER OF A
BILLION DOLLAR CONTINGENCY- ON
DROUGHT I- COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
THAT WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHERE
WE'RE HEADED WITH RESPECT TO THE
DROUGHT BUT- ON THE FLIP SIDE.
BOB IF WE WAIT UNTIL MAY REVISE
TO- THINK ABOUT AND DISCUSS-
WHAT THIS QUARTER OF A BILLION
DOLLARS IS GOING TO BE UTILIZED
FOR THAT'S PRETTY LATE IN THE
GAME I MEAN MAY REVISE IS
ALREADY- A BIG RUSH TO THE BIG
COMMENCES A BIG RUSH TO THE- TO
THE FINISH LINE- ON IT IT SEEMS
TO ME. THAT THIS CONTINGENCY
FUND IF WERE. WAITING TO UTILIZE
IT FOR- TO ADDRESS WHATEVER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES MAY BE AT. A LATER
TIME THAT MEANS THAT THIS IS FOR
URGENT NEAR TERM USES. AND THERE
OUGHT TO BE AT LEAST SOME
UNDERSTANDING GOING INTO- AND
THE PERIOD OF TIME BEFORE MAY
REVISED. WHAT THE TRIGGERS ARE
WITH THE METRICS ARE FOR THE USE
OF- OF THAT MONEY IS THAT
SOMETHING. THAT YOU THINK YOU
CAN GET TO US- SHORTLY. AS
OPPOSED TO HAVING TO WAIT UNTIL
MAY. WELL THANKS FOR THE COMMENT
AND POINT WELL TAKEN THE LAST
THING THAT WE WANT TO DO IS JAM
THE DISCUSSION ON SUCH A LARGE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING- AT THE SAME
TIME OBVIOUSLY WE WANTED TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE SPECIFIC
CONDITIONS THAT THEY WERE
EVOLVING AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT
IT BACK IN DECEMBER AS WE ARE
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER. IT WAS
THE ONE OF THE SNOW YES AND WHAT
IS DECEMBER THAT WE HAD SO WE
JUST WEREN'T SURE YOU KNOW HOW
AND IF AND HOW THE FUNDING WOULD
BE NEEDED THAT BEING SAID I WILL
WORK WITH OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN OUR GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
ON YOUR REQUEST TO AS I
UNDERSTAND IT SORT OF FRAME OUT
ARE FLUSH OUT. OUR APPROACH ON
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS BEFORE THE MAY REVISED
PROCESS SO YOU CAN PROVIDE INPUT
AND ENSURE THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THE DIRECTION WE'RE MOVING ON A
TWO FIFTY APPROPRIATE SO I WILL
GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT AND I
WILL TAKE THIS MESSAGE TO THE
TOP OF. THE FOOD CHAIN HERE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCED I THOUGHT
YOU WERE AT THE TOP OF THE FOOD
CHAIN. WELL WE HAVE. AS YOUR- WE
HAVE OUR I MEAN NO ALTERNATE I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. I
DON'T WANT TO SET AN EXPECTATION
THAT WE CAN'T MEET AND
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ARE OBVIOUSLY
ARE KEY PARTNERS ON. ALL HEALTH
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. AT IT
WITH. A AN ATTEMPT AT HUMOR
SECRETARY SAID OKAY. AND THANK
YOU FOR BEING RISK- A TO THAT
REQUEST. MISTER BENNETT I KNOW
YOU HAVE SOME QUESTIONS WHAT YOU
PICK UP FROM HERE. THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR BLOOM- AND I
- APPRECIATE PRESENTATION AND-
PARTICULARLY SECTOR CROW PUTS
SERVE OPEN US IN TERMS OF TRYING
TO WORK- WITH THE COMMITTEE. AS
WE MOVE FORWARD TO- JUST WOULD
ADD ONE THING- THE FOLLOW UP IN
A CHAIR BLOOM SAID COMMENTS AND
THAT IS- YOU KNOW THE QUARTER OF
BILLION DOLLARS SAID THAT SHE'S
REFERENCING. IN DECEMBER WE
CERTAINLY HAD A VERY WET
DECEMBER AND IF WE WOULD HAVE
HAD YOU KNOW THREE MONTHS OF
THAT WE WOULD HAVE A VERY
DIFFERENT SITUATION NOW BUT- I
THINK WE'RE PRETTY LATE IN THE
RAIN CYCLE AT THIS POINT TIME.
AND SO WE KNOW WE HAD TO WHICH
YOU KNOW VERY DRY- JANUARY AND
FEBRUARY- SO WITH IT SEEMS THAT.
WE WOULD WISH IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL IF WE COULD HAVE- BE A
BETTER A NOW. IN OTHER WORDS
UNLESS SOME SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
IT SEEMS LIKE WE OUGHT TO BE
ABLE TO START TO. TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE SITUATION IS WHICH IS
IT'S PRETTY SERIOUS AS WE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD SO. I'LL LEAVE THAT
THERE- I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
ROAD- THE DEPARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE- AND IT YOU KNOW IN THE
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING- THAT IS
OUT THERE IT'S IDENTIFIED THAT-
THERE IS JUST- INSUFFICIENT
CAPACITY- IN TERMS OF- BEING
ABLE TO ADMINISTER ALL THINGS WE
HAVE TO DO AND AS A RESULT. WE
DO HAVE- ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
EXTERNAL PARTNERSHIPS FOR
CONSULTING. AND IS THERE A- HIT
I'D LIKE TO HEAR WHY WE INVEST
THAT WAY AND NOT JUST BUILD UP
THE CAPACITY. AND I HAVEN'T
NUMBER QUESTIONS ALONG THIS
LINE. AND I GUESS I WOULD BUT
PREFACE THAT MALL BY SAYING
THIS. IT'S VERY POSSIBLE
CALIFORNIA IS NOT JUST IN A
DROUGHT BUT IS IN A PERIOD OF
CHARACTERIZATION. OF WHICH THE
DIFFERENCE BEING THAT DROUGHT
BEING TEMPORARY AND WE'RE GONNA
GET BACK TO QUOTE NORMAL. AND
THERE IS ASIAN BEING THIS IS THE
NORMAL. WHERE WHERE ARE RIGHT
NOW. IF THAT'S THE CASE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO
REALLY HAVE TO BEEF UP. ALL OF
OUR- WHEN IT COMES TO WATER AND
THAT MEANS ALL OF THESE AGENCIES
I THINK NEED TO BE MORE ROBUST-
AND BE ABLE TO HANDLE ALL OF
THIS AND SO- IS THIS THE TIME
FOR US TO BEGIN TO AN- INCREASE
CAPACITY. IN THESE AGENCIES-
BECAUSE MY EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN-
WHEN WE RELY ON OUTSIDE
CONSULTANTS- WE HAVE. SPENT A
FAIR AMOUNT OF MONEY BUT WE ALSO
LOSE ALL THE EXPERTISE- BECAUSE
THE CONSULTANTS CHANGE EXCEPT OR
A- THEY DON'T HAVE THE LONG TERM
INTEREST- NECESSARILY OF- TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THINGS WORK SO-
THAT WOULD BE- I'D- I'D LIKE TO
HEAR. A RESPONSE IF I COULD
ABOUT. THOUGHTS ON IN IN
INCREASING CAPACITY VERSUS-
HAVING A ONE TIME FUNDING GOING
FOR EXTERNAL PARTNERSHIPS. AND I
KNOW CAPACITY MEANS GOING FROM
ONE TIME FUNDING TO ONGOING
FUNDING- SO DEPARTMENT FOR. I
SEE IF I COULD. YES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAIR IF I MIGHT. AND IT
MAY TAKE A MINUTE FOR THIS IS
CHUCK BOND THERE'S THE VIDEO I
CAN SEE IT. BUT SO MY NAME'S
CHUCK BONHAM I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT LET ME ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION AND THEN ALSO
REFER- TO DIRECTOR NEMETH TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS SO
CALLED NEW NORMAL WE'RE SAYING.
SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT THREE
RESPONSES FROM MAY FIRST SIGN ME
UP THAT'S THE BUILDING AND THAT
IS AT THE CORE OF OUR SERVICE
BASED BUDGETING EXERCISE. WHICH
IN A COUPLE OF AGENDA ITEMS I'M
GOING TO GIVE A FULLER
PRESENTATION ABOUT. SECOND IN
THE CONTEXT OF DROUGHT THOUGH I
WOULD ARGUE. YOUR PAST
INVESTMENTS LAST YEAR. CAN YOUR
POTENTIAL INVESTMENT OF ANOTHER
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION TO OUR
DEPARTMENT. TAGS A NEXUS TO
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING HERE'S
HOW. YOU'VE PREVIOUSLY APPROVED
FUNDING FOR OUR DEPARTMENT TO
MODERNIZE OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
UNDER THE DROUGHT WE HAVE.
REDUCED OUR WATER USE ON OUR ARE
MORE EFFICIENT WATER USE ON OUR
OWN ECOLOGICAL RESERVES WE'VE
CONVERTED A LOT OF OUR DIESEL
PUMPS TO SOLAR ARRAYS. WE'VE
MODERNIZED OUR HATCHERIES AND
ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE FUTURE
PROOFING STATE ASSETS FOR THE
NEW NORMAL AND WHEN YOU TAKE A
ONE TIME CAPITAL INVESTMENT IN
YOU MODERNIZE OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
YOU'RE HELPING US BRIDGE OUR GAP
IN OUR SERVICE THAT'S A PROVEN
TACTIC THAT DELOITTE. ANALYZED
IN THE SERVICE BASED BUDGET
PROCESS OUR POINT. ASKED TO
CONSULTANTS. LET ME CLARIFY IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS PROPOSED
ADDITIONALLY FIRE DEPARTMENT. WE
VALUE PARTNERSHIPS AND THAT'S
WHAT WE MEAN REALLY I THINK MORE
THAN CONSULTANTS HERE ARE SOME
EXAMPLES. CURRENTLY WE'RE ENGAGE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RICE
COMMISSION AND THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. TO DO SOMETHING CALLED
REVERSE AUCTION BIDS. WORKING
WITH RICE GROWERS AND KIND OF
THE LOWEST BID STRUCTURE REVERSE
AUCTION TO HELP FUND THE WEDDING
UP OF SOME WEAPONS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FOR PACIFIC
FLYAWAY BENEFIT. ANOTHER EXAMPLE
OF PARTNERSHIP THE BIGGEST
CONTIGUOUS WETLANDS SOUTH OF THE
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN DELTA IS
OWN AND MANAGED BY A DISTRICT
CALLED GRASSLANDS ARE DISHING
DISTRICT. WE ARE USING SOME OF
THE CURRENT FUNDING YOU
SUPPORTED TO HELP MANAGE THEIR
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
BENEFIT OF BIRDS PACIFIC FLYWAY
. SO IT'S NOT THAT WE'RE SEEKING
TO SEND OUT CAPACITY THROUGH
CONSULTING AND IT'S MORE WE'RE
PROPOSING PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE
STRATEGIC AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING TOOLS
IDENTIFIED BY DELOITTE. THERE
FOUR WAYS YOU CAN BRIDGE OUR
CAPACITY GAP. YOU CAN INVEST IN
LABOR HOURS. YOU CAN LOOK AT ALL
OF OUR MANDATES AND DETERMINE
THAT SUMMER OLD NOT RELEVANT IT
COULD BE CHANGED THIRD YOU CAN
MAKE CAPITAL INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FOURTH YOU
COULD INCREASE YOUR PARTNERSHIP
FOR. SO THE DROUGHT FUNDING WE
SEE REALLY FOCUSES IN ON THE
ABILITY TO INVEST IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND EXPANDED OUR
PARTNERSHIPS WHICH BUILD
CAPACITY IN THE LONG RUN. I LOVE
A CHANCE TO COME BACK LATER
PERHAPS ONE ON ONE IF YOU HAVE
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS JUST ABOUT
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING AND
WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT THAT
MORE. THAN A COUPLE OF AGENDA
ITEMS IF I COULD CHAIR I'D LIKE
TO REFER TO DIRECTOR NEMETH.
JUST FOR A QUICK SNAPSHOT ON
THIS NEW NORMAL WHICH IS. YOU
KNOW IT'S KIND OF HYDROLOGICALLY
AND MEDIA ARE LOGICALLY
TERRIFYING AND I THINK THE MORE
WE TALK ABOUT IT. THE BETTER
EVERYONE WILL BE. YES PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING- ASSEMBLY MEN AND-
CHERRY BLOOM- THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
THERE I ON VIDEO- VERY QUICKLY
THE DEPARTMENT- IS DOING QUITE A
BIT OF WORK AS A RESULT OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR'S
FUNDING LAST YEAR TO IMPROVE OUR
ABILITY- FRANKLY TO UNDERSTAND
THE NEW NORMAL AND IT THE LEVEL
OF DESTRUCTION UP TO OUR WATER
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM SO A COUPLE OF
THE THINGS. OF THE ONE IS WE ARE
INVESTING IN IMPROVEMENTS TO
FORECASTING FROM THE DEPARTMENT
ACTUALLY THROUGH ITS FLOOD
MANAGEMENT- CANDLES FORECASTING-
BEFORE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THAT INFORMATION IS VERY
IMPORTANT- NOT JUST TO- D. W.
ARE THE STATE WATER PROJECT BUT
ALSO MANY MANY LOCAL WATER
DISTRICTS WHO DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO DO THAT KIND OF
TECHNICAL WORK THEMSELVES THEY
RELY ON THAT INFORMATION TO MAKE
THEIR OWN WATER MANAGEMENT
DECISIONS. IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
INFORMATION FOR THE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD OF LAST
YEAR- AS YOU KNOW AND THIS YEAR-
IN TERMS OF DROUGHT RESPONSE
THERE'S- AT ALL LIKELIHOOD WHEN
THE HYDROLOGY DOESN'T PROVIDE
ENOUGH WATER FOR ALL LEGITIMATE
WATER NEEDS OF TYPICALLY THE
WATER BOARD GOES THROUGH OUR A
CURTAILMENT PROCESS AND ALL OF
OUR FORECASTING INFORMATION
HELPS THE WATER BOARD ALSO MAKE
THOSE KINDS OF DETERMINATIONS SO
THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE'RE
DOING THIS YEAR FRANKLY IN REAL
TIME IS MOVING TOWARDS- ARIEL
SNOW OBSERVATION. SO IF YOU CAN
IMAGINE- YOU KNOW WE'VE RELIED
ON- BOTH OUR PHYSICAL- OUR OUR
PHYSICAL ASSESSMENT OF SNOWPACK
THAT'S THE THING THAT REALLY
ATTRACTS A LOT OF- SORT MEDIA
IT'S JUST VERY ACCESSIBLE WHERE
WE GO WITH THESE TOOLS AND. WE-
WE MEASURE THE SNOW WHY CON. THE
DEPARTMENT BEEN DOING THAT- FOR.
WE HAVE AN AND- A RESOURCE OF
DATA- I'M GOING BACK TO-
ESSENTIALLY A HUNDRED YEARS WERE
WERE- WE'RE MEASURING PHYSICALLY
AND ALL THE SAME LOCATION SO WE
UNDERSTAND SNOW PATTERN WITH
THIS YEAR- BUT WE ALSO- YOU SNOW
SENSORS- WHAT WE LEARNED LAST
YEAR- WHAT IS THAT THAT'S NOT
ENOUGH. I'M LAST YEAR WE HAD A
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGE- IN TERMS
OF UNDERSTANDING SNOW PACK AND-
WHAT IT WOULD TRANSLATE IN TERMS
OF- RUN OFF INTO RIVERS STREAMS
AND RESERVOIRS SO THIS YEAR
WE'VE ADDED- THIS ARIEL SNOW
OBSERVATORY. THAT CAN LOOK AT
THE SIERRA- ALL THE WAY TO THE
TOP- IN PARTICULAR WATERSHEDS
AND IT ENABLES US TO IDENTIFY-
HOUSE OF THE LINE FOR SNOW PACK
IS RETREATING FURTHER UPS UP THE
SLOPES OF THE SIERRA. AND WE CAN
DO THAT YOU KNOW EFFECTIVELY ON
A MONTHLY BASIS AND WE CAN ALSO
ANALYZE IN THREE METER GRIDS THE
SNOW WATER CONTENT DOWN TO ABOUT
AN INCH OR TWO. SO IT'S AN
AWESOME- A SET OF TOOLS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS DEPLOYING MORE
WIDELY THIS YEAR TO INTEGRATE
INTO OUR FORECASTING. OF THE
SECOND THING THAT WE'RE WORKING
ON WHICH IS GOING TO TAKE A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME TO THE
THREE YEARS OUT. BECAUSE IT'S
MORE COMPLEX IS INTEGRATING INTO
OUR MODELING SYSTEMS THAT SOIL
MOISTURE IN AMBIENT TEMPERATURES
SO THAT WE CAN ADEQUATELY
CAPTURE WHAT'S HAPPEN WHEN WE
HAVE THE SNOW PACK. WHAT'S THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT IT'S GOING TO
SEEP INTO THE GROUND AND
EVAPORATE AMIDST- INCREASING
AMBIENT TEMPERATURES AND FRANKLY
INCREASING LOW TEMPERATURES ON
AVERAGE AND WE'RE VERY MUCH.
SEEING THAT TREND- THAT WILL
REQUIRE A PEER REVIEW- THAT. IS
A REAL ADJUSTMENT TO IN HISTORY
STAND- CAL IS VERY MUCH THE- IN
THAT KIND OF WORK HAVE A LOT OF
PARKER IN THAT WORK. AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL OUR COLLEAGUES AT
THE U. S. BUREAU OF RECLAMATION
PARTICULARLY IN DENVER BUT ALSO-
AT. AND U. S. GEOLOGICAL SURVEY
SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE MAKING I
THINK THE NEXT SET OF
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE MAKING
WHICH IS GOING TO BE CRITICAL A
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT- SOME OF THE PRODUCT
CHALLENGES THAT. WE HAVE THE
OVERDRAFT IN THE VALLEY OF
CENTRAL VALLEY AND WHAT IT'S
GOING TO TAKE TO- REVERSE THAT
TREND- LAST YEAR- THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE PROVIDED THE DEPARTMENT.
WITH MONEY TO BUILD UPON SOME
IMPORTANT PILOT WORK THAT WE
STARTED- IN THE MERCED WATERSHED
IN THE TWELVE. WOLLEMI RIVER
WATER. WHERE WE GO S. HEADWATERS
TO FLOODPLAIN AND WE EVALUATE
THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE AND OTHER
RISKS ON. ON WATER QUALITY ON
THE IMPACTS OF WILDFIRE ON WATER
SYSTEMS ON FLOOD- AND HOW WE CAN
ACTUALLY MOVE THAT WATER- TO
MEET ALL OF THOSE KINDS OF.
CLIMATE DRIVEN INTENSE DEMANDS
BOB THE DEPARTMENT IS EXPANDING
THAT RESEARCH AND ANALYSIS TO
ALL WATERSHEDS THAT FEED INTO
THE CENTRAL VALLEY ALL OF THOSE
MAJOR WATERSHEDS. SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE BETTER INFORMATION- NOT
ONLY TO THE- GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES BUT ALSO
THE SURFACE WATER- WATER SUPPLY
DISTRICT IN THAT AREA. AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE IT AND- AND EVERYONE'S
REALLY GOING TO TAKE NOTE OF
THAT WATER. SCENE GOING TO BE A
VERY PROMINENT THEME IN OUR- A
CALIFORNIA WATER PLANTS WE ARE
JUST STARTING THE UPDATE. ON
THAT AS YOU KNOW THAT'S- THAT'S
MANDATED BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
BE UPDATED EVERY FIVE YEARS AND
YOU'LL SEE ALL THAT KIND OF
ADVANCE PLANNING WORK. ON THAT
HELPS US REALLY ADAPT THE NEW
NORMAL IT WILL BE HUGELY
IMPORTANT- AND WORKING- BETWEEN
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH OF THE
LEGISLATIVE. BRANCH TO REALLY
TARGET THOSE INVESTMENTS. THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO.
DESCRIBE THAT OR DETAIL. WELL
THANK YOU FOR YOU VERY MUCH THAT
I I'VE I APPRECIATE AS A SERIOUS
A TOP AS IT SITS WORTH IT TO
HAVE. A AUTHOR ANSWER WELL WITH
REGARDS TO THE NEW NORMAL YOU'RE
A DIRECTOR BOTTOM DID YOU WANT
TO ADD SOMETHING THERE I THINK
EMAIL THIS IS SECRETARY CRAWFORD
I WOULD SIMPLY SAY AND
APPRECIATE. CHUCKING CARLA'S YOU
KNOW A DETAILED RESPONSE AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL THE GOVERNOR'S
BEEN VERY LEAR WITH US WHICH IS
YOU KNOW WE ARE NOW LIVING IN A
NEW NORM ALL OF THESE CLIMATE
EXTREMES AND WE HAVE TO MOVE
FROM. DROUGHT RESPONSE TO
DROUGHT MANAGEMENT. WE CAN NO
LONGER DO WHAT WAS DONE IN
RECENT DECADES WAS THINK ABOUT
DROUGHT ISN'T AS AS AN EPISODE
THAT HAPPENS ONCE A DECADE OR
TWO. BUT RATHER- ESSENTIALLY-
CONSISTENT OR CONSISTENT THREAT-
ON OUR SYSTEMS AND THAT'S WHY
ALL OF THESE INVESTMENTS BOTH
THE FISH AND WILDLIFE NDW ARE
ARE SO IMPORTANT SO PLEASE KNOW.
THAT WE'RE NOT ONLY RESPONDING
TO THE ACUTE CONDITIONS IN THIS
DROUGHT BUT ESSENTIALLY
MODERNIZING OUR SYSTEMS TO
ADJUST. TO THIS NEW NORMAL.
THANK YOU I REALLY THAT.
CROWFOOT AN IF I COULD MAKE
THESE TO GENERAL COMMA AND ONE
IS THAT. DEMOCRACY IS JUST DON'T
NORMALLY DO A GOOD JOB OF
PLANNING AHEAD. YOU KNOW WE ARE
SO RESPONSIVE TO END UP AND THE
PUBLIC DOESN'T REALLY WANT TO
LOOK AHEAD. AND THE PUBLIC DOES
WANT TO HEAR YOU KNOW IF YOU DO
THIS HARD THING NOW THINGS WILL
BE BETTER FIFTEEN YEARS FROM NOW
AT THAT JUST DEMOCRACY DON'T DO
THAT VERY WELL. IN THOSE OF US
IN A POSITION OF LEADERSHIP HAVE
A RESPONSIBILITY TO TRY TO DO AS
MUCH OF THAT AS POSSIBLE SO I
APPRECIATE. THE GOVERNOR'S
POSITION AND I APPRECIATE YOU
COMMUNICATING THAT- THE- THE
SECOND THING THAT I'D LIKE TO
JUST POINT OUT AS YOU KNOW WE
TALK ABOUT THE NEW NORMAL AND-
THAT MEANS FOR EXAMPLE AS WE
TALK ABOUT CENTRAL VALLEY. BUT
IT'S NOT JUST IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THAT WE HAVE TO. WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO CHANGE HEARD OF
OUR PROJECTIONS IN TERMS OF WHAT
SUSTAINABLE BUT IN ADDITION TO
THAT WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE WE
WEREN'T SUSTAINABLE. BEFORE THE
NEW NORMAL. AND SO WE SORT OF
HAVE A DOUBLE THE DOUBLE PROJECT
AHEAD OF US WE NEEDED TO GET TO
SUSTAINABLE IF WE WOULD HAVE
STAYED IN THE OLD CONDITIONS AND
NOW WE HAVE EVEN THE MORE
EXTREME ISSUE OF. HAVING A NEW
NORMAL HIT US ON TOP OF THAT SO
THE URGENCY. IS- IT IS GOOD TO.
COME AND IT IS LIKE THAT KIDS
AND- OF THE LILIES ON THE THING
THAT. THE DID DID DID NEED THE
PUBLIC'S GONNA BE ON TOP OF THIS
REALLY FAST- IF THE DIRE PROJECT
PROJECTIONS- COME FORWARD. SO
WITH THAT I HAVE I'LL TRY TO
KEEP MY OTHER QUESTIONS VERY
BRIEF- THAT IS FOR DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES- SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE SMALL WATER
SUPPLIERS DROUGHT RELIEF
PROGRAM- I'M CONCERNED. THIS IS
A CLASSIC WE WANT SMALL OR WATER
SUPPLIERS ARE NORMALLY PROVIDING
DRINKING WATER- TO COMMUNITIES-
OF SMALL FARMS- RELY ON THIS.
AND- IT HE SEEMS THE L. GREAT
INVEST WOULD BE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY- HAVE ARE HAVE THE
RESOURCES. TO BE ABLE TO PREPARE
THEMSELVES FOR- THE NEW NORMAL
AND SO IS SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND OFF TO MEET. ALL OF THE
PROJECT APPLICANTS- APPLICATION
TO FULFILL ALL THE APPLICATIONS
CAN YOU GIVE ME A SCALE. THERE
ON THAT- WHERE ARE WE ON PROJECT
APPLICATIONS VERSUS- AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT WE HAVE. YEAH SO-
IN TERMS OF- PROJECT
APPLICATIONS SO WE HAVE- FUNDED
THE SEVENTY ONE PROJECTS IN
TOTAL- ABOUT A FIFTY OF THOSE
HAVE BEEN THROUGH THIS SMALL
PROGRAM- WE'RE GOING TO MAKE TWO
MORE ROUNDS OF GRANTS AND SO WE
WILL- I HAVE EXPENDED AND
AWARDED ALL THE DOLLARS THAT
WERE PART OF LAST YEAR'S
APPROPRIATION. OF THE SIXTY
MILLION MORE IN ADDITION- IT
SHOULD BE- CONSIDERED IN
COMBINATION WITH FUNDING THAT
THE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD ALSO PASSED IN TERMS OF-
RESPONDING TO SOME OF THESE-
SOME OF THESE SMALL WATER SYSTEM
ISSUES SO FOR EXAMPLE ASSEMBLY
MEN. I'M A LOT OF THE WORK THAT
WE DO- IN RELATIONSHIP- WITH THE
WATER BOARD IS FOCUSED ON- THAT
DOLLARS THROUGH THIS PROGRAM
COMPLIMENTING OR OR WORKING IN
TANDEM WITH DOLLARS THAT THE
WATER BOARD- HAS TO PUT TOWARDS
SMALL SYSTEM CONSOLIDATION FOR
EXAMPLE OR OTHER KINDS OF
DRINKING WATER FOCUSED- DROUGHT
RESILIENCE DOLLARS- INTERN. OF
WHAT WE THINK YOU KNOW THE
OVERALL- SORT OF APPETITE IS FOR
THOSE THAT FUNDING- I WILL BE
ABLE TO GIVE YOU WHAT A DOLLAR
ANSWERED TODAY BUT- AND WE CAN
COME BACK AND TALK A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THAT. BUT WE THE
DEPARTMENT PUT OUT. AN
ASSESSMENT OF- DROUGHT
VULNERABILITY FOR THESE SMALL
SYSTEMS AND WE EXPECT THAT ON
THE THROUGH THE FUNDING THAT'S
BEEN MADE AVAILABLE THAT WE
WILL. ESSENTIALLY BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS ABOUT THE TOP 10215% OF
THOSE IDENTIFIED THAT SMALL
SYSTEMS THROUGH THIS PROGRAM AND
THEN TOGETHER WITH THE WATER
BOARD- THERE'S PROBABLY IT'S
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE OF. A SMALL
AGENCIES THAT WE HAVE ALREADY
IDENTIFIED AS BEING. UNIQUELY
VULNERABLE TO DROUGHT CONDITIONS
SO WE THINK THAT THE SIXTY
MILLION- WILL ENABLE US TO GET.
A WHOLE LOT FURTHER- I WOULD
ALSO SAY THAT. THE DEPARTMENT IS
IMPLEMENTING- SENATE BILL FIVE
FIVE TWO WHICH IS PUTTING
TOGETHER A TASK FORCE- OF- NOT
JUST STATE AGENCIES BUT LOCAL
AGENCIES TO HELP DIRECT THE- D.
W. R. AND- ALSO SOME OF THE
WATER BOARD'S EFFORTS- TO. BE
RESPONSIVE TO THOSE- WATER
SUPPLY NEEDS- FOR THOSE WERE ALL
KINDS OF COMMUNITIES SO WE WOULD
EXPECT- GETTING THAT- TASK FORCE
UP AND GOING IT WAS- I'M STARTED
AT THE BEGINNING OF. JANUARY
ONE- WE EXPECT TO HAVE THAT- UP
AND GOING AND AS- A MECHANISM TO
HELP DIRECT FUTURE FUNDING- THAT
MIGHT BE. NEEDED IN THESE KINDS
OF COMMUNITY THANK YOU. I DON'T
WANT PUSH TO AND CHAIRMAN GOOD A
BLUE SAYS GOOD GREAT INTER
ACROSS SO- I I'VE THIS IS THIS
IS. THIS ISN'T A COMBINATION OF
A QUESTION THAT THEY'LL DO IT IN
THE FORM OF A COMMENT AND HOPE
THAT- OF AGENCY- OVERALL WILL
CONSIDER THIS BUT WE HAVE FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY THREE MILLION FOR
WATER AND WASTEWATER- NOW-
ARRANGE PAYMENT PROGRAM- AND I.
I JUST WONDER WHETHER SOME OF
THAT FOUR HUNDRED FORTY THREE
MILLION COULD INSTEAD BE USED IT
TO SUPPLEMENT. A SIXTY MILLION
GOING TO THE AND SMALL. DROUGHT
RELIEF. THAT ACTUALLY- TO
MILLION FOR WANTED SIXTY MILLION
FOR THE OTHER BUT- AND THE
REASON I SAY THAT IS THAT I FEEL
PRETTY CONFIDENT THAT THE LARGE-
PUMPERS ARE GOING TO BE PRETTY
SUCCESSFUL- AT- LOBBYING HERE
BUT IT'S GOING TO BE THE SMALL
WATER AGENCIES IN THE SMALL
FARMERS THAT ARE- THAT WE WERE
ALREADY SEEING STORIES OF YOU
KNOW IF THE COMMUNITIES OF YOU
KNOW THOUSAND FARM WORKERS AND-
THEY DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO. DEEP IN THERE WELL THEY
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES AND
THEY'RE LITERALLY OUT OF WATER I
WANT TO MAKE SURE SO I HOPE THAT
WE COULD INCREASE THE CAPACITY
THERE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND
WITH THAT I'LL JUST JUMP OVER
TO- TWO OTHER QUICK THINGS I
HOPE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF-
CONSERVATION- WHEN THEY'RE
AROUND LOOKING AT THE MULTI
BENEFIT RE PURPOSING OF LAND-
WOULD CONSIDER SOLAR FARMS ON
THAT LAND IF WE'RE GONNA FOLLOW.
FARMLAND WE HAVE HUGE ENERGY
NEEDS AND ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
WITH OUR ENERGY NEEDS IS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE PLACES- FOR YOU KNOW
FIGHT FINDING THE RIGHT AMOUNT
OF LAND- AND IN APPROPRIATE
PLACES AND SO I WOULD HOPE THAT
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD CAREFULLY
LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE THAT WOULD
BE A WIN WIN ON BOTH SIDES SOLAR
PANELS. AND FOLLOWING THE LAND-
TO TRY TO HELP US WITH- THE
WATER PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE AND
THEN- HE GIVEN HOW LONG THIS IS
GOOD IT THE RIDGES BOXES OF
BENTON AND DISK BEST PART A
CONVERSATION I JUST WOULD SAY I
AM VERY CONCERNED. ABOUT- SIGMA
AND THE- PUMPING THAT IS STILL
GOING ON AND SO. OF THESE THESE
PLACES AND WE'RE HAVING OVER
PUMPING AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE
HAVING- DISADVANTAGE COMMUNITIES
AND AT RISK COMMUNITIES
LITERALLY RUNNING OUT OF
DRINKING WATER. AND- IT IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT- WE HAVE TO
ACCELERATE- WHAT WE'RE DOING
WITH WITH CIGNA- SO THAT WE YOU
KNOW WE DON'T HAVE WITHOUT
THOUSAND DOMESTIC WELLS GO DRY
LAST YEAR- THAT. THIS COULD BE
MANY THOUSANDS MORE THAN THAT IF
THE NEW NORMAL CONTINUES- AND WE
DON'T PUT A PRIORITY ON THAT SO
I HOPE THAT WE CAN REALLY WE'D I
DID JUST THINK THAT. OF THE
TWENTY YEAR TIME FRAME AND SIGMA
IS- IS VERY GENEROUS AND TO WITH
THE NEW NORMAL OUT THERE IT'S
GOING TO BE A REAL PROBLEM FOR
DRINKING WATER SO- THEY'LL BE
MORE THINGS ON THAT THAT'LL
BRING UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE OF JEROBOAM.
YOU'RE WELCOME MISTER BENNETT-
LET'S JUST QUORUM AND THEN WILL
PURSUE WITH THE AS FRIEDMAN
SCHOOL. WELL HERE SENATE HERE
FRIEDMAN HERE QUESTION MULLIN.
PATTERSON RIVAS SMITH YES. THIS
FRIEDMAN THANK YOU I'LL BE HOME
AT I HAVE A COMMENT AND THEN I
HAVE A QUESTION ONE QUESTION AND
FOR I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING I
WANT TO ON PARTICULARLY THINK
THE SECRETARY WHO I THINK IT'S
REALLY BEEN A AMAZING LEADER IN
ALL THINGS RESOURCES AND IT'S
ALWAYS WONDERFUL TO SEE HIM
HERE- FIRST MY COMMENT IS THAT
WE I THINK THAT AS WE HAVE THESE
DISCUSSIONS WE REALLY DO NEED TO
ALWAYS REMEMBER. THAT WHAT WE'RE
SEEING NOW WITH CLIMATE. AND
WITH DROUGHT WHICH IS THE NEW
NORMAL IS THE RESULT OF HUMAN.
CAUSED CLIMATE CHANGE AND THAT'S
UNDENIABLE IF YOU BELIEVE IT ALL
IN SCIENCE IF YOU THINK THAT
NASA JPL- HAS ERA- IF YOU
BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
PUT. A ROVER ON MARS LITERALLY
ONE FOOT FROM WHERE THEY HAD
ORIGINALLY PLANNED YOU ALSO
SHOULD TRUST THEM WHEN THEY HAVE
THE MOST ADVANCED SENSING
EQUIPMENT IN THE WORLD. ALL
AROUND THIS PLANET AND SAY THAT
THIS IS WHAT'S HAPPENING BECAUSE
OF US HEATING UP OUR CLIMATE.
AND SO ALL OF THE ALL OF US.
WHAT'S HAPPENING AND SEE THE
COST THE FINANCIAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED. WITH THESE CHANGES.
NEEDS TO REMEMBER THAT EVERY
TIME THEY TALK ABOUT. ANYTHING
THAT WE DO FOR RESILIENCY OR TO
COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE BEING TOO
EXPENSIVE. BECAUSE THE COST OF
DOING NOTHING OR CONTINUING AS
WE ARE IT'S ASTRONOMICAL AND
IMPOSSIBLE TO CALCULATE SO
THAT'S MY COMMENT FIRST.
SECONDLY I WANT TO GO BACK TO
SOMETHING THAT THE SECRETARY I
THINK HE MAY HAVE REFERENCE WHEN
HE TALKED ABOUT LEGISLATION. MY
BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT AND SIX
OH SIX. WHICH MOVED US AWAY FROM
DROUGHT PLANNING INTO EFFICIENCY
AWAY FROM CONSERVATION AND MORE
TOWARDS INVESTING IN EFFICIENCY.
AND MY QUESTION IS WHETHER. THE
DO YOU HAVE YOU ARE IN THE STATE
BOARD'S NEEDS MORE RESOURCES TO
HELP. ROLL OUT THOSE EFFICIENCY
STANDARDS AND JUSTICE CHECKED
BACK TO SEE IF YOU BELIEVE THAT
WE NEED TO DO. WORK TO QUALIFY
THOSE EFFICIENCY STANDARDS AND
WHAT WE NEED TO DO HERE IN THIS
BUDGET TO. REALLY GIVE OUR
AGENCIES THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
AS EFFICIENT AS WE CAN SO THAT
WE'RE NOT CONSTANTLY IN THIS.
BILL OF TELLING EVERYBODY TO CUT
BACK WHEN IT FOR MORE EFFICIENT
WE HAVE MORE WHAT MORE WATER TO
USE FOR THE THINGS WE REALLY
NEED TO USE IT FOR. SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND WILL GO OFFLINE AND
WITH YOUR ANSWER. ASSEMBLY I
WANT TO TURN TO THEIR NAME AND
POSSIBLY EXACT OFFERS SO BACK IN
MOMENT BUT I JUST WANT TO. FIRST
OF ALL COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU
AN UNDERSCORE YOUR POINT ON
THANK YOU FOR CONNECTING THE
DOTS. ON ACCELERATING CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THIS DROUGHT- A
SCIENTIFIC STUDY FROM THE
INTERGOVERNMENTAL PANEL ON
CLIMATE CHANGE THE- SEMINAL BODY
OF INTERNATIONAL SCIENTISTS WAS
RELEASED EARLIER THIS WEEK AND
IT SHOWS THAT WE HAVE. A SMALL
AND NARROWING WINDOW OF
OPPORTUNITY. TO REDUCE THE
IMPACT OF CATASTROPHIC WHILE
WHILE. A CONSTRUCT A CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND THIS IS NOT ONLY AN
ISSUE OF SURVIVING AND THRIVING
ACROSS THE PLANET BUT IN
CALIFORNIA AND YOU CONNECT THE
DOTS SO EFFECTIVELY ON CLIMATE
CHANGE AND DROUGHT AND WILDFIRE
AND EXTREME HEAT. OR SEA LEVEL
RISE AND FLOOD SO THANK YOU FOR
DOING THAT. AND ALSO THANK YOU
FOR THE VISION AND THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN LEGISLATION.
CONSERVATION AS A WAY OF LIFE-
PRESS IN BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE
WORKING TO GET AWAY FROM HIS
TEMPORARY CHANGES IN WATER USE
AND MORE TOWARD. DURABLE WATER
EFFICIENCY. ULTIMATELY WHAT WE
WANT EVERYBODY TO DO IN
CALIFORNIA IS B. AS EFFICIENT
WITH WATER AS WE ARE WITH
ENERGY. YOU KNOW REGARDLESS OF
OUR POLITICAL IDEOLOGY NO ONE
WHATEVER YOU KNOW LEAVE THEIR
HOUSE WITH ALL OF THE LIGHTS ON
THAT'S BECOME- YOU KNOW-
INGRAINED IN ALL OF US TO BE
MORE ENERGY EFFICIENT. WE NEED
TO BECOME MORE WATER EFFICIENT
YOUR LEGISLATION IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THAT AND- DIRECTOR
NAME AT THE QUESTION OF. WHETHER
YOU IN THE WATER RESOURCE
DEPARTMENT WATERBOARDING MORE
RESOURCES. SURE- THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY- WE ARE ASSESSING-
RIGHT NOW FRANKLY AS WE-
CONTINUE TO PUT TOGETHER- OUR
OUTDOOR WATER USE EFFICIENCY
STANDARDS- AS YOU KNOW- THIS IS
A- COMPLEX ARE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT- WAS MEANT TO-
SET SOME STANDARDS- IN MULTIPLE
WAYS ONE FOR INDOOR. ONE FOR
OUTDOOR BUT THEN ALSO- PROVIDE
WATER DISTRICTS WITH MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY TO WORK BETWEEN
THOSE TO MEET AN OVERALL BUDGET-
SO A COUPLE OF THINGS- ONE- IN
TERMS OF THE OUTSOURCING- ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE LEARNING-
IS THAT. THERE ARE SOME- START
SIMILARITIES TO SIGMA IN THAT-
WE DO HAVE A NEED TO COLLECT
DATA ACTUALLY AS WE GO THAT
INFORMS WATER USE EFFICIENCY
EFFICIENCY STRATEGIES SO YOU
WILL SEE IN- ARE. BUDGET FOR- A
FUNDING FOR CONSERVATION
PROGRAMS WE DO HAVE A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR- THAT SORT OF SET
ASIDE IF YOU WILL FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO ADDITIONAL
MAPPING- TO REALLY UNDERSTAND-
ON SOME OF THESE LANDSCAPE
ISSUES PARTICULARLY AS IT
PERTAINS TO. COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL USES WHERE I THINK WE
THINK THERE'S SOME REAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO BRING DOWN- OR
TO IMPROVE WATER USE EFFICIENCY-
ACROSS THE BOARD IN CALIFORNIA
AND THAT'S INFORMATION THAT WE
YOU KNOW WE- NEED TO DEVELOP- AS
WE MOVE ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING
NEW STANDARDS- THAT MAY IN FACT-
TRIGGERING NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ONCE WE GET MORE
DEEPLY INTO- INTO ACTUAL
IMPLEMENTATION- BOTH OF OUR-
APPROACHES I THINK TOWARDS.
INDOOR ARE INDOOR
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE PROVIDED
TO THE LEGISLATURE BUT ARMOR
OUTDOOR RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH WE
WILL PROVIDE TO THE WATER BOARD
HAVE KIND OF A TO A STUDENT THAT
TWO STEP APPROACH ONE IS AN
INTERIM EFFICIENCIES. AND THE
TWENTY FIVE AND THEN A NEW
STANDARD. IN TWENTY THIRTY TO
HELP WATER- REALLY MAKE A PRETTY
SICK. EVENTS TO OPTUM ALL
THERE'S MORE EFFICIENT- AS WE
SAY- THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL. TO
ACT IMPLEMENT THOSE- NEW
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS- WE WILL
CERTAINLY BE BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE WITH THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF FOR THOSE RESPONSES
AND- LET ME ALSO CHIMED IN ON
THE- IMPORTANCE OF- ADDRESSING
THE- CLIMATE CRISIS SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE CHANGE THE NAME OF THAT
SUBCOMMITTEE LAST YEAR TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S UNDERSTOOD THAT-
ADDRESSING THE CLIMATE CRISIS
REALLY IS REALLY- THE CORE
BUSINESS. OF OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE. I'M SORRY I
COULDN'T AGREE MORE- WITH THE
COMMENTS FROM LAST SECTOR
CROWFOOT AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
FRIEDMAN WILL MOVE NOW TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH QUESTIONS
. THANK YOU CHAIR BLOOM IT'LL BE
UP FOR SECRETARY CROWFOOT AND
IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION.
THERE'S HARDLY ANY MONEY IN THIS
BUDGET FOR STORAGE IN A WHAT
POINT EVER GOING TO RECOGNIZE
THAT WARMER TEMPERATURES
CONTRIBUTING TO THE LOW SNOW
PACK. IN MORE PROLONGED DRY
STRETCHES. WHEN IS THE STATE.
GOING TO DO FOR MORE FOR WATER
STORAGE AND CAPTURE WHEN WE DO
HAVE WHETHER YEARS. YEAH THANK
YOU FOR THAT POINT AND LET ME BE. WE RECOGNIZE THAT THAT MORE
SMART STORAGE IS IMPORTANT I'M
BY SMART STORAGE CERTAINLY WE
MEAN UNDERGROUND STORAGE WE KNOW
WE HAVE A LOT OF CAPACITY IN OUR
UNDERGROUND AQUIFERS. WE NEED TO
DO MORE TO GET DEBATE THESE
WINTER RAINS THIS WINTER STORM
WHAT FLOWS UNDERGROUND. AND AS I
MENTIONED WE HAVE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSED IN THIS BUDGET
TO HELP LOCAL AGENCIES DO THAT
WE HAVE MILLIONS OF ACRE FEET OF
CAPACITY OUR IN OUR UNDERGROUND
WATER BASINS AND WE KNOW WE NEED
TO RECHARGE THEM TO IMPLEMENT-
SIGMA SO. BUT MY PERSPECTIVE
THIS IS AN ABSOLUTE NO BRAINER.
IT'S MORE COMPLICATED THAN A LOT
OF PEOPLE REALIZE BECAUSE WE
NEED TO ENABLE OR THE LOCALS
NEED TO DO THIS RECHARGE IN WAYS
THAT DON'T. IMPAIR WATER RIGHTS
OF OTHER WATER USERS SO THERE IS
A WATER RIGHT PROCESS THAT CAN
BE COMPLICATED BUT- THE WATER
BOARD'S DONE A GREAT JOB WITH
THE W. R. OF TRYING TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS. I IN
ADDITION TO THE FUNDING SO
UNDERGROUND STORAGE IS IMPORTANT
AS IT IS REGIONAL STORAGE ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY GREATER LOS
ANGELES. IS A LOT MORE DROUGHT
RESILIENT THAN IT WAS TWENTY
YEARS AGO IS THEY INVESTED IN
REGIONAL SERVICE STORAGE I
INCLUDING DIAMOND VALLEY LAKE I
BELIEVE WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT
REGIONAL RESERVOIR IN THAT AREA
SO. WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT. THOSE REGIONAL PROJECT
AND THEN ALSO I WOULD MENTION
THAT WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
ALLOCATING OVER TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FROM PROPOSITION ONE THE
STORE AT THAT WATER BOND IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN FOUR SEVEN LARGE
PROJECTS FOR UNDERGROUND THREE
SURFACE STORAGE PROJECTS. TO GET
THOSE BELT- THAT BEING SAID YOU
KNOW WE HAVE FIFTEEN HUNDRED
RESERVOIRS ACROSS THE STATE. AND
A LOT OF THE YOU KNOW THE BEST
OPPORTUNITIES TO ACTUALLY
CAPTURE WATER AND SURFACE
STORAGE ARE ALREADY UTILIZED. SO
WE DO WHAT WE DO THINK THERE'S.
TARGETED SORT OF SURGICAL- X. OF
SERVICE STORAGE THAT CAN DO. WE
REALLY NEED TO MAKE A BIG THRUST
ON RECHARGING OUR UNDERGROUND
STORAGE ABOUT COULD AGREE WITH
YOU MORE THAT NEEDS TO BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IN IN A NEW TWIST TALKED ON
PROP ONE FROM TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN IS EIGHT YEARS THAT
WE'VE BEEN. WAITING FOR THAT
FUNDING TO GO OUT. IS IT MEANT
TO NINE IS THE TEMPERATE FLATS
FOR THE SITE PROJECT STILL
MOVING FORWARD OR IS THERE ANY
MOVEMENT. A CONNECT TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS SET ASIDE.
RESERVE MONEY GO TO THE- WATER
COMMISSION TO FUND THOSE
PROJECTS. GREAT QUESTION SO BOTH
OF THOSE PROJECTS WERE INITIALLY
IDENTIFIED IN UNIVERSITY EIGHT
PROJECTS THAT WOULD GET FUNDED
BY EIGHT THIS PROP ONE FUNDING
THIS SET ASIDE FOR STORAGE- THE
TEMPERANCE FLAT PROJECT.
DEVELOPERS THE PROJECT ALREADY
ULTIMATELY WITHDREW THEIR
APPLICATION FOR THOSE PUBLIC
FUNDS- IT IN SHORT BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK THEY FOUND A
FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE PATHWAY
FORWARD FOR THE TEMPERANCE FLAT.
DAM AND RESERVOIR THIS SITES
PROJECT IS VERY MUCH MOVING
FORWARD AND PASSED AN IMPORTANT
MILESTONE WITH THE WATER I
COMMISSION JUST A FEW MONTHS
AGO- THAT IDENTIFIED OR
VALIDATED THE FINANCIAL
FEASIBILITY OF THAT PROJECT.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT PROP
ONE WHICH WAS THE GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND THAT WAS PASSED
BY THE LEGISLATURE THAT WENT TO
THE VOTERS- WAS VERY VERY
SPECIFIC I'M FAIRLY DIRECTIVE IN
TERMS OF THE PROCESS THAT NEEDED
TO BE TAKEN FOR. OUR THAT PUBLIC
FUNDING ON THE SURFACE STORAGE
PROJECTS AND IT'S TAKEN A LONG
TIME- WE RECOGNIZE THAT IT IT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN IT'S QUICK YOU
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD AS QUICKLY
AS THEY CAN. AT THE SAME TIME-
OBVIOUSLY PROJECTS LIKE SITES
NEED TO YOU NEED TO GO THROUGH
THE VARIOUS ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESS SEE SO JUST KNOW THAT
THE NEW SEVEN MINISTRATION IS
WORKING TO GET THESE SEVEN
PROJECTS THIS PUBLIC FUNDING AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. AND TO
SUPPORT THEIR EFFORTS TO
ACTUALLY- YOU KNOW GET COMPLETED
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE IT'S A
PRIORITY. OTHER THAT TWO HUNDRED
MILE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR. LET'S CUT CALL IT A
RESERVE ACCOUNT FOR RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT SURE WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO GET WITH IT CAN
BE USED FOR IT THE- FRANK KERN
WALKING THE KERN CANAL. OR ANY
OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE THE BIG
CONCERN OF MINE IS WATER STORAGE
AND WATER CONVEYANCE. AND OF MY
BIG FEARS WE HAVE AN EARTHQUAKE
IN THE I COULD DOCKED IN THE
DEBATE SYSTEM IS BROKEN WE'RE
pWE SAVED KEEP YOUR WATER FOR
YOUR OWN HOUSE FOR A FEW DAYS
NOW IT'S A WEEK NOW IT'S A
COUPLE WEEKS. WE'RE GONNA BE
WITHOUT WATER FOR MONTHS IF NOT
A YEARS. IT CAN ANY OF THAT THE
ONLY BE USED FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS. FOR OUR- WATER
CONVEYANCE SYSTEM IN THE STATE.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK THE SHORT
ANSWER IS THIS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR CONTINGENCY IS.
AND FOR DISCUSSION BETWEEN THE
NEW TO MINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE SO I THINK YOU KNOW
ALL IDEAS WITHIN THE WATER
RESILIENCE PORTFOLIO ARE ARE ARE
ON THE TABLE AND AS A CHAIR
BLOOM NOTED. I THINK THERE'S AN
INTEREST IN YOUR COMMITTEE TO
UNDERSTAND OUR APPROACH IN THE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE I
WILL SAY DEPARTMENT WATER
RESOURCES DIRECTOR NAME IS TEAM
IS VERY CLEAR WITH US WE HAVE TO
MODERNIZE AND REHABILITATE. OUR
BACKBONE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
WATER CONVEYANCE WHILE REGION'S
CAN YOU KNOW BUILT THEIR OWN
RESILIENCE WE STILL NEED AS
BACKBONE CONVEYANCE AND THAT'S
WHY WE CONTINUE TO ADVANCE. THE
HOTTER NICE CONVEYANCE THROUGH
THE DELTA UP TO PROTECT AGAINST
EARTHQUAKE RISK AND SEA LEVEL
RISE AND IT'S ALSO WHY I AM VERY
PROUD OF THE FIRST TIME THE
STATE IS FUNDING REGIONAL
CONVEYANCE BROUGHT JACKSON LIKE
FRYING CURRENT CANAL LIKE DELTA
MENDOTA CANAL. LIKE THE STATE
AQUA DOCKED. THE CALIFORNIA
AQUEDUCT SOUL I THINK WE WOULD
AGREE WITH YOU THAT I CONTINUED
INVESTMENT IS NEEDED IN THOSE
CONVEYANCE FACILITIES TO ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY RESILIENCE
TO EARTHQUAKE RESILIENT.
EARTHQUAKES AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE YOU SECOND CRAWFORD. NOW I
HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
- WOULD BE- BCP WE INTERNET TEN
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
CONVEYANCE AND HABITAT AGREEMENT
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE. HOW MANY
OF THOSE PROJECTS WERE COMPLETED
WITH THAT TEN MILLION DOLLARS. A
LITTLE OVER A DOZEN AND WE CAN
GET YOU A SPECIFIC LIST OF THAT
RANGE IN SCALE. IN SOME CASES A
MUCH LARGER SCALE LIKE I
MENTIONED WITH GRASSLANDS
IRRIGATION DISTRICT. AND IN
OTHER CASES YOU KNOW SMALLER ON
OUR OWN DEPARTMENT PROPERTIES
BUT WE'D BE GLAD TO FOLLOW UP
WITH THE SPECIFIC LESSEN IT AND
HOW MANY PROJECTS UNIT
ANTICIPATE WITH A NEW FUNDING OF
FIFTEEN POINT FOUR MILLION FOR.
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. SAME
ARE- I WOULDN'T SAY DOUBLE BUT
CERTAINLY THE SAME AND WE'RE THE
SAME PROCESS OF TRYING TO
IDENTIFY- SPECIFICALLY WHERE
WOULD MAKE THOSE INVESTMENTS SO
WE HAVE A FAST TURN AROUND
BECAUSE WE'RE FIGHTING THE
IMMEDIACY OF WHAT WILL BE THIS
COMING. IN A DRY SUMMER AND
BUILDING THAT LONG TERM
RESILIENCY THE COMMITTEE'S BEEN
DISCUSSING THIS ONE. OKAY THANK
WON'T TAKE UP MUCH FOR TRAFFIC.
THANK YOU- OF FOR A DIRECTOR SO
BACK- THE A- AND RELATING TO THE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR GROUNDWATER CLEANUP
AND RECYCLED WATER HOW DO YOU
PLAN TO ALLOCATE BETWEEN THESE
TWO PROGRAMS AT ALL- JUST GIVE
YOU MY THOUGHTS ON ON THAT THAT-
GIVEN THAT. THAT THE GROUNDWATER
CLEANUP CAN BE FUNDED THROUGH
MULTIPLE PROGRAMSAND- WATER
DISTRICTS ARE REQUESTING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR RECYCLED
WATER TO ENSURE THEIR LONG TERM
DROUGHT RESILIENCY. IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO
ENSURE THAT OF THE LION'S SHARE
OF THAT MONEY BE AVAILABLE FOR
RECYCLED WATER PROJECTS GIVEN
THAT YOU CAN GO ELSEWHERE FOR-
OF THE OTHER. PRIORITY. FOUR LET
ME- LET ME- JUST- LOOK AT MY
NOTES HERE- YEAH WE ARE IN THE
BILL IN IN THE PROCESS OF
GETTING STAKEHOLDER INPUT ON HOW
TO ALLOCATE- AT BETWEEN THOSE
TWO VERY HIGH LEVEL AND
PRIORITIES. AND OUR INITIAL
STUFF LEVEL DISCUSSIONS WITH KEY
STAKEHOLDERS- REGIONAL WATER
BOARD STAFF THE DEPARTMENT TOXIC
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL STAFF
AND I WERE ALL HELD WITHIN THE
LAST MONTH SO WE ARE- CONTINUE
TO GATHER INFORMATION AND WE
HOPE TO HAVE OUR DRAFT
RECOMMENDATIONS PUBLISHED IN
APRIL SO IN A MONTH OR SO- FOR
AND THERE WILL BE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. AND THEN THE
WORK WILL SOON THEREAFTER
CONSIDER ITS RECOMMENDATIONS ON
A REGULARLY SCHEDULED BOARD
MEETING- SO WE WILL WE WILL LOOK
AT THE AVAILABILITY OF THE FREE
SPENDING INCLUDING NON
REPAIRABLE FUNDING- FROM THE
VILLAGE OF- FEDERAL MONEY FROM
THE STATE REVOLVING FUNDS BOTH
THE DRINKING WATER AND- AND-
CLEAN WATER FUNDS- AND CONSIDER
WHAT THE ALTERNATIVE SOURCES OF
FUNDING FOR BOTH OF THOSE
PROJECTS ARE BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FOR YOUR THOUGHTS ON- HOW
THAT WHAT HOW THAT MONEY SHOULD
BE ALLOCATED GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND DON'T GO AWAY
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO-
ISSUE NUMBER TWO- AT THIS TIME
AND THE- YOU'LL BE MAKING THAT
PRESENTATION. AND WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. OKAY- SO I AM. WE
HAVE- WE HAVE ONE- REQUEST TIME
UNDER THE BETA PROGRAM FUNDING-
ADDING WHICH IS CONVERSION OF
WHAT IS NOW CONTRACT UP FUNDING
TO POSITION FORTY SO WE ARE
REQUESTING THE AUTHORITY TO
CONVERT. APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN EXISTING
GENERAL FUND CONTRACTING
RESOURCES TO PERSONAL SERVICES
FOR A TOTAL OF FIVE PERMANENT
POSITIONS WITHIN OUR DIVISION OF
WATER RIGHTS TO SUPPORT HIGH
PART PRIORITY BIG DELTA WATER.
WATER CONTROL PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION WORK- AND THIS
ALSO INCLUDES- BUT I THINK ANY
WOMAN TATIAN THAT IS RELATED TO
CLIMATE CHANGE DROUGHT AND WATER
RIGHTS ADMINISTRATION- IN THE
BAY DELTA SEVEN THIS WOULD AND I
THINK- DOVETAIL NICELY WITH SOME
OF THE- CONCEPTS THAT- THE
COMMITTEE HEALTH SUBCOMMITTEE
HAS BEEN DISCUSSING TODAY- THAT-
THE OTHER- SPEAKERS HAVE HAVE
MENTIONED. OF THIS WOULD REALLY
AB WE REALLY APPRECIATED THE
LEVEL OF CONTRACT FUNDING THAT
WE'VE- OBTAINED IN THE PAST BUT
WE REALLY NEED TO CONVERT THAT
INTO A PERMANENT CAPACITY FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE. AFRIKAANS
WORK INTO INTO REAL REAL
IMPLEMENTATION SO IT WOULD IT
WOULD ENABLE US TO MOVE FROM
GENERAL PLANNING PLANNING
PROCESS THESE. TWO
IMPLEMENTATION IN THE DELTA
ITSELF AND IT'S TWENTY FIVE.
TRIBUTARIES HI THESE ARE LONG
TERM EFFORTS. THAT WILL REQUIRE
STAFF TO OVERSEE IMPLEMENTATION
INCLUDING MONITORING ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT COMPLIANCE REVIEW.
ASSESSED ASSESSMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF WORKS OVER THE
LONG FROM OVER THE LONG RUN- IT
WILL ALSO INCLUDE- THIS ARE
VITAL TO STOP HAS ALSO BEEN VERY
ACTIVE DURING THE- EXISTING. IN
DEVELOPING. AND FORMULATING THE
APPROPRIATE WAY TO IMPLEMENT
CURTAILMENTS- THAT- HAVE BEEN
AND MAY BE NECESSARY IN THE
FUTURE THAT IS ALSO VERY
RESOURCE INTENSIVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY. WITH THE
AFFECTED COMMUNITIES AND THAT WE
HAVE THE MOST EQUITABLE
CURTAILMENT SYSTEM POSSIBLE-
THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE LAW.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OR PROVIDE MORE
DETAILS. THANK YOU- DO WE HAVE A
- ANY INFORMATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT. THIS
IS CRYSTAL STRUCTURE WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I HAVE
NOTHING TO ADD BUT HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
ELTA L. A- PLEASE. THANK YOU
AGAIN RACHEL EHLERS WITH THE L.
A. O. NOW WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL HERE- YOU KNOW TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT'S POINT
TO INCREASING DEPARTMENT
CAPACITY RATHER THAN RELYING ON
EXTERNAL RESOURCES. MAKES SENSE
WHEN THERE'S AN ONGOING NEED
WHICH WE SEE HERE I THINK THE
MAIN POINT WE WANTED TO RAISE
HERE AS HIGHLIGHTED ON PAGE
THIRTY FIVE OF YOUR AGENDA IS
JUST. THIS IS A PRETTY IMPORTANT
EFFORT FOR THE STATE ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THAT ENVIRONMENTAL
DEGRADATION IN THE DELTA. AS
WELL AS UNCERTAINTY FOR WATER
USERS SO. IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME
COMING WE GOTTA GET IT DONE- BUT
WE'RE JUST MOVING FORWARD BUT
JUST PROBING WHETHER THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL STEPS THE STATE AND
THE LEGISLATURE CAN TAKE TO HELP
EXPEDITE PROGRESS WHETHER THAT'S
ADDITIONAL FUNDING OR ADDITIONAL
STATUTORY CHANGES- BUT- BUT WHAT
IS WHAT IS IT WHAT WE NEED TO DO
THAT. TO MAKE FORWARD PROGRESS
ON THIS IMPORTANT EFFORT. THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IF THERE'S
NO QUESTIONS WILL MOVE DIRECTLY
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE- AND-
IS SELECTIVELY PRESENTING ON
THAT AS WELL.
SO THIS- THIS THIS LAST MATTER-
HAS TO DO WITH- IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE WATER AND WASTEWATER A
RICH- PAYMENT PROGRAM. AND- WE
WERE I AM VERY PROUD OF OUR
ABILITY TO GET OUT- WITH THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PAYMENT OF DRINKING WATER EVERY
RICHEST IT WAS REALLY- HUGE HUGE
EFFORT AND TOOK REDIRECTION OF A
NUMBER OF OUR STAFF TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE MET THE DEADLINE OF
GETTING THIS MONEY OUT IN A
TIMELY WAY TO WATER SYSTEMS TO
ADDRESS. I'M A REGISTERED- CAN
THE REGS THAT THAT IN THAT
INDIVIDUAL CUSTOMERS ACCRUED
DURING OF THE CUPBOARD AND
VIRGIN CITY. SO WE ACTUALLY
HAVE- THAT PROCESS OF GETTING
DRINKING WATER. SYSTEM DOLLARS
OUT TO GO TO A WE ARE JUST. YEAH
IT'S NOW IN THE FINAL STAGES OF
HAVING THAT CHECKS BEING CUT AND
PAID OUT. SO WE HAVE CLOSED THE
APPLICATION PROCESS FOR THE
DRINKING WATER PROGRAM- AND- WE
HAVE NOW TURNED TO- PROVIDING.
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR WASTEWATER
SYSTEMS TO APPLY FOR THE FUNDS
FOR THE SAME PURPOSES TO- TO PAY
OFF A RELIGIOUS CUSTOMER
REGISTERED ACCRUED DURING THE-
TO STOP. TO SET MY MIND. WE'VE
DONE OUR BEST TO MAKE THE
APPLICATION PROCESS STREAM
STREAMLINED THE BASIC MINIMUM
THAT WE CAN USE. WE'VE USED
WE'VE DONE A LOT OF OUTREACH
WORKING WITH TRADE ASSOCIATIONS
TO MAKE SURE THAT- EVERYBODY WHO
IS ELIGIBLE ALL SYSTEMS THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE. ARE AWARE OF THE
PROGRAM AND THE DOLLARS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AND WE ARE WORKING
AND- WE ARE WORKING DILIGENTLY
TO- YEP TO COMPLETE THE WASTE
WATER- PORTION OF THIS PROGRAM.
HOW WE ARE OUR ESTIMATE IS THAT
TIME IN ADDITION TO THE THREE
HUNDRED- AND ONE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WE WERE GETTING OUT TO THE
DRINKING WATER SYSTEM. THAT
THERE ARE PROBABLY ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY I'M- MILLION
AN ESTIMATED- WASTE WATER
DOLLARS- THAT COULD DOLLARS THAT
GO TO WASTE WATER SYSTEMS. AND
THAT THAT WILL LEAVE- SOME FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ON THE TABLE THAT WILL
HAVE NOT WILL NOT BE ACCOUNTED
FOR AT THE MOMENT. AND SO WE
WILL. BE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND PUTTING
TOGETHER IDEAS FOR- WHAT WHAT TO
DO WITH THOSE ADDITIONAL FUNDS-
WITH WITH RESPECT TO THE-
DRINKING WATER. SYSTEMS I DID
WANT TO NOTE. THAT TIME- THAT.
THE NUMBER OF WATER SET UP.
ACCOUNTED APPROXIMATELY 80% OF
THE HOUSEHOLD STATEWIDE THAT
WERE SERVED BY PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS SO WE THINK THAT WE DID
WE WERE ABLE TO REACH. ARE
SIGNIFICANT MAJORITY OF.
CUSTOMERS AND HOSPITALS THAT
WERE AFFECTED AND HAVE BUILT UP-
A RELIGIOUS AND WE WERE ABLE TO
THROUGH PROVIDING DOLLARS TO
THEIR WATER SYSTEMS TO GET FROM
THE RELIEF THAT WAS THE POINT OF
THIS- WITH APPROPRIATED- PART OF
MONEY. SO I WILL LEAVE IT AT
THAT AND TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
. THANK YOU- LMAO COMMENTS ON
THIS. NO COMMENTS ON THIS
OVERSIGHT ITEM THANKS MISTER
CHECK HELD- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I ASSUME- NOTHING TO
HAVE. THAT'S CORRECT AND HAVING
INTERNET QUESTIONS. DRASTIC
THANK YOU- WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
FOR. SECRETARY ROSS IS STILL
WITH US I AM. I'VE LEARNED A LOT
THIS MORNING- I AM HERE- TO
PRESENT TWO ITEMS AS I LOOK AT
THE AGENDA HERE THE FIRST ONE IS
ON THE FARM TO SCHOOL GRANT
PROGRAM I'M CITY IF THEY IS
REQUESTING THIRTY TWO MILLION.
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A GENERAL FUND
AND SIXTEEN POSITIONS TO EXPAND
THE CALIFORNIA FARM TO SCHOOL
INCUBATOR GRANT PROGRAM- JUST
LAST WEEK WE RELEASED OF WHAT
THE FIRST PARTNERED THE PLANTING
THE SEED FARM TO SCHOOL BUT NOT
FOR SIX SOUTH WHICH HAS HAD A
VERY ROBUST STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
OVER THE LAST YEAR AND A VERY
IMPRESSIVE ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
TO REALLY FOCUS ON HOW DO WE
IMPROVE THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF OUR STUDENTS- IMPROVE
THE ACQUISITION OF LOCALLY GROWN
HEALTHY FRESH CALIFORNIA PRODUCE
PRODUCTS AND PROVIDE EXPERIENCE
A LEARNING FOR STUDENTS TO
REALLY HELP CONNECT THEM TO
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTION.
NUTRITION AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
HOW OVER ONE BILLION SCHOOL
MALES WERE SIR. LAST YEAR AND
THEY'RE OFTEN PROVIDING TOO MANY
OF OUR STUDENTS THE ONLY MALE
BUT THEY MAY HAVE IN THAT DAY.
AND CLEARLY THERE'S MUCH WE CAN
DO TO IMPROVE THE NUTRITION AND
THE HEALTH OF THOSE STUDENTS AS
WELL AS THEIR EDUCATIONAL
LEARNING. CAPACITY IT'S VITAL
THAT WE ENSURE THAT IN A STATE
THAT GROWS- TWO THIRDS OF THE
FRESH FRUITS VEGETABLES AND TREE
NUTS. ALL THE HEALTHY THINGS
THAT WE HAVE WE'VE GOT WE'VE
ALREADY GOT MALCOLM'S PLEDGE
PROGRAM BUT THERE'S SO MANY
PRODUCTS THAT WE CAN REALLY
EXPAND. AND IMPROVE ECONOMIC
RETURNS TO OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
BY DOING MORE INSTITUTIONAL
ACQUISITION. OF CALIFORNIA GROWN
PRODUCTS. THIS IS THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IT'S IT THEN IT
TO THE THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS AGREED TO IN THE
BUDGET. WE BELIEVE THAT THROUGH
THE STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT THAT
WE HAVE BEEN DOING FOR THE LAST
TWO YEARS IN PARTICULAR. AND THE
SUCCESS OF THE FIRST ROUND OF
FUNDING THAT WE HAD. THAT THERE
IS DEFINITELY DEMAND FOR THE US
I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT WITH MADE
BY THIS LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR WITH THE BUDGET WAS
APPROVED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. HAVE A THREE YEAR
PROGRAM TO INVEST FOUR HUNDRED
AND FFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
IMPROVE OUR KITCHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF MAKING THIS
WHOLE- PART SCHOOL PROGRAM. WORK
TO OFFER MORE FROM SCRATCH
COOKING TO OUR STUDENTS. SO AS
WE FOCUS ON. OUR CLIMATE SMART.
SYSTEM WHICH STARTS ON THE FARM
AND CARRY THROUGH TO WHAT WE'RE
OFFERING IN OUR SCHOOLS I'M FOR
MAKING THIS REQUEST WITH REGARD
TO THE SIXTEEN POSITIONS THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING. WE THINK THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT WAY OF LINKING
SCHOOL NUTRITION DIRECTORS WHO
ARE LOOKING FOR THE PRODUCT IT'S
GROWN LOCALLY. AND ART FARMS WE
WANT TO PUT A SPECIAL FOCUS ON
OUR SMALL FARMS. ON OUR FARMS
UNDERSERVED HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED FARMERS WHO MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO MAKE THOSE DIRECT
LINKAGES AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THESE REGIONAL NAVIGATORS. WELL
REALLY ENSURE THE SUCCESS OF
THIS PROGRAM AND WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ON
THAT ONE. OR TWO THE SECOND ITEM
THAT I WAS ASKED TO PRESENT ON-
THIS IS FUNDING FOR OUR STATE
ORGANIC PROGRAM THIS IS. THIS
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THAT YOU'RE
MOVING ON TO. I'M I KNOW HAVE
THE ATTENDED FRONT OF ME. IT I
CAN TAKE LIKE THIS NUMBER FOUR.
BUT LET'S LET'S. AND AT A- HI-
ISSUE THE ONE THAT YOU JUST
SPOKE THAT- LET'S MAKE SURE-
THAT WEEK- FIRST ALL ASK A L. A.
O. AND TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO- ADD ANY COMMENTS THEY MIGHT
HAVE. QUESTION GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FRANK MENACE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M
A SECRETARY ROSS MENTIONED THIS
PROPOSAL HAS TWO COMPONENTS
FIRST THIRTY MILLION ONE TIME
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD ASSIST
SCHOOLS IN IMPLEMENTING FARMERS
GO PRACTICES I'M SUCH AS
PREPARING LOCALLY GROWN FOODS IN
PROVIDING EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES- THIS WOULD BRING
THE TOTAL AMOUNT FOR GRANTS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR TO SIXTY MILLION
SINCE THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET PACKAGE PROVIDED THIRTY
MILLION IN BOTH THE CURRENT YEAR
AND BUDGET YEAR SO THERE IS
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM GOING
INTO THE BUDGET YEAR BASED ON
ACTIONS TAKEN LAST YEAR. AND
THEN SECOND THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES TWENTY EIGHT MILLION
ONGOING TO HIRE SIXTEEN
ADDITIONAL STAFF THAT WOULD
SUPPORT- FARM TO SCHOOL EFFORTS-
SO FOR THE GRANT TO RECOMMEND
REJECTING ADDITIONAL FUNDING-
SAID THAT AND ARE NOW IF THIS IS
UNCLEAR WHETHER THERE WILL BE
I'M DEMAND FOR THIS AMOUNT THE
CURRENT YEAR GRANT CYCLE THIRTY
MILLION I'M HASN'T BEEN AWARDED
GET SO WE'RE ON SHARE ON ON WHAT
THAT DEMAND FOR THAT WILL BE.
INTERESTING AND THE DEPARTMENTS
I'M FIRST GRANT CYCLE IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- DEPARTMENT
AVAILABLE NINE MILLION AND
GRANTS BUT ONLY RECEIVED- TWELVE
MILLION IN TOTAL REQUEST I'M OF
THE NOTE THAT INCREASING THE
PROGRAM- FROM EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION TO SIXTY MILLION OVER A
THREE YEAR PERIOD THE RELATIVELY
LARGE INCREASE FOR- A RECENTLY
ESTABLISHED PROGRAM- WE ALSO
NOTE THAT THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET- INCLUDE SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT REPORT ON PROGRAM
OUTCOMES FOR THE GRANT PROGRAM
BY JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
I'M FINE IT IS PREMATURE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING-
WITHOUT THAT- PROGRAMMATIC
OUTCOME INFORMATION EVER FOR THE
ADDITIONAL STAFF WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE- APPROVE
THE REGIONAL STAFF WE FIND THAT
THE- THE STAFF COULD INCREASE
THE ADOPTION OF FARMERS WILL
PRACTICES STATEWIDE BY BETTER
TAILING I'M SUPPORT TO THE
SCHOOL TO HAVE COMMON- REGIONAL
INFORMATION BARRIERS THAT HAVE
TO TAKE ANY COMMENTS. AND
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. GOOD MORNING WITH THE
AREA OF FINANCE NO BUT I'M HAPPY
HELP IN ANY QUESTION. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND YOU HAVE A
QUESTION IT INDIA EIGHT LAP L.
A. O. N. ASK THE QUESTION THOSE
WONDER OF SECRETARY ROSS
COULDN'T ADDRESS THE ISSUE WITH
THE AFTER FUNDING IT'S A 6100%
INCREASE. AND WE HAVE NO OF
MATRIX TO SEE IF THE SYSTEM
MEANS IS A WORK. AFTER RAFI. YES
THANK YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS METHOD APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION- WE ARE VERY CONFIDENT
BASED ON THE EXTENSIVE OUTREACH
THAT WE HAVE DONE FOR TWO YEARS
NOW. WE HAVE EXPANDED
CONSIDERABLY THE FARM TO SCHOOL
NETWORK. WE HAVE HOSTED OVER
THREE HUNDRED NEW STAKEHOLDERS
EXPRESSING THEIR INTEREST IN
THIS PROGRAM. WE KNOW THAT
ESPECIALLY COMING OUT OF A
PANDEMIC. WE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF IMPROVING THE
NUTRITIONAL OFFERING TO
STUDENTS. AND WE FIND THAT BASED
ON EXTENSIVE SURVEY WORK.
INTERVIEW WORK. AND BACK AND
BACK HUNDREDS OF MEETINGS THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH UR ADVISER
COMMITTEE AND DIFFERENT WORK
GROUPS STRINGS. THAT PEOPLE ARE
VERY ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM. AND THE CAPACITY TO
MAKE PROGRESS AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE HAVE BUILT AND FROM DAY
ONE A VERY ROBUST. EVALUATION
PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE THAT WE NOW
AS WE GET MORE AND MORE
EXPERIENCE SOMETHING ELSE. WE
KNOW WHAT'S WORKING AND WE CAN
BUILD ON THOSE SUCCESSES. WE
HAVE BEEN TOLD ACROSS THE
NATION. ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE PUT
TOGETHER AND THE DESIGN OF OUR
EVALUATION PROGRAM AND WE FEEL
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE AT LEAST
THREE YEARS. TO GIVE YOU THE
KIND OF DATA THAT YOU NEED. THAT
IT WOULD BE ONE OF THE FIRST AND
IN THE NATION TO DO THIS KIND OF
AN EVALUATION. AND WHAT HELPED
LEAD OTHER STATES AND OTHER
SCHOOL SYSTEMS. AND DOING
SIMILAR PROGRAMS. FIFTY IT GOING
TO YOU THREE YEARS OF GIVE US A
MATRIX OF HIS WORK IN IN YOUR
ONE YOU CAN'T OUT MATRIX EVERY
YEAR THAT THAT'S GOING FORWARD
TO A GOOD ME ASK FOR A LITTLE
BIT AT A TIME MAYBE FIVE MILLION
TEN MILLION INSTEAD OF. THIRTY
I'M SORRY. I MEANT I MEANT THAT
WE FEEL THREE YEARS OF DATA IS
NECESSARY BUT WE WILL HAVE
PROGRESS AND MILESTONES CHECK
INS THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE- INFORMATION TO YOU. AS
AS WE FINISH EACH YEAR. THANK
YOU. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
THE THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
ITS CURRENT YEAR THAT
APPLICATION PROCESS- WILL OPEN
LATER THIS MONTH AND SO WILL
WILL HAVE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
ON WHAT THE UPTAKE WAS AT THE
GRANT PROGRAM FOR THIS YEAR.
OKAY AS WE MOVE THROUGH BETWEEN
NOW MAY WE'LL GET MORE UPDATES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION AND ALLOW ME TO
FOLLOW UP- WITH RESPECT TO THE
FARM TO SCHOOL REPORT THAT WAS
RELEASED- RECENTLY THAT AT AND
THAT MAKES A NUMBER OF POLICY
SUGGESTIONS AND RECOMMENDATIONS.
FOR METRICS TO HELP DETERMINE
SUCCESS- WHAT AGAIN IS THE UP A
PLAN FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF THE-
CHANGES DEFINITIONS ARE METRICS
THAT ARE RECOMMENDED IN THE
REPORT. YES I'M IT THAT'S A VERY
GOOD RECORD WE ARE IN FACT GOING
THROUGH OUR EVALUATION AND
ANALYSIS OF THAT REPORT SOME OF
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
ALREADY WORKS IN PROGRESS- I'M
VISITS COME OUT WE'VE HAD ENOUGH
INPUT FROM THE DEVICE YOU GROUPS
AND IT'S HELPED IN THE DESIGN OF
THIS YEAR'S GRANT PROGRAM. SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO IMPLEMENTING AS
MANY OF THESE AS WE POSSIBLY CAN
IN THE NEXT ROUND AND THEN OVER
SUBSEQUENT ROUNDS AS WELL. GREAT
THANK YOU- AND THEN- WITH
RESPECT TO THE FARM TO COMMUNITY
FOOD HUBS OF PROGRAM- THAT-
FOLLOWS MY LEGISLATION FROM LAST
YEAR- WHAT IS THE TIMELINE FOR
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE PILOT PROGRAM- INCLUDING
CUT. STAFFING FORMATION OF THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE PUBLIC
OUTREACH REGARDING GRANT
AVAILABILITY. INFORMATIONAL
WORKSHOPS FOR INTERESTED
APPLICATIONS AND APPLICATION
REVIEW AND DISBURSEMENT. YES SO
WE ARE IN THE EARLY STAGES OF
THAT WE- DO YOU NEED TO ADD-
STAFF FOR THAT PROGRAM AND WITH
AUTHORIZATION- FOR STAFFING WE
WILL BE ABLE TO PUT THAT PROGRAM
TOGETHER BUT WE REALLY IF THIS
IS GOING TO BE A VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM- OR NOT ONLY OUR FARM TO
SCHOOL PROGRAM BUT JUST OUR
LOCAL FOOD SYSTEM RESILIENCY AND
SELF. WE KNOW THAT WE WANT TO DO
EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
WE WILL BE STAFFED UP IN JULY IT
WERE USING SOME TEMPORARY
STAFFING NOW ON TO DO SOME
EVALUATIONS WE WILL FORM THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE NO LATER THAN
AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO
THAT WE CAN BEGIN OUR PUBLIC
OUTREACH. PROCESS AND HAVE
INFORMATIONAL WORKSHOPS WITH
APPLICATION RUBIO AND
DISBURSEMENT BAILABLE BY
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN ESTABLISHING THIS
PROGRAM OR EAGER TO GET TO WORK
ON IT WE KNOW IT'S AN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT THAT WILL HELP MAKE
FARM TO SCHOOL EVEN MORE
SUCCESSFUL BUT ALSO BRING SOME
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES GOOD RESILIENCY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS IN THAT
REGARD- SANTA ANA NOW WE CAN
MOVE ON TO- ISSUES NUMBER FIVE
SECRETARY ROSS THE OTHER ISSUE
YOU'RE GOING TO ADDRESS. YES
THIS IS OUR STATE ORGANIC
PROGRAM AND IT'S FOR EDUCATION
AND HELP REACH- THE DEPARTMENT
IS REQUESTING FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND. DOLLARS
FROM THE AGRICULTURAL FUND FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
AND SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND I'M GOING
WITH ONE ADDITIONAL PERMANENT
POSITION- THEY THE GROWTH IN OUR
STATE ORGANIC PROGRAM AND THE
INTEREST IN OUR CONSUMERS OF A
QUERY MARC ORGANIC. PRODUCE AND
PRODUCTS IS GROWING AT A VERY
SIGNIFICANT RATE- WE HAVE AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ARE WE
CALLING MARCO CAPTIVITY YEP.
THREE CALIFORNIA ORGANIC POLICY
THE ADVISER. THEY HAVE BEEN VERY
AND IN WHAT AT ALL WAY THAT CAN
USE OF OUR- STREAM. TO BE ABLE
BETTER SUPPORT PEOPLE WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN GETTING INTO THE
ORGANIC- GROWING SECTOR OUR
AREN'T SUPPORTING THOSE THAT ARE
IN IT NOW. BY PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WE NOW HAVE
A GARDEN ORGANIC INSTITUTE AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
THROUGH COOPERATIVE EXTENSION
THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
CONTRIBUTOR TO THIS KIND OF
WORK. AND SO THIS WOULD BE TO
SUPPORT A STAFF MEMBER THAT
WOULD BE FOCUSING ON OUTREACH
EDUCATION- PUTTING TOGETHER
CONFERENCES AND WORKSHOPS AND
PARTNERING VERY CLOSELY WITH
BOTH THE CSU. AT THE UC SYSTEM
REALLY EXPAND THE UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT IT TAKES TO GROW
ORGANICALLY AND. TO DO THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS. THANK
YOU- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
HELLO. THANK YOU MINUTES AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
HAVE NO COMMENTS OR CONCERNS ON
THIS PROPOSAL I TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT. REVERE A FINANCE
I KNOW COMMENTS AT THE TIME THAT
HAPPENED TO QUESTIONS AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WITH THAT
WILL MOVE ON TO- ISSUE NUMBER
SIX. DIRECTOR BONHAM YOU'RE BACK
. LAST YEAR. THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME ON ISSUE SIX I'D LIKE TO DO
TWO THINGS WITH THIS ISSUE I'D
LIKE TO START WITH AN UPDATE
ABOUT SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
AND THEN I'D LIKE TO TURN TO THE
FOR BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS IN
TODAY'S AGENDA THAT HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP TO THE BUDGETING
EXERCISE. THAT BE GREAT THANK
YOU. SO HERE'S THE END OF UPDATE
REPORT DYNAMIC. AND BY WAY OF
REFRESHER FOR THOSE DIALING AND
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING IS- A
MANAGEMENT EXERCISE. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDING CHAIR
BLOOM INSTRUCTED US TO DO ABOUT
TWO YEARS AGO. WE HIRED A
NATIONALLY KNOWN FIRM DELOITTE
AND THEY TOOK US TO AN OPEN
TRANSPARENT PROCESS IT INVOLVED
ALL OF OUR- UNITY'S MANY OF YOUR
BUDGET AND LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP STAFF DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND IT ENDED UP WITH THE
REPORT. PROVIDED THAT TO THE
LEGILATURE AND THAT THE TOOL
THE TACTIC THE MANAGEMENT
ASSESSMENT LOOKS AT AND ENTITIES
LEVEL OF CURRENT SERVICE YOU DO
THAT BY ANALYZING ALL THE TASKS
YEAH IT'S A T. DOES IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE ITS CORE SERVICE AREAS
SO WE ANALYZED APPROXIMATELY
THREE THOUSAND TASKS CONDUCTED
BY OUR EMPLOYEES CAN YOU BATES
STATIC YOU BENCHMARK AGAINST
THAT LABOR HOURS. AND IT GIVES
YOU AN ESTIMATE OF YOUR LEVEL OF
PERFORMANCE OR SERVICE. AND THEN
YOU DO AN ANALYSIS CREEK
COMPARES TO YOUR MISSION YOUR
ASSIGNMENT YOUR MANDATE YOUR
EXPECTATION. AND YOU CAN
ILLUSTRATE A GAP BETWEEN CURRENT
SERVICE AND EXPECTED MISSION
LEVEL SERVICE WE DID THAT.
BOTTOM LINE CONCLUSION I THINK
IS WELL KNOWN NOW WE'VE BEEN
TRANSPARENT ABOUT IT. WE HAVE
ACROSS THE BOARD EIGHT SERVICE
AREAS WHERE GENERALIZING WE ARE
CURRENT STAFFING IS SUFFICIENT
TO ACCOMPLISH ABOUT 35% OF THE
MISSION LEVEL ASSIGNMENTS WE'VE
RECEIVED OVER THE DECADES. THE
GAP IS GREATEST IN OUR AREAS OF
SPECIES AND HABITAT CONSERVATION
AND PERMITTING AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION. THERE ARE WAYS YOU
CAN FILL THE GAP I MENTIONED
THAT EARLIER IN MY CONVERSATION
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENEFITS.
SO WHAT WE JUST DID AT THE
REQUEST OF YOUR STAFF IS SEND
OVER- POWER POINT PRESENTATION
THE SERIES OF SLIDES. THAT SHOW
THIS DATA. AND A REFRESHED. TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DATA. HE HAD A
COUPLE OF THE SLIDES- SHOWED
THAT DATA COMPARED IN NINETEEN.
TWENTY DATA AND WHAT WE DO
ANNUALLY NOW IS WE GO BACK TO
THAT TASK REGISTRY OF THREE
THOUSAND. WE GO BACK TO THE SAME
MANAGERS AND SUPERVISORS WE ASK
THEM TO RE FILL OUT THE ESTIMATE
OF LABOR HOURS RELATIVE TO THE
TASK. WE'RE RUNNING WE TRAILER
YEAR SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE LOOKING
AT YOU KNOW DATA A YEAR OLD. WE
HAVE A STAFF PERSON WHOSE SOLE
JOB IS MANAGING THIS INFORMATION
ON OUR AUTOMATED SYSTEM ENGAGING
WITH OUR ENTERPRISE SOME OF THE
THINGS WE SEE IN THE COMPARATIVE
ANALYSIS. IS THAT- WE SEE MOSTLY
UP A SLATE- DECREASE IN OUR
CURRENT SERVICE LEVELS SO A
SLIGHT INCREASE IN THE GAS. WE
THINK THAT COULD BE ATTRIBUTABLE
JUST TO THE UNIQUENESS OF THE
LAST YEAR AROUND THE PANDEMIC.
THE GAP ACTUALLY GREW THE MOST
IN OUR EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
SERVICE AREA AND WE THINK THAT
IT IS IN PART POTENTIALLY
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE OUTREACH
WORK WE DO REST ON VOLUNTEERS.
AND KIND OF THE ABILITY TO USE A
VOLUNTEER BASE LAST YEAR WAS
COMPROMISED OR CHALLENGE BECAUSE
OF THE DYNAMICS AROUND THE
PANDEMIC. WE DO SEE A SLIGHT
INCREASE MEETING OUR SERVICE
LEVEL WENT UP. AND THE GAP
SHRUNK A TOUCH OVER THE SPECIES
HABITAT CONSERVATION WORLD AND
NOT MY ANALYSIS MY GUESS ON THAT
WILL BE. IMPOSED IN PART IT'S
YOUR LEADERSHIP AROUND- THE
THIRTY NINE POSITIONS FOR OUR
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT PROGRAM.
THAT REALLY SHOWS A CHANGE IN
THAT COLUMN. WE WANT TO DO WHAT
YOU'RE STAFF ASKS IN THE AGENDA
SO I WILL MAKE THAT A
COMMITMENT. INSTEAD OF SENDING
YOU EACH YEAR BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS AND WAITING TO SEE IF
YOU'D LIKE THE SERVICE BUT IT
BUDGET ANALYSIS RELATIVE EACH
PROPOSAL WILL JUST MAKE. SENDING
THAT S. B. B. DATA ARE STANDARD
PRACTICE FOR ALL PROPOSALS WE
BRING TO YOU. THE LAST THINGS I
WANT TO SAY ON SERVICE BASED
BUDGET BEFORE TURNING TO THE FOR
BCPS IN THE AGENDA. STATE LOT OF
CONVERSATION OCCURS REGULARLY
I'VE LIVED THROUGH IT LIKE THE
CHAIR AND MANY OF THE MEMBERS
HAVE. WHAT ABOUT ALL THE
POTENTIAL FOR FEE INCREASES AT
THE DEPARTMENT TO DEAL WITH THE
GAP BETWEEN CURRENT IN MISSION.
I JUST WANT TO. BE REALISTIC
HERE. THE DEPARTMENT DEALS WITH
SUNDRIDGE OF FEES ACROSS OUR
WORK LOAD. LICENSES ENTITLEMENTS
SPORTFISHING ALL THE WAY TO FEES
AROUND. WE'LL BARRELS TO FIND
ARTICLES SPILL RESPONSE WE KEEP
TRACK OF THEM HAVE DONE DOZENS
OF FEE INCREASES OVER THE LAST
FIVE OR SIX YEARS. MY ASSESSMENT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
FEED OUR WY OUT OF D.
SUSTAINABILITY DYNAMIC THEY
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN MISSION AND
CURRENT SERVICE LEVEL
PARTICULARLY IN THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES CONSERVATION REALM WHERE
THE GAP IS THE LARGEST THERE'S
NOT A USER FEE BASED AND OFTEN A
USER FEE BASED CAN'T TOLERATE
THE EXPONENTIAL INCREASE OF FEES
NECESSARY TO KIND OF MATCH UP
MISSION AND CURRENT. SO I THINK
THIS PROCESS IS REALLY
REPEATEDLY ILLUSTRATED. TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM PERMANENTLY
REQUIRES THINKING THROUGH WHAT'S
AN ADDITIVE LONG RUN SUSTAINABLE
FUND SOURCE TO DEAL WITH SOME OF
THESE MISMATCHES. AND ON THAT
FRONT CHAD NO- YOUR ATTENTION
AND YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THE SPACE
SIDE I JUST GOT A WITH KNOWLEDGE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
CONTINUING TO EVALUATE
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING OPTIONS TO
ADDRESS WHAT WE SEE IS THE GAP
AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE ALSO
CONTINUING TO EXPLORE WAYS TO
ADVANCE EFFICIENCIES AND
MAXIMIZE EXISTING RESOURCES WHAT
HAPPENED LAST YEAR ON THE THIRTY
NINE POSITIONS FOR OUR
ENDANGERED SPECIES PROGRAM. AND
THIS YEAR'S PROPOSAL TO MAKE
THOSE POSITIONS PERMANENT IT'S
AN ILLUSTRATION AS ARE SOME OF
THE ONE TIME INVESTMENTS INTO
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE BUT I REALIZE
WE HAVE NOT YET COME WITH THE
TROOPS SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
OPTION ACROSS A LOT OF OUR
SERVICE AREAS I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT BECAUSE I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA ASK ME IN A MOMENT.
BUT BECAUSE THERE AND ASK THE
PLEASURE THE CHAIR IF YOU LIKE
ME TO TURN TO THE FOR BCPS. THAT
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED IN THIS ISSUE
OR PAUSE FOR QUESTIONS MORE
BROADLY ABOUT SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING. NOT YOU CAN GO HEAD
MOVE ON THE CHAIRMAN'S STEPPED
OUT SO I'M GOING TO TAKE OVER SO
GO AHEAD AND CONTINUE WITH THE
ITEMS. THANK YOU NUMBER SMITH
SO. THEN IN THE AGENDA THERE ARE
FOUR IDENTIFIED BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS WITH THE NEXUS TO
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING. LET ME
EXPLAIN THE NEXUS AND EACH OF
THE PROPOSALS FIRST WE HAVE-
PROPOSAL FOR UP MODEST SOME
MIGHT THINK OF EIGHT HUNDRED TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO COMPLETE A
TECHNOLOGY PROJECT TO GET MORE
PEOPLE OUTDOORS AND THIS IS TO
EARN OUR FISHING LICENSES FROM
CALENDAR YEAR. TWO EIGHT THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE DAYS FROM
DATE OF PURCHASE OPPORTUNITIES
SO HISTORICALLY YOU BY YOUR
FISHING LICENSE IN THE MOMENT
YOU BUY IT IT'S VALID FOR
WHATEVER THE REMAINDER OF THE
YEAR IT'S SO IF YOU BUY IT IN
JANUARY GET A FULL YEAR. IF YOU
DECIDE TO GO FISHING IN OCTOBER
AND YOU BY THEN YOU ONLY GET A
COUPLE OF MONTHS. WE BELIEVE
THAT IF WE TRANSITION THAT TO. A
PROGRAM THAT OTHER STATES ARE
DOING FROM THE MOMENT YOU
PURCHASE IT THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE DAYS BOARD IT'S VALID WE
MAY SEE MORE PEOPLE BUY LICENSES
WHICH WILL INCREASE OUR REVENUE.
IN THE LONG RUN. THE OTHER
CHANGE WITHIN THIS PROPOSAL IS-
TO GIVE A DISCOUNT TO SENIORS
FOR THEIR FISHING LICENSES NOW
THIS ASPECT COULD AFFECT OUR
REVENUE IN THE LONG RUN BECAUSE
WE DON'T YET KNOW. WHAT SENIORS
WILL AVAIL THEMSELVES OF THE
DISCOUNT BUT IT'S EQUALLY TRUE
THAT DISCOUNT COULD MOTIVATE
MORE SENIORS WHICH I THINK IS TO
FIND A SIXTY FIVE OR OLDER SO A
LOT OF GOOD FISHING TIME. FROM
SIXTY FIVE ON. THE BOTTOM MORE
LICENSES AND WE COULD SEE MORE
REVENUE. SO THE EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND ALLOWS US TO COMPLETE
SOME OF THE BACK OF THE HOUSE
TECHNOLOGY WORK AND GET THIS
AUTOMATED WITHIN OUR LICENSE
AUTOMATION SYSTEM. WHAT'S THE
NEXUS THE SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING. THIS IS ACTUALLY
MANDATED BY THE BILL ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT SEVENTEEN SO THIS IS
A PROPOSAL TO FUND THE
DEPARTMENT WORK TO AVOID AN
UNFUNDED MANDATE AND THE SERVICE
BASED BUDGETING PROCESS
IDENTIFIED LEGISLATIVE MANDATES
BOOK THE LACK OF FUNDING TO
MATCH WITH THE MANDATE. A REASON
WHY WE GET A GAP SALUTE THE
NEXUS IN MY VIEW IS FINDING A
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE SAME IS TRUE
FOR THE NEXT BUDGET PROPOSAL ON
THIS ISSUE. SENATE BILL EIGHTY
CREATES A NEW ENDEAVOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO AVARIETY OF
THINGS IMPROVE OUR SAMPLING OF
CRAB. IT A CERTAIN TIME OF YEAR.
HE ENGAGE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO CREATE AN OF
THIS ARRAY SHOULD PROGRAM WHICH
MEANS THAT CRABBERS CAN
POTENTIALLY- CLEAN THE CRAP IN A
WAY THAT REDUCES THE POTENTIAL
RISK AROUND TOXINS IN THE- NUTS
OF THE CRAB. YET STILL SAIL CELL
FOR PUBLIC CONSUMPTION BUT
BEATING THE CRAP. SO THIS IS A
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE THE REQUEST
IS FOR LIMITED FUNDING. OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF GENERAL FUND AND
THREE POSITIONS PERMANENTLY TO
CREATE THE ADMINISTRATION
SAMPLING AND OTHER CRAP PROGRAM
ELEMENTS. MANY OF THAT THAT'S
WHY GENERAL FUND AND WHY NOT FEE
COMMERCIAL FISHING. WE TRIED TO
FEED COMMERCIAL FISHING AT A
RATE THAT RECEIVED A LOT OF
RESISTANCE THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION ULTIMATELY
ADOPTED US ALL THE INCREASE. BUT
THERE ARE PUBLIC BENEFITS IN
THIS SPACE AS WELL. YEAH
DESTABILISE PORTS ACROSS OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES ON THE COAST
CLIMATE CHANGE IS INCREASING THE
RICH TO OUR VALUABLE COMMERCIAL
FISHERIES WERE FACING JOB LOSSES
AND REGIONAL DEPRESSION. AND IF
WE DON'T AKE THE KIND OF STEPS
REQUIRED BY THIS BILL IT'S
POSSIBLE WE'LL SEE A REDUCTION
OF GOOD CLEAN SEAFOOD ON THE
PLATES FOR CALIFORNIANS TO ENJOY
SO THERE'S A LOT OF BROAD PUBLIC
BENEFIT FROM THIS PROGRAM.
THAT'S THE SECOND PROPOSAL THE
NEXUS IS AVOIDED UNFUNDED MONDAY
MANDATE BY ENSURING THE FUNDING
TO IMPLEMENT LEGISLATIVE
MANDATES. THIRD PROPOSAL- WHALES
AND TURTLES. SO I THINK MOST
PEOPLE REALIZE NOW WE HAVE A
CONFLUENCE OF. A STANDING EVENTS
HAPPENING IN THE OCEAN. SO
WARMING CLIMATE WARMING OCEAN
CONDITIONS IS AFFECTING LARGE
MARINE MAMMALS MIGRATION PATHS
ALONG OUR COAST HAS THAT
MIGRATION PATH IS ALTERING THESE
MAMMALS ARE COMING MORE
REGULARLY IN CONTACT WITH. CRAB
FISHING GEAR THAT'S PLACED IN
THE OCEAN OUR CRAB FISHERY IS
ONE OF OUR MOST REMAINING
LUCRATIVE FISHERIES FOR OUR HARD
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN IN THE
OCEAN. NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
TREATS IS NOT ICONIC EVENT ON
THE CALENDAR TO EAT DUNGENESS
CRAB. OUR STATE WILL BE THE
FIRST STATE WE'RE WELL ON THE
WAY. TO GET A FEDERAL PERMIT
UNDER THE FEDERAL ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT TO GIVE REGULATORY
STABILITY. TO OUR HARDWORKING
COMMERCIAL FISHING MEN AND WOMEN
IN THE OCEAN WHILE ALSO BEING
THE FIRST STATE TO CREATE A REAL
TIME SCIENCE DRIVEN PROGRAM. TO
REDUCE ENTANGLEMENTS OF WHALES
AND SEA TURTLES IN OUR FISHERY
GEAR IN THE OCEAN IT'S CUTTING
EDGE NO ONE ELSE IS DOING THIS.
THE PROPOSAL SIX FUNDING- TO
IMPLEMENT THAT PROGRAM- AND THEN
LASTLY THE FOURTH ITEM. IS A
MODERNIZATION. OF OUR RESEARCH
FULLY. IN HERE WE HAVE ABOUT
THIRTY VESSELS THAT ARE NON LAW
ENFORCEMENT VESSELS THAT WE USE
AS THE BACKBONE FOR OUR
SCIENTIFIC MONITORING AROUND THE
STATE. IN WITHIN THE SAN JOAQUIN
SACRAMENTO DELTA ESTUARY
ENVIRONMENT WE TOOK A LOOK AT
OUR AGING VESSEL FLEET WE LOOKED
AT TWELVE VESSELS AND OF THOSE
TWELVE WE CONCLUDED FIVE OF THEM
ARE AT MOST RISK OF JUST THEY'RE
TAKING TOO MUCH MAINTENANCE
TIME. THEY'RE OUTDATED AND WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO RETIRE THEM SO
THESE VESSELS SUPPORT THE
MONITORING- OF- LEGALLY
PROTECTED AND RECREATIONAL USE
FISH. THEY RELATE TO ABOUT FIFTY
THREE SURVEYS WE DO- EACH YEAR
ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND MONITORING
TRIPS WE NEED TO MODERNIZE THIS
PART OF OUR SCIENTIFIC VESSEL
FLEET. SO THE WHALE PROPOSAL IS
NEXUS TO SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
IS OUR GREATEST GAP IS
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SPECIES
CONSERVATION. BROUGHT BENEFIT TO
SAVING WHALES IN THE OCEAN AND
ENSURING A SUSTAINABLE DUNGEON
THIS CRAP FISHERY IN CALIFORNIA
. THE VESSEL PROPOSAL THE FOURTH
IT'S NEXUS TO SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING YOU CAN MAKE A ONE
TIME CAPITAL INVESTMENT IN YOUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND GAINED GREAT
EFFICIENCIES AND CONVERTING YOUR
GAP- MEMBER SMITH I CAN'T SEE
WHETHER CHAIR BLOOMS COME BACK
BUT THAT'S MY STORY ON ISSUE SIX
AND I'M BACK. IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS I'M BACK- AND I DO
HAVE A QUESTION- THAT'S ABOUT
SPECIES CONSERVATION BUT FIRST I
WANT TO COMMEND YOU ON- REALLY
EMBRACING SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING- I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT I KNOW THE COMMITTEE
APPRECIATE THAT- AND I THINK IT-
WE'RE SEEING FROM YOUR REPORTS.
THAT IT'S REALLY PAYING OFF AND
THE EXTREMELY BENEFICIAL SO MY
QUESTION ABOUT SPECIES
CONSERVATION HAS TO DO WITH
BLACK BEARS SOME. DO WE KNOW HOW
MANY THERE ARE IN THE STATE. HAS
THERE BEEN A STATEWIDE COUNTLESS
SO WHEN WAS THAT- HOW DO YOU
PERFORMANCE STATEWIDE COUNT AND
HOW DO YOU DETERMINE THE
APPROPRIATE NUMBER OF HUNTING
PERMITS FOR THE SPECIES. WE DO
ALL OF THOSE THINGS USING BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE. AND DECADES
OF LEADERSHIP AND WILDLIFE
MANAGEMENT. SO WE HAVE AN
ESTIMATE. AND LET ME TELL YOU
HOW WE GET TO THAT ESTIMATE
CHAIR SO. YOU KNOW WE HAVE
SCIENTISTS- ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENT WE MIGHT HAVE AS MANY
STATE SCIENTIST AS ANY OTHER
DEPARTMENT AND STATE SERVICE
PERHAPS MORE. THESE ARE TRAINED
BIOLOGIST- COMING OUT OF
UNIVERSITIES AND YOU KNOW WORK
EXPERIENCE ELSEWHERE. AND THEY
DO THIS ACROSS ALL THE ANIMALS
AND PLANTS WE MANAGE SO IT'S NOT
LIMITED THE BEARS. SAGE GROUSE
HALIBUT- YOUR WHALES SHARKS SO
ON SO FORTH. THIS IS A COMPLEX
SPACE FOR THE SCIENTIST THERE
ARE DIFFERENT WAYS YOU CAN
DETERMINE A POPULATION. AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS THE
BIOLOGIST IS CALCULATING
ECOSYSTEM ERRAIN TO SPECIES
YOU'RE TRYING TO ESTIMATE.
WHETHER COST AND THE ASSESSMENTS
TYPICALLY USE SOME CORE DATA
STREAMS ONE IS HARVEST WHICH IS
A EUPHEMISM FOR WHAT KIND OF
LEGAL TECH THE USE OF AN ANIMAL
OR A PLANT. ABUNDANCE SO YOU'RE
LOOKING ACROSS THE POPULATIONS
RANGING DISTRIBUTION ANY DATA
STREAMS. AND TYPICALLY STANDARD
PRACTICE ALL THAT FEEDS INTO UP
SOME MATHEMATICAL MODEL. IN THE
MODEL THEN PRODUCES ESTIMATES
THAT ALLOWS THE MANAGERS TO MAKE
DECISIONS WITHIN OUT WE'RE
SEEING THAT POPULATION STABILITY
INSTABILITY. ERTZ FEATURES
PLANTS WE DON'T DO A CENSUS IT'S
NOT ANALOGOUS TO SAY THE CENSUS
BUREAU TRYING TO COUNT EVERY
CITIZEN THAT IS NOT STANDARD
PRACTICE FOR ANY STATE OR
FEDERAL WILDLIFE AGENCY. SO WE
DON'T LITERALLY SEEK TO TELL
EACH INDIVIDUAL ANIMAL ON A
POPULATION- THERE ARE SOME
PLACES- HERE ON THE EAST SIDE OF
THE SIERRA SAGE GROUSE WE'RE
WE'RE ABLE TO DO AERIAL
SURVEILLANCE. AND THE SPECIES
LIFE'S STRATEGY THE TEND TO
CONGREGATE IN OPEN SPACES AND
YOU CAN COUNT FROM THE AIR THAT
BECOMES A DATA STREAM FOR A
MODEL. BUT WITH THE BEARS. WE
DON'T THINK THERE'S A SIMPLE WAY
TO DO IT TRUE CENSUS ON EVERY
SINGLE PAYER THEY MOVE PLACE TO
PLACE. THEY HIDE THEY HIBERNATE
TO CAMOUFLAGE SO IT'S NOT
LITERALLY THE CASE WE COUNT. AT
THE STATE WIDE POPULATION FOR
BEARS AND I WOULD SUBMIT IF
THAT'S WHERE WE WANT TO HEAD.
ROUTE WE MAY FIND OUT- THE
RESOURCES TO LITERALLY DO THAT
ARE PRETTY ASTRONOMICAL LIKE
ADDICTS LOST AND STAFF LABOR
PERSON OUR LEVEL. SO HERE'S HOW
WE DO IT WITH BEARS. WE TAKE
THAT INFORMATION AND WE
CALCULATE IT FROM WHAT HUNTERS
REPORT EACH SEASON. THE HUNTER
OF THE BEARS REQUIRED TO BRING
TO BEAR BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT.
AND WE TAKE A PREMOLAR TOOTH OUT
OF THE BEAR AND YOU CAN DO A LOT
OF SCIENTIFIC WORK BUT IT'S
CREDIBLE AND PRECISE FROM THAT.
LOCUSTS DESCEND ON EACH AND SEX
AT THAT MOMENT OF THAT
PARTICULAR BEAR. AND THEN WE
AGGREGATE THAT INFORMATION FROM
THE TOOTH ANALYSIS. WE TAKE THE
AGGREGATION AND WE PLUG IT INTO
A MODEL AND THAT'S WHAT ALLOWS
US TO PRODUCE AN ANNUAL BEAR
POPULATION DYNAMICS. NOW MORE
RECENTLY WE'VE BEGUN TO AUGMENT
THAT WITH LOCALIZED VERY
SPECIFIC KIND OF GPS DRIVEN WORK
ON REGIONAL BEAR POPULATIONS
WERE CLOSE TO COMPLETING. AN
ASSESSMENT ON THE EAST SIDE AND
MODOC COUNTY THERE WILL BE JUST
LOOKING AT THE BEARS AND MONO
USING KIND OF GPS DATA. WE'RE
TAKING THOSE STREAMS AND WE'RE
PUTTING THEM INTO OUR STANDARD
MODEL APPROACH AND WE COME UP
WITH AN ESTIMATE. WE THINK
THAT'S PRETTY CREDIBLE. IN WHAT
WE SEE RIGHT NOW USING THAT
EFFORT IS WE ESTIMATE- BLACK
BEAR POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA IS
ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND. THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART OF THAT ESTIMATE
IS REALLY TO LOOK BACKWARDS AND
GENERALLY SPEAKING THAT ESTIMATE
OF FORTY THOUSAND. IT'S WITHIN A
PRETTY STABLE POPULATION TREND
SO THE OVERALL POPULATION BASED
ON OUR WORK IS NOT GOING DOWN.
OUR STATE IS GOING UP BUT IT
LOOKS PRETTY STABLE. SO WHEN YOU
GET TO AN ASSESSMENT AT THE
BIOLOGIST LEVEL OF STABILITY.
THAT'S REALLY WHEN YOU GET INTO-
CHAIR HOW DO YOU FIGURE OUT.
WHAT'S A SUSTAINABLE POTENTIAL
USE OF THE ANIMAL. SO UNLIKE
SOME OTHER DYNAMICS YOU FIVE
DIGIT AND BOBCATS AND ELSEWHERE.
PEOPLE ACTIVELY CLIENT BEAR FOR
USE THERE'S CONSUMPTION AT A LOT
OF THE BEAR PRODUCT IS USED. SO
RIGHT NOW ALL THE WAY THE
DEPARTMENT MAN JUST BEAR HUNTING
IS COURSE YOU CAN'T USE DOGS THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE DEPARTMENT
ARE COMMISSION WORK THROUGH THAT
SEVERAL YEARS AGO. WE CAP. THE
AMOUNT OF BEARS THAT CAN BE
TAKEN EACH YEAR THROUGH HUNTING.
BACK CAP AS IT IS AT SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED. THAT NUMBER OF
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED. REFLECTS
PRETTY STANDARD SCIENTIFIC
THINKING WITHIN WILDLIFE
MANAGEMENT SO IF YOU'RE LOOKING
AT A POPULATION. THE SCIENTISTS
WILL TELL YOU 10% OF THE
POPULATION IS A STANDARD THAT IS
CONSIDERED AMONG WILDLIFE
MANAGERS WILL BE A CONSERVATIVE
KIND OF NUMBER FOR YOUR HUNTING
IMPACT. SO IF YOU THINK ABOUT
THAT CURRENT CAP OF SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED RELATIVE TO THAT 10%
FIGURE SEVENTEEN HUNDRED IS
ABOUT FOUR POINT 25% OF THAT
STABLE POPULATION. SO WHAT WELL
BELOW WHAT ARE WILDLIFE
SCIENTIST INDICATE IS KIND OF A
SUSTAINABILITY HARVEST LEVEL
WITHIN THE HUNTING CONTEXT BUT
THERE'S ANOTHER LEVEL AND THEN
I'LL PAUSE FOR QUESTIONS WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IN THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS IS ACTUALLY THAT WE'RE NOT
NEAR THAT SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
LEVEL THE CAP IF YOU WILL. AND
I'VE GOT IT IN MY NOTES HERE
SOMEWHERE UP HERE IS. IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO WE'RE JUST LOOKING
AT THAT DATA NOW. THE NUMBER OF
BEARS HARVESTED WAS ACTUALLY.
ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
SIX SO WE'RE EVEN BELOW THE CAP.
WHICH MEANS IF YOU'RE THINKING
OF THAT 10% SUSTAINABILITY
NUMBER. WILL PROBABLY MORE
AROUND THE 3% NUMBER RELATIVE TO
THAT KIND OF. BEST SCIENTIFIC
JUDGMENT OF YOUR HARVEST TARGET
YOU'RE ALWAYS KEEPING AN EYE ON
. HERE'S WHAT WE DO HAVE TO DO
THE- WE'VE GOT TO TAKE THIS
STATE WIDE DYNAMIC WHERE WE'RE
LOOKING AT HARVEST DATA. AND
WE'RE USING. FIND IT IN MERRITT
WITH THESE REGIONAL AS GPS
EFFORTS THAT SOME WORK WE SHOULD
DO THAT SOME WORK I'M
INSTRUCTING OUR STAFF TO
ACCELERATE. LAST COMMENT WHAT
WE'RE ACTUALLY IN THE MIDDLE OF
A PUBLIC PROCESS RIGHT NOW. SO I
WANT TO BE REALLY CAREFUL ABOUT
. SOME ASPECTS OF THIS. WE
RECENTLY CREATED A PROCESS THAT
OUR STATE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION WORK ANYONE CAN
SUBMIT A PETITION. TO THE
COMMISSION ON AN ON AN ITEM
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION WE'RE
IN RECEIPT OF A PETITION THAT'S
ASKING A LOT OF THESE BEAR
HUNTING QUESTIONS. THE
COMMISSION'S REFERRED IT TO OUR
DEPARTMENT OUR DEPARTMENT WILL
GO BACK TO THE COMMISSION IN
APRIL IN PUBLIC SESSION WITH THE
PUBLIC KIND OF DEBATE THE
PETITION IT'S PRESENTED AND I
WANT TO ALSO. RESERVE THAT SPACE
SO THAT PROCESS CAN KIND OF PLAY
OUT FAIRLY FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENGAGE IN. THAT'S A LOT- CHAIR
LET ME PAUSE THERE. THAT'S WHAT
I WAS JUST GONNA SAY THAT'S A
THAT'S A REAL EDUCATION THANK
YOU- JUST ONE QUICK QUESTION FOR
MY EDIFICATION- THAT TEN
PERCENT. TO A FIGURE THAT'S
ACROSS SPECIES OR THAT'S
SPECIFIC TO BEAR. YEAH I THINK
THAT THERE'S A- THE SPECIES
INDIVIDUALISTIC NATURE AND
THAT'S THE NUMBER I AYE MINOR
THINGS WERE USING IMPAIR WHETHER
IT'S UP OR DOWN FOR DIFFERENT. I
THINK IS TRUE AND RELATES TO
WHAT OUR OUR- UNIONS AROUND ANY
GIVEN POPULATIONS ABUNDANCE.
LIKE WE'RE DEALING WITH SAGE
GROUSE RIGHT NOW WHICH IS A
FEDERALLY PROTECTED SPECIES BUT
YOU CAN STILL HUNT SAGE GROUSE
IN THE EASTERN SIERRA. AND THERE
ARE WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT HUNTING
HARVEST LEVELS ANYWHERE NEAR
THAT HIGH BECAUSE THE POPULATION
OF THE SPECIES IS MUCH LOWER SO
YOU DO HAVE TO TAILOR YOUR
MANAGEMENT DECISION WITH THOSE
FACTORS AS WELL. THANK YOU MR
BACK. UP THANK YOU AB. JUMPING
JACK BACK IN HERE FROM THE OTHER
COMMITTEE HEARING SO IF THIS
SOMEHOW HAS BEEN COVERED AT- I
HAVEN'T I'M INTERESTED IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE-
WE'RE FINDING WITH GENERAL FUNDS
AND THERE WAS- SOME TALK ABOUT
WHILE AGO ABOUT INCREASING FEES.
HOW TO HELP WITH A FUNDING- THE
HAD A BIG FEE INCREASE AND
THERE'S LOTS OF OPPOSITION TO
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO REVISIT THE
TOPIC THAT I BROUGHT UP- IN THE
PAST WHICH IS. TO HAVE A FEE AND
THE HAVE- AT LEAST START TO HAVE
A SMALLER INCREASE BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY TIE THAT SMALLER
INCREASE TO THE CONSUMER PRICE
INDEX IN SOME WAY SO THAT IT'S
TOTALLY GOES UP TO TRY TO
DECREASE THE CHANCES THAT WE
HAVE- THE DEFICIT SO I'M JUST.
CURIOUS IS THERE- IS THE
DEPARTMENT CONSIDERING- LOWER-
FEE INCREASE- RATHER THAN THE
LARGE ONE THAT- MET WITH SO MUCH
OPPOSITION AND IF THE-
DEPARTMENT IS CONSIDERING A
LOWER FEE INCREASE WOULD IT ALSO
BE MATCHED WITH A- A WRITER FOR
SOME KIND OF- CONSUMER PRICE
INFLATION- ADDED TO IT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MY ANSWERS KIND OF YES
BUT AND HERE'S HERE'S THE BUT
PART. OF THE HOWEVER PARK- I
PEOPLE APPROPRIATE SO. WE HAVE
HUNDREDS OF FEES ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENT WE CAN GET THERE SO
YOU MAY BE ASKING ABOUT ONE. AND
I THINK YOU'RE REFERRING TO FEES
ON COMMERCIAL FISHING BUT WE
HAVE HUNDREDS THE WAY WE DO OIL
SPILL RESPONSE IS WE HAVE FEES
ON THE PRODUCTION OF BARRELS OF
OIL AT THE FACILITY. REPHRASE
THAT RECENTLY WE HAD FEES ON
PEOPLE WHO NEED PERMITS FOR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS WE RAISE
THAT RECENTLY. YEAH FEES FOR
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO HUNT AND FISH
. SOME OF THOSE MORE RECENTLY
HAVE. BECAUSE THE LEGISLATIVE
WORK BEEN GIVEN ABILITY FOR US
TO YOU KNOW KIND OF MINISTERIAL
TO DO- ANNUAL COPYRIGHT IF YOU
WILL CALL. IF YOU'RE ASKING JUST
ABOUT COMMERCIAL FISHING- YES WE
TRIED TO RAISE FEES SOME WILL
SAY WE- SOUGHT TO RAISE THEM TO
EXPONENTIALLY HIGH. THE OUTCOME
BETWEEN THE LEGISLATIVE AND
ADMINISTRATIVE BRANCH WAS A
MODEST FEE INCREASE BUT I GOT TO
BE FRANK. A LOT OF OUR USER
COMMUNITIES CANNOT FATHOM. THE
COST OF WHAT THE FEE WOULD BE TO
TRULY ALIGN OUR MISSION AND OUR
CURRENT SERVICE LEVEL SO MY
PERSONAL VIEW IS THAT APARTMENT
CAN'T FEED ITS WAY OUT OF A LOT
OF THE PREDICAMENT WE'RE IN AND
THE BEST EXAMPLE IS. OUR WORK IN
SPECIES CONSERVATION
PARTICULARLY ENDANGERED SPECIES
IS TO THE GENERAL BENEFIT OF THE
PUBLIC. I MEAN WHAT WOULD BE A
FEE. CHARGE SOMEONE WHO SUBMITS
A PETITION TO PROTECT AN ANIMAL
UNDER THE STATE ESA OF THREE.
MAGIC IT'S HARD TO CONTEMPLATE
WHAT WOULD BE A VARIETY OF FEET
SOURCES TO TRULY GET OUT OF THIS
DYNAMIC IT IT I'VE I APPRECIATE
YOUR RESPONSE AND I AGREE WITH
YOU THAT THERE ARE MANY PUBLIC
BENEFITS- TO WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
DOES IN. ALL OF THOSE SHOULD NOT
BE. GOOD FUNDED BY BY FEES I'M
PROBABLY FAR MORE INTERESTED IN
MAKING SURE WE CONTINUALLY HAVE
MODEST FEE INCREASES. A. N. I
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ADOPT WHAT I THINK IS
BEST PRACTICE WHICH IS TO HAVE
THOSE FEE INCREASES HAVE AN
AUTOMATIC CONSUMER PRICE.
INFLATION ADDED TO IT I THINK
IT'S A IT IS YES THERE WILL BE A
POLITICAL BATTLE TO THAT BUT
THAT OF POLITICAL BATTLE IS ONE.
WELL WORTH HAVING IF YOU IF YOU
WIN IT ONCE- YOU YOU ADDRESS A-
LONG TERM PROBLEM- CHAPTER SEVEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR RESPONSE THANK YOU. AND ALL
I'LL JUST SAY- I THINK- IT'S
CLEAR THAT INCREASING GOT WE'VE
WE'VE HAD SOME EXPERIENCE WITH
ATTEMPTING TO AND INCREASED FEES
AND WE KNOW- THAT- YOUR SENSE
THAT WE'VE KIND OF REACHED A
LIMIT OF HOW FAR WE CAN GO WITH
MANY OF THESE FEES IS. PROBABLY
TRUE AND I ALSO AGREE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT THAT-
HAVING A COLA WOULD BE HELPFUL
ALTHOUGH I DON'T THINK IT WOULD
SOLVE. THE PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE
BECAUSE- THEY PUT THEIR- WE
WE'VE GONE SO LONG WITHOUT IT-
ADDRESSING ANY ADJUSTMENTS AT
ALL IN MANY. CASES- BUT I I'M
pWE GET TO A PLACE WHERE- WE
BRING IN THE NECESSARY FUNDING-
WITHOUT RESORTING TO SOME KIND
OF FEE INCREASE SO WE'RE SORT OF
IN A CIRCULAR ZONE HERE WHERE WE
DON'T WANT TO DO WHAT WE MAY
HAVE TO DO- AND- WE KEEP PUTTING
IT OFF. AND THINGS KEEP GETTING
WORSE SO- I DON'T KNOW THAT
THERE'S AN ANSWER TO THAT IT'S
REALLY MORE OF AN OBSERVATION A
FRUSTRATION- IT. COULD I JUST
RESPONDED THAT REAL QUICKLY
THERE IS TO IT THE IDEA OF JUST
GOING YEARS AND YEARS WITHOUT
ADJUSTING A FEAT THAT'S THAT'S
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE
AND THEN THE SECOND ONE IS
THERE'S A DEFICIT YOU KNOW WE'VE
BECAUSE WE'VE DONE THAT WE'RE
WE'RE BEHIND. BUT AT LEAST LET'S
QUIT DIGGING THE HOLE DEEPER
BECAUSE EVERY YEAR WE DON'T HAVE
A COLA- WE JUST MAKE WE JUST GET
THE FEE FURTHER AND FURTHER
BEHIND WHERE IT SHOULD BE AYE
AYE AYE SO I WE DON'T NEED TO
GET ENGAGED IN A GONNA CALL
CLEAR BUT I CERTAINLY. DON'T
DISAGREE WITH THAT SENTIMENT- OF
MY POINT WAS SIMPLY THE WHOLE IS
ALREADY SO DEEP THAT EVEN WHEN
WE MOVED TO AS I THINK WE
SHOULD- REGULAR INCREASES BASED
ON. A SOME KIND OF COLA- WE'RE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO CLOSE THE-
THE EXPECT THE GAP AND TO
DECREASE THE DELTA SIGNIFICANTLY
ENOUGH BUT ENOUGH SAID ABOUT
THAT- I IN THE COLLECTED THE- TO
CALL ON ALEJO AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO SEE IF THEY HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON. A ISSUE. SIX THE
WILL MOVE TO ISSUE SEVEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR RACHEL IN WITH
L. A. OCCUPY VERY BRING I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. AND JUST WITH
ECHO- THAT REQUEST THAT THAT
THAT SERVICE BASED BUDGET DATA
BE INTEGRATED INTO FUTURE BUDGET
REQUEST FROM THE DEPARTMENT
GREAT TO HEAR THAT COMMITMENT
FROM THE DIRECTOR THAT. AB
REALLY WILL HELP YOUR DECISIONS
TO UNDERSTAND HOW PROPOSALS
MIGHT HELP CLOSE OR WIDEN GAPS.
ALSO JUST REITERATE THAT PART OF
THE REASON THE LEGISLATURE
PURSUED THIS S. B. B. EXERCISE
WAS TO UNDERSTAND SOME OF THESE
FEET VERSUS GENERAL FUND
ALIGNMENT ISSUES SO. THAT DATA
WILL BE REALLY IMPORTANT- IN ANY
FUTURE DECISION. WHILE I THINK
THE DIRECTOR MAKES A GOOD POINT
THAT THE GAPS ARE LARGE ENOUGH
THAT. THAT FEES WOULDN'T BE
FEASIBLE NOR APPROPRIATE IN MANY
CASES SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
PUBLIC TRUST RESPONSIBILITIES.
TO HELP CLOSE THIS GAP. THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WHEN YOU'RE
ADDING NEW IN PARTICULAR WHEN
YOU'RE ADDING NEW EXPLICIT
ACTIVITIES THAT HAVE EXPLICIT
BENEFICIARIES BUT IT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE TO THINK ABOUT. WHO
SHOULD PAY FOR THAT- JUST
BECAUSE THERE WAS A VERY
SUBSTANTIAL FEE PROPOSAL SEVERAL
YEARS AGO THERE WAS A BROAD BASE
THAT HAD A LOT OF RESISTANCE.
SHOULDN'T PRECLUDE YOU FROM
CONSIDERING INDIVIDUAL FEE
INCREASES- WHEN APPROPRIATE FOR
EXPLICIT ACTIVITIES. AT WITH
REGARD TO LIVE FOR PROPOSALS
BEFORE YOU IN THIS AGENDA ITEM
WE DIDN'T RAISE ANY CONCERNS IN
PART BECAUSE OF AS THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED THERE ARE SOME PUBLIC
BENEFIT. ASSOCIATED WITH SEVERAL
OF THEM THAT THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY ALSO HAVE A FEE
PAYING BENEFICIARIES BUT- JUST
ONE ECHO THAT THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT CONTINUOUS
CONVERSATION I HAVE EVERY YEAR
FOR THE DEPARTMENT BECAUSE THEY
DO HAVE MULTIPLE CONSTITUENCIES
MULTIPLE TYPES OF ACTIVITIES.
AND MULTIPLE FUND SOURCES- SO
ASKING THESE TYPES OF QUESTIONS
THAT CAN CONTINUES TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT IT'S BEST ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES WITH
SPECIFIC SPECIFIC. BENEFICIARIES
THANKS. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. MERRIAM KAPLAN WITH
THAT OF THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS
- NO FORMAL COMMENTS HERE BUT I
WOULD JUST REITERATE- THE
COMMENTS OF DIRECTOR BOND- AND
THAT IT CONTINUES TO BE AT A
PRIORITY OF THE ADMINISTRATION
TO ADDRESS THE SERVICE BASED
BUDGET GAPS. THANK YOU AND HAPPY
TO HELP YOU ANSWER ANY QUESTION
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DIRECTOR BOTTOM I DO HAVE ONE
MORE QUESTION ON- OFF ON ON THIS
ITEM- ARE YOU SPOKE A ABOUT THE-
REPLACEMENT OF A CERTAIN NUMBER
OF- OF VESSELS IN- IN THE
DEPARTMENT'S FLEET- AND I FORGET
WHAT THE NUMBER WAS- THAT YOU
HAD IDENTIFIED. BUT YOU
IDENTIFIED THOSE IS- NEEDING
REPLACEMENT LIKE NOW BECAUSE
THEY **** OUTLIVE THEIR- THAT
THEY'RE COSTING MORE THAN- THAT
IS REASONABLE. IF YOU WERE TO
LOOK FORWARD THREE OR FIVE YEARS
HOW MANY MORE VESSELS WOULD FALL
INTO THAT CATEGORY YOU HAVE A
NUMBER FOR THAT. SO AS I
MENTIONED WE HAVE A LITTLE OVER
THIRTY. VESSELS IN KIND OF THIS
RESEARCH SPACE THAT ARE NOT LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WE TOOK A LOOK AT
THE VESSELS WE EXPECTED TO BE
RETIRED BY. TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE CAME UP WITH
TWELVE. AND THE AGES OF THOSE
ARE BETWEEN LIKE THIRTY EIGHT
EIGHT YEARS. AND THE MAJORITY OF
THOSE TWELVE WERE PURCHASED BACK
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES. AND
YOU GET ABOUT TWENTY FIVE YEARS
OF LIFE OUT OF THE VESSEL. AND
SO WE WENT FROM IN THE THIRTIES
TO TWELVE AND WHERE YOU GET FIVE
IT IS WE PRIORITIZE WITHIN THE
TWELFTH- THOSE WHICH ARE KIND OF
AT. THE END OF THEIR USED AND
USEFUL LIFE THE SOONEST. SO YOU
HAVE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
TWELVE AND FIVE IS THE NEXT
TRANCHE FOR SURE. IF YOU COULD
GET THE- A- A DOLLAR AMOUNT FOR
THE ADDITIONAL SEVEN BESTIVAL
OF. VESSELS I WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT. HOUSTON THANK YOU. AND NOW
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE SEVEN NOW
L. I'M SORRY- MISTRUST IN FELLOW
FOR DIRECTOR BOTTOM. IS SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
WAS INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET. AND I DO BELIEVE YOU'RE
ASKING FOR THE SAME AMOUNT OF
FUNDING AND YOU'RE ASKING US TO
PAY FOR THE SAME PROGRAM THE
SECOND YEAR IN A ROW. WELL WHAT
ABOUT THE LAST YEAR FUNDING. NO
I WOULD NEVER ASK FOR THAT-
CYLINDERS THAT SO LET ME PROVIDE
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION AND YOU
ARE RIGHT ABOUT IDENTIFYING THAT
CONFUSING ASPECT. SO LAST YEAR.
AND WE'RE CURRENTLY. COMPLETING
YOUR APPROPRIATION AUTHORIZATION
TO US OF SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND WHAT WE DID
WITH THAT SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND. IS WE WENT AHEAD AND
CREATED A MORE MOBILE PHONE
APPLICATION. SO INSTEAD OF
HAVING TO USE A PAPER BOOK TO
FIGURE OUT WHEN YOU'RE FISHING
ON THE MCLEOD. CAN YOU KEEP A
FISH BETWEEN THE BRIDGE IN THE
TREE WE WE'VE GONE AND CREATED A
MOBILE PHONE APPLICATION. FOR
AREAS WITHOUT CELL SERVICE
THAT'S BEEN ONE OF OUR BIGGER
CHALLENGES. AND WE ALSO WENT
AHEAD AND PUT ALL OF OUR FISHING
REGULATIONS INTO A GPS.
APPLICATION THAT CAN BE YOU
READILY ACCESS FROM YOUR PHONE.
THAT'S WHAT WE USE THE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND FOUR BUT
BECAUSE BOTH OF THOSE WILL BE
READY. FOR NOW IF YOU APPROVE OF
THE 800-100-0800 TEN THOUSAND.
WE WILL TAKE THAT AND USE THAT
MONEY FOR SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
WE HAVE A LITTLE AUTOMATED
LICENSE STRUCTURE WHERE ANYONE
CAN BUY A LICENSE ELECTRONICALLY
. THAT SYSTEM. WE JUST
RENEGOTIATED A CONTRACT WITH THE
PROVIDER OF IT AND NOW TO DO THE
THREE SIXTY FIVE LICENSE AND THE
DISCOUNTS FOR SIXTY FIVE YEAR
OLDS WE NEED TO GO BACK INTO
THAT COMPUTER SYSTEM AND PUT IN
ALL THE FUNCTIONALITY FOR THESE
TWO NEW THINGS. SO THAT HUNDRED
TEN IS FOR NEW WORK THE SEVEN
FIFTY DO GREAT THINGS AND THEN
THEY JOINED. ABOUT ONE YEAR FROM
NOW IS A COMPLETE KIND OF
PACKAGE FOR CUSTOMERS TO HAVE A
BETTER USER EXPERIENCE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. BECAUSE IT'S NOT
LIKE MY COLLEAGUES I HAVE A BIG
CONCERN WITH THE SERVICE BASED.
BUDGETING THAT IS NOT BE IN THAT
USE FOR EACH DEPARTMENT THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE USED AND IF IT'S
FISHING LICENSE BEAR HUNTING.
WHATEVER THE DEEP SEA FISHING
KIND OF CASE. DO YOU HAVE A
MATRIX THAT THEIR ENERGY
DEPARTMENT LOAN FUNDS TO BE
KEEPING TRACK OF MONEY THAT YOU
MIGHT. USE IN ANOTHER DEPARTMENT
AND NOT GOTTEN BACK FROM THAT
FUND. AGAIN KIND OF SO WE. WE'RE
NOT IN THE PRACTICE OF LEARNING
OUR MONEY ELSEWHERE. WHAT WITHIN
OUR DEPARTMENT AS ILLEGAL IN
FINANCE MIGHT WANT TO MENTION WE
MAY HAVE MORE SPECIFIC DEDICATED
ACCOUNTS THAN ANY OTHER
DEPARTMENT AND STATE GOVERNMENT
. AND HISTORICALLY WE'VE HAD A
TRUST PROBLEM WITH ARE YOU ARE
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
TELL IF THEY'RE DOLLAR FOR PIGS
END UP BEING USED ON TURKEY'S.
WHAT SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
ALSO INVOLVED WAS AN ASSESSMENT
OF OUR TEN MAJOR ACCOUNTS WITH
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES SO WE CAN
INCREASE OUR TRANSPARENCY ON HOW
MONIES COMING IN AND WHERE IT'S
GOING AND WHAT IT'S BEING USED
FOR AND THAT'S NOW PART OF OUR
ANNUAL PROCESS WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES UNDER SPD. AND IF
YOU'D LIKE A FOLLOW UP WE WOULD
ENJOY THE CHANCE TO COME BY YOUR
OFFICE AND KINDA UNPACKED THAT
ASPECT OF OUR WORK OKAY YET
PRESENT I WANT TO ASK FOR AN
AUDIT BUT I WANT TO SEE IT WHEN
MAYBE THE LAST TIME YOUR
DEPARTMENTS WERE AUDITED BUT
I'LL KEEP AN EYE IN THE FUTURE
BECAUSE I THINK THAT MIGHT BE
THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM. THANK
YOU THANK. ALL RIGHT DIRECTOR
LET'S MOVE ON ISSUE SEVEN OUR
LAST ITEM OF THE DAY ON
CANNABIS. LICENSURE SAFETY AND
QUALITY ASSURANCE. OKAY SO AGAIN
CHECK BOND DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT THE SMALL LIFE. AND
HERE'S HOW IT WOULD START ON
CANNABIS. THERE'S A LOT OF-
UNDER WAY IN UNDER DISCUSSION
AROUND CANNABIS. MANY OF THOSE
THINGS DON'T RELATE TO OUR
DEPARTMENT. AND I WHEN I READ
THE NEWSPAPER ITS SEEMS
POSSIBLE THE LEGISLATURE AND
OTHERS WILL BE THINKING THROUGH
LIKE THE NEXT VERSIONS OF YOU
KNOW OUR CANNABIS APPROACHING
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S A LOT
HAPPENING. BUT BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL FROM OUR DEPARTMENT IS
MUCH MUCH MUCH NARROWER THAN ALL
THOSE OTHER THINGS. LAST YEAR-
BECAME LAW AB ONE FORTY ONE. FOR
THREE YEARS UNDER THIS LAW
THERE'S A WAY WE'RE GOING TO.
BRING MORE CULTIVATORS INTO A
LICENSE SPACE USING PROVISIONAL
LICENSES AND SOME STREAMLINING
COMPONENTS AROUND SOME OF OUR
DEPARTMENT'S PERMITTING. THERE'S
A DEFINED WINDOW THREE YEARS
THERE'S A WORKLOAD WE CAN
REASONABLY ESTIMATE THIS
PROPOSAL IS TO COVER THE CLARKS
OUR TIME AND EFFORT FOR FILLING
THAT KIND OF OBLIGATION FOR
THREE YEARS. WE SEEK AN AMOUNT
OF THE ALLOCATION OF ONE FROM
THE CANNABIS TAX FUND TO COVER
THIS REGULATORY WORK OVER THE
THREE YEARS. AND SEVEN LIMITED
TERM POSITIONS TO FIND ABOUT
THREE YEARS I KNOW THERE ARE A
LOT OF QUESTIONS LIKE WHAT'S
YOUR LAW ENFORCEMENT DOING HOW
DO YOU WORK WITH COUNTIES WHAT'S
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY YOU RECEIVE
UNDER ALLOCATION THREE AT THE
TAX HOW'S THAT BEAT BEING USED
FOR GRANTING. IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS WELCOME ANY CHANCE TO
FOLLOW UP ON THOSE BUT THIS BCP.
IS ABOUT A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
MONEY SEVEN POSITIONS THREE
YEARS. AB ONE FORTY ONE AND
PROVISIONAL LICENSE. REPLIES
THERE AND SEE WHICH WAY THE
COMMITTEE OR YOU CHAIR MIGHT
LIKE TO GO WITH CONVERSATION OR
QUESTIONS. I DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC DIRECTION FOR YOU AND-
I'M THE ONLY ONE OF NOT MORE.
CAMPUS IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING ON
THAT NOT. OUR I'VE I'VE WE CAN
JUST HEAR FROM L. A. O. AND TO.
A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND-
WRAP THIS ONE UP. NO COMMENTS ON
THIS ITEM THANK YOU MISTER CHECK
. GREAT I DO LOOK FORWARD TO-
YOUR FUTURE REPORTS ON THIS-
DIRECTOR BONHAM. I'M SORRY
THERE'S AND THERE'S- NO COMMENTS
TO MAKE ON THIS ITEM THANK YOU
FOR HAVE YOU HAD SO MUCH STATIC
AND I KEPT YOU WAITING CLOSE
YOUR EYES FOR THAT- WELL THAT
CONCLUDES OUR- ISSUES TO BE
HEARD. THERE ARE A COUPLE OF-
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS- ON OUR
NON DISCUSSION- AGENDA ITEMS AND
ALL I JUST KICK THAT OFF-
SECRETARY ROSS I THINK. A OF A
YOU'VE- BEEN ABLE TO HAVE- THE
GREAT PLEASURE OF- HANGING
AROUND AND LISTENING TO THE REST
OF- ARE- AGENDA ITEMS HERE AND I
APPRECIATE IT- YOU'RE WAITING
PATIENTLY- BUT I DID WANT TO
MAKE A COMMENT ABOUT ISSUE SIX
ON THE NON DISCUSSION AGENDA. A
GIVEN THAT LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
APPROPRIATED A MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF- OF- THE-
A BILLING QUESTION AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO OF MY LEGISLATION THE
B. C. P. ON THIS ITEM- ALLUDES
TO THE FUNDS NOT BEING UTILIZED
UNTIL FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE- AND- SO I
WONDERING IF YOU CAN GIVE ME- AN
UPDATE ON THE- IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN FOR THIS BILL AND- EXPLAIN
WHY- THE- THE FUNDS WILL BE
UTILIZED. TO FOR A LITTLE WHILE
. YES AND I'M HAPPY TO DO THAT
MISTER CHAIR- I REALLY
APPRECIATE. YOUR WORKING ON THIS
LEGISLATION HAS BEEN ABOUT A TWO
YEAR PROCESS TO GET- THE FINAL
VERSION THAT IS NOW THE LOCK-
AND I WANT TO START OUT BY
SAYING WE ARE VERY COMMITTED AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE TO FULLY
IMPLEMENTING THIS. AND IT IS OUR
GOAL AND OUR COMMITMENT TO HAVE
OPERATIONAL PROGRAM BY THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO- THE
CHALLENGE FOR US HAS BEEN- MULTI
FOLD. ONE AS WE RECEIVE THE
BUDGET WITHOUT POSITION
AUTHORITY AND WE NEED TO HAVE
THE RIGHT KIND OF STAFF WITH THE
RIGHT BACKGROUND ON THIS TO BE
ABLE TO FULLY- DEVELOP THE
STANDARDS FOR THE COMMUNITY BY
BANKS FOR ANIMALS- AND TO THE
REGULATORY PACKAGE. AND SO WHAT%
WITH THIS- WITH THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL WE WILL BE ABLE TO
START AND RECRUITMENT PROCESS.
WE DID TRY TO RECRUIT WHAT ARE
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS TO GET US
STARTED- OVER THE LAST SIX OR
SEVEN MONTHS AND THAT TIGHT
LABOR MARKET AND ESPECIALLY FOR
SOMEONE WITH THE KIND OF
TECHNICAL. SCIENTIFIC
CREDENTIALS VETERINARY
BACKGROUND BACK THAT WE NEED
IT'S A VERY TIGHT LABOR MARKET
AND LIMITED TERM POSITION. OR
ARE NOT VERY ATTRACTIVE TO
PEOPLE WHAT THOSE KINDS OF
CREDENTIALS SO WE WILL START OUR
RECRUITMENT PROCESS KNOWING THAT
THIS IS IN THE BUDGET. WE WILL
ADVERTISE THEM AS LIMITED TERM
WITH THE POSSIBILITY OF BEING
ABLE TO GO TO PERMANENT AND HOPE
THAT THAT WILL HELP WITH THE
RECRUITMENT PROCESS. BUT I DO
WANT TO ASSURE YOU THAT- WAIT WE
ENJOYED WORKING WITH YOU ON THE
FAILED TO GET AT RIGHT WE ARE
FULLY COMMITTED TO GETTING IT
IMPLEMENTED. AND ARE VERY
HOPEFUL THAT WITH THE RIGHT
PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO. MAKE OUR
PUBLICATION SHAT IN THE CALENDAR
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO GREAT
THANK YOU I HOPE SO TOO. THERE'S
A LOT OF DOGS OUT THERE THAT
ARE- ANXIOUS. TO START GIVEN
BLOOD. MISTER SMITH I THINK YOU
ARE YOU HAVE A I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S- CERTAIN. ROSS OR SOMEONE.
SKEWS ME FOR YOU. IT'S A AS AS A
SAYS A BIT OF GOT CALLING- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MY ITEM IS IT
IS NUMBER TEN. THIS Y. LAS COULD
. ACTIONS COMPENSATORY
MITIGATION CREDITS BOTH
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS HAVE
BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF THESE
MEASURES LIKE SB SEVEN NINETY.
WHICH CREATED INCENTIVES AND
VOLUNTARY INITIATIVES TO
CONSERVE AND PROTECT OUR
WILDLIFE. HOWEVER IT HAS BEEN
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION THAT
SOME OF THESE EFFORTS AND TOOLS
LIKE AB TWO ZERO EIGHT SEVEN
FROM TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN ARE
BEING USED TO PREVENT HOUSING
PROJECT FROM BEING BUILT. I HAVE
A COUPLE PROJECTS IT CONCERNED
AB TWENTY EIGHTY SEVEN
AUTHORIZES THE APPROVAL OF
REGIONAL CONSERVATION INVESTMENT
STRATEGIES. TO PROVIDE VOLUNTARY
NON BINDING GUIDANCE. YET THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY REGIONAL
CONSERVATION INVESTMENT STRATEGY
IS CURRENTLY BEING USED AS AN
EXHIBIT IN A CIVIL LAWSUIT TO
PREVENT TWENTY THOUSAND HOMES
BEING BUILT. INCLUDING THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED MUCH NEEDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. THE DRAFT ADDED
STRATEGY WAS WRITTEN BY TWO
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS THOSE SAME
TROOPS SAME TWO GROUPS ARE SUING
THE WHOLE RANCH. AND I'D LIKE TO
GET OF THE DIRECTOR OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE AND APPROPRIATE STAFF
TO SIT DOWN WITH ME ON A MEETING
TO IN THE DISCUSSES ISSUES MORE
IN DEPTH. BECAUSE WE NEED
HOSING IN CALIFORNIA WE GET A
PROJECT THIS CAN BE BUILT BEEN
APPROVED AND NOW IT'S BEEN SUED
AND MORE LITIGATION SO THAT'S
ALL I ASK FOR FROM OF DIRECTOR
BONTA PROBABLY. I GLADLY
COMMITTED THAT FOLLOW UP I'VE
DONE THE SAME WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG. AND I. WILL
JUST INFORM YOU. OUR DEPARTMENT.
HAS ENTITLED EVERY PROJECT THAT
THE HOMEOWNERS COME FORWARD WITH
AND- I'VE TOLD TO HOMES
LEADERSHIP REPEATEDLY. THEY CAN
CALL ME AND SIT DOWN AND TALK
WITH ME ABOUT THE ISSUE YOU'RE
RAISING AND IT'S BEEN CRICKETS.
SO I WELCOME THE CHANCE TO MEET
WITH YOU OFFLINE. IT TO ME CAN
WE DO THIS WITHIN THE NEXT
THIRTY DAYS. PLEASE OKAY THAT
WILL HAVE A REACH OUT TO LOCAL
HAVE THE PAINTING I KNOW IN THE
SWING SPACE ARE PROBABLY ABOUT
TEN OR TWELVE IS BECAUSE WE CAN
GET A CONFERENCE ROOM SO. WE'LL
KEEP IT TO THAT NUMBER. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WELL WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENT NOW. EVERYONE
WILL HAVE- I'M SORRY WE'VE RUN
LONGER THAN I ANTICIPATED BUT
THAT ALWAYS SEEMS TO BE THE
CASE- EVERYONE WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE TO SPEAK WE'LL START WITH
THOSE IN THE ROOM AND THEN OPEN
THE PHONE LINES. FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE INTENDING TO CALL IN
THE PHONE NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR FOUR
SEVEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH
INJURY AS WE HEAR ON BEHALF OF
THE HOME RANCH CORPORATION- WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH- AND WE
ACTUALLY- WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE DIRECTOR'S RESPONSE WITH
RESPECT TO. SET UP A SETTING UP
A MEETING- THE ITEM THAT'S
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE HERE IN
ISSUE NUMBER TEN SHOULD BE A
ROUTINE ITEM TO APPROVE FUNDING
FOR ADDITIONAL STAFF- THAT'S NOT
A BAD THING. BUT I THINK THIS IS
A GOOD POINT TO KIND OF LOOK AT
HOW THE PROGRAM'S BEEN
IMPLEMENTED BEFORE MORE STAFF.
THE INVESTMENT FOR MORE STAFF IS
BEING MADE- THERE IS THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM WHERE YOU
BRING PEOPLE TO THE TABLE ON A
VOLUNTARY BASIS. AND YOU HAVE TO
THERE HAS TO BE TRUST AND HAS TO
BE TRANSPARENCY. AND THERE ALSO
HAS TO BE OBJECTIVE AS POSSIBLE
DATA THIS USED. AND THE RANCHES
EXPERIENCE IN ADULT VALUES NOT
THAT. AND SO ARE THESE ISSUES
THAT WE WILL BE EAGER TO DISCUSS
WITH THE DIRECTOR. THANKS TO THE
COMMITMENT THAT'S BEEN MADE
TODAY DURING THE SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING. AND WE ALSO NEED THIS
TO BE TRANSPARENT BECAUSE-
IDEALLY MORE COMPANIES MORE
INTERESTED PARTIES WILL COME A
FORT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
PROGRAM ON A VOLUNTARY BASIS BUT
THERE HAS TO BE TRUST. AND THERE
HAS TO BE TRANSPARENCY. SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO AREN'T SOME OF
THESE ISSUES OUT. AND WHEN THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE DOES GET TO THE
POINT OF MAKING A DECISION TO
ACTUALLY APPROVE THE STAFF
POSITIONS IT'LL BE FOR PROCESS A
PROGRAM. THAT'S IMPROVED A GOING
FORWARD SO THAT MORE PEOPLE
TRUSTED. AND ACTUALLY. TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ABDEL ALBERS SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM AND BE. A
PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE FARM TO SCHOOL PROGRAM
AS WELL AS THE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS OF ON GOING FUNDING. FOR
HIRING SIXTEEN NEW POSITIONS TO
SEE ITS SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION. HOWEVER WE
BELIEVE THAT THE PROGRAM MUST
PRIORITIZE ORGANIC PROCUREMENT
PESTICIDE USE IN AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITIES HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY HARMFUL FULL FOR
CHILDREN AND ESPECIALLY LATIN X.
CHILDREN. SO WHILE FOOD MUST BE
NUTRITIOUS IT ALSO MUST BE GROWN
WITHOUT TOXIC PESTICIDES.
SECONDLY WHAT WE SUPPORT FUNDING
FOR THE ORGANIC TRANSITION WITH
THE ORGANIC TRANSITION PROGRAM
WE BELIEVE SHOULD BE. A
STANDALONE PROGRAM RATHER THAN
INTEGRATED INTO EXISTED EXISTING
PROGRAMMING TO ENSURE THAT SMALL
SCALE AND SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
FARMERS HAVE ACCESS TO. COMPLETE
COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT DURING THE
TRANSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL- MOVED TO THE PHONE LINES
NOW OPERATOR ARE YOU READY TO GO
. YES LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. OUR FIRST COMMENT
WILL COME TO MIND NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SURE NUMBERS THE CITY KIA KARATE
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL HERE TO COMMENT
ON I'M A HANDFUL. WITH EACH I'M
ON THE TAP WATER RESILIENCE
PACKAGE WE SUPPORT INCREASED
FUNDING TO ENSURE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. BUT IT OF A
LETTER RECENTLY ALONG WITH ARE
NOT ADDRESS THE PARTNER OUT MY
FEET RECOMMENDATIONS TO PROTECT
THE HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER
INCLUDING FUNDING A STATEWIDE
LOW INCOME WATER REPURPOSE AND
PROGRAMS YOU THINK THE
UNFETTERED RESEARCH FUNDING THAT
WAS ALLOCATED IN THE BUDGET LAST
YEAR. BUT EXTREMELY STRONG NEXT
WITH YOUR EQUIPMENT A LOT OF
BENCHMARK PERSPECTIVE TO
REDIRECT THE ON COURT PERFECT.
FIVE HUNDRED NINE DOLLARS FOR
LARGE SCALE WATER RECYCLING.
WITH THE HOLDS PRO IN LA.
BETWEEN FORMER PROJECTS WILL
HELP. ROB BILLION WATER SUPPLY
AND FIFTEEN. JOBS IN THE- I'M
SIGNIFICANT ON A BETTER FUNDING.
HEALTH WE TO REPLY LEAD PIPES
AND THE STATE WE STRONGLY URGE
YOU USE ABOUT PROCESS TO ENSURE
THE THREE FOR. ARE FIVE ON FULL
AND NOT. TO OF SERVICE. MATURE
THAT THEY ARE NO LET BIKES AND
PEOPLE. WATER BOTH REQUIRING.
TESTING IN. FOR ACCIDENT. THANK
YOU TO GET THE PHARMACY PROGRAM
AT OUR YOU TRYING SUPPORT THE-
MILLION DOLLARS. BUDGET AS WELL
AS THE MILLION ARE GOING I THINK
. TO ENSURE SUCCESS WHAT. THESE
REPORTS OF OUT OF. TO AS A NOT
MODEL. SCHOOL DISTRICT BRING
HOPE YOU'RE FREE TO STUDENTS.
CHANGE ORDER AND CREATE NEEDED
MARKET ARE STATE FARM.
ESPECIALLY FOR SMALLER. IT
UNDERSERVED THIRTY. AND I LIKED
WITH THE OUTCOME. ON THE NEED
FOR A STEP OR GET. AGRICULTURE
TRANSITION PROGRAM IS DIRECTORY
MARC THANK YOU CHIARA CAN'T.
YES- AT BIG MUCH WITHOUT
PARTICULAR COMMENT.
NETWORK CURRENT CYCLE INSTITUTE
AND THE CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED
ORGANIC FARMERS WE SUPPORT OF
FIFTEEN MILLION THREE ORGANIC
TRANSITION PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
UNDERSERVED PRODUCERS A
STANDALONE PROGRAM THAT TFA IS
WHAT IS NECESSARY TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF FARMERS AND CONSUMERS.
RATHER THAN THE CURRENT NARROWLY
FOCUSED PROGRAM EMBEDDED WITH
THE CONSERVATION AGRICULTURE
PLANNING GRANTS PROGRAM IT'S
PROGRAM WOULD EXPIRE XPAND UPON
THE SEVEN MILLION ATISFIED IN
FY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND TWO
AND INCLUDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. IN MARKET
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL PLANNING
AND ECONOMIC SUPPORT WE URGE YOU
TO APPROPRIATE A HUNDRED MILLION
TO THE FARMING CONSERVANCY
PROGRAM HOW TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION THIS IMPORTANT
PROGRAM CAN HELP ACHIEVE THE
STATE'S THIRTY BY THIRTY
CONSERVATION GOALS. BY PROVIDING
GRANTS FOR THE PROTECTION IN
HANSON OF AGRICULTURAL LAND BUT
IMPROVE CLIMATE RESILIENCE
POLLINATOR HABITAT CALIFORNIA'S
BIODIVERSITY FIVE PERCEPTION AND
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE FINALLY WE
SUPPORT PROPOSED THIRTY MILLION
FOR. SCHOOL GRANT PROGRAM NEXT
YEAR AND A THREE MILLION ONGOING
FUNDING FOR SIXTEEN PERMANENT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVISIONS
TO ENSURE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I NEXT TIME WILL
COME ONE OF THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR NUMBER OF
BETHEL SO I'M OF WATER BE USED
CALIFORNIA WATER RESISTANT- AT
WILL COST A SIGNIFICANT INITIAL
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT WATER
RECYCLING A TERRIBLE NOTED THAT
PRINTER FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND LAST YEAR'S- BUDGET IS TO BE
SHARED WITH GROUNDWATER CLEANUP
AND BECAME CLEAR AT A RECENT
STATE BOARD WORKSHOP AT THE
FUNDING MIGHT NOT EVEN BE SPLIT
FIFTY FIFTY MORE GOING OVER TO
THE GROUND WATER. A CLEAN UP
SIDE YEP RECYCLED WATER NEEDS
ITS OWN FUNDING CATEGORY.
SECRETARY BLUMENTHAL NOTED THAT-
AT A RECENT MEETING IN THAT
THERE IS AT LEAST ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN NEED
FOR RECYCLED WATER FUNDING IN
JUST THE NEXT THREE YEARS. AND
THE CURRENT ALLOCATION WE HAVE
ABOUT FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WHAT
IS. JUST A DROP IN THE BUCKET.
S. CALLED BUT NOTED THAT WE NEED
TO ONE. IN THE LONG TERM WATER
RESULT PROGRAM BEFORE GOING TO
BE. BICOL AND WHAT WITH. IT HAS
TO BE IN OUR GOAL TO THROUGH
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES. THAT WE
REQUESTED THE AND BACK- LOOK FOR
WORKING YOU IN THE MONTHS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT TOM
WILL COME FROM LINE NUMBER
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIM DELFINO ON
THE BEHALF OF DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY AND CALIFORNIA
WILDERNESS COALITION BIRTH THEY
WANTED SUPPORT ISSUE SEVEN THE
REVERSION AND ONGOING
APPROPRIATION FOR THE
BIODIVERSITY PROGRAM STAFF
POSITIONS. SECOND I WANT TO JUST
KNOW THAT WE APPRECIATE DIRECTOR
BONHAMS UPDATE ON THE SERVICE
BATES BUDGETING EFFORT AND THE-MINISTRY AND THE ACCEPT ME
ASKING ABOUT THAT WELL TO
APPRECIATE THE MINISTRATIONS-
INVESTMENT IN GENERAL FUND INTO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. BUT WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THERE IS SOME FRUSTRATION THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WHILE
I'VE BEEN ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT
YET PUT FORWARD ANY PROPOSALS OR
BEGUN DISCUSSIONS AROUND NEW
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SOURCES AND
WE WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THAT MOVE FORWARD AND IT IS NOT
AN EASY DISCUSSION IS A
COMPLICATED. AND WE HAVE NOT
MADE PROGRESS ON THAT- FINALLY I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT PER ITEM
SEVEN YOU'RE SUBCOMMITTEE
RECEIVED- A LETTER THIS MONTH
SIGNED BY THIRTY SEVEN
ORGANIZATIONS ASKING FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS THAT THE CANNABIS GRANT
PROGRAM OVER AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE FOR OVER
FIVE YEARS. TO DEAL WITH THE
GROWING BACKLOG OF TRESPASS GROW
SITES IN NEEDED REMEDIATION IN
PARTICULAR WE SEE AN EXPLOSION
OF THE ILLEGAL GROW SITES IN THE
CALIFORNIA DESERT IS THE COMING
OVER AND WRAPPED UP NEXT. AND WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE. TO WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR THAT GRANT. PROGRAM
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR NEXT COM OKAY FROM ONE THREE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHAU TRY THE NECKLINE. THAT'S
WHAT A LINE NUMBER TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LAURA KIM
I'M CALLING FROM THE LOS ANGELES
ALLIANCE FOR A NEW ECONOMY- AND
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM ENERGY HE DID
EARLIER- FOR. REMAINING WAIT
WHAT AND WATER WE ARE THE
PROGRAM FUNDS TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT ON GOING LOW INCOME
WATER READ ASSISTANCE OR AND
IT'S NOT FUNDING SIMILAR
APPROPRIATE OF FUNDS TO CONTINUE
TO ADDRESS THE AFFORDABILITY
CONCERNS OF OUR RESIDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND WHAT
ALSO ECHO SUPPORT FOR ADDITIONAL
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES OR LONG
TERM WATER RESILIENCE IN THE
FACE OF THE PERSISTENT DROUGHT A
NEW NORMAL AND APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS MADE IN TODAY'S HEARING
ABOUT THAT REALITY IN ITS
URGENCY TO ADDRESS. WITH
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
AND LOCAL WATER SUPPLY SOURCES
THAT ARE SUSTAINABLE SUCH AS WE
STARTED RECYCLING AS WELL AS
STORMWATER AND GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE OPPORTUNITIES WHICH
HAVE BEEN HIGHLIGHTED BY THE L.
A. WE'VE REALLY SEEN THAT
DRAMATIC- THE- FOR THE POSITION
FUNDS SUCH AS THE- OVER ONE
BILLION DOLLARS. I REQUEST FOR
D. W. R. HUNDRED DOLLARS AND
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN OUR
QUEST FOR THE BOARDS. I
REVOLVING LOAN SO REALLY PRETTY
THE CONCERN OF ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT MOVE US FORWARD EIGHT.
CLIMATE RESILIENT FUTURE THAT
CAN ALSO CREATE GOOD JOBS THANK
YOU HELLO PROBABLY MIGHT NOT BE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MEXICO
LINE NUMBER FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ABOUT LEE
AND I'M FROM THE COUNTRY FOR THE
ASSOCIATION AND I. ONE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO FUND THE
COURTS TO EXACTLY MY CHANGE YOU
. BOB AND LOOK AT THE NATION
BUSIEST PORT IN A TREE CAME
WAIT. GRAHAM TEN NINE CAN CARRY
TO ALLOW ONTO ONE. ACADEMIC OF
COMPOUND AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
COUNTRY FISCAL THAT IF ATTENDED
WILL. COMMUNISM'S POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS WILL CURRENT
DEPARTURE IS USED TO MAY BY THAT
THAT SUPPORT. UNDER THAN TEN
MILLION WILL GO TO A DEGREE MOVE
WORK PUSH CAMP WHICH WILL
TRANSFORM WORKFORCE WITH FUTURE
TO CLIENT. ZERO MISSION
TECHNOLOGY. EIGHT HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION A LOT OF PER
YEAR ON THE SHOW QUICK MINUTE
AND TRUCK FOR WILL HELP TO KEEP
I'M NOT GREENHOUSE GASES.
EQUIVALENT ONE POINT TWO BILLION
PER HIGH POWER BECAUSE A LOOK
CAR SURGES. THIRTY MILLION TOTAL
THE DIGITALIZATION OF TWENTY THE
STOCK AND FINALLY TWENTY BILLION
A LOT TO CAPACITY UP. TO ISSUE
COME DRIVE LICENSE. REVOKED
BUDGET WILL COURT GESTURE
WELCOME GARDEN SUPPLY CHAINS IN
TO COMPARE ADVANTAGE. KEEPING
ALL AT THE- OF TRADE. HE WAS BY
URGES OF ON THE PLAN THANK YOUNG
. THANK YOU I THINK YOU MAY-
COUNCIL ALSO COMMENTING ON
BEHALF OF CLEAN WATER ACTION.
BIRTH ON THE DROUGHT PACKAGE
WERE IN THE MIDST OF THE DRIVE.
IN THE STATE IN TWELVE HUNDRED
YEARS. LAST SUMMER THE RATE OF
NEW TRIED TRACKING WATER WELLS
REACHED THE PEAK OF THE PRIOR
DROUGHT AND WILL BE HUNDREDS OR
THOUSANDS OF TRAVEL OUT THIS
YEAR. WITHOUT THE POOR AT LEAST
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
FOR EMERGENCY DROUGHT RESPONSE
AND DRINKING WATER RESILIENCY
INVESTMENT. THREE HUNDRED
MILLION TO IMPLEMENT THE DROUGHT
RESILIENCY REQUIREMENTS AT EIGHT
FIVE FIVE TWO. AND A HUNDRED
MILLION TO IMPLEMENT THINK ABOUT
WITH 30% SATISFIED FOR DAX AND
DRINKING WATER. ON THE WATER
RESEARCH PROGRAM AND ITS
PROVIDED CRITICAL DISTANCE FOR
THE COMMUNITY WOOD BURKE
ALONGSIDE IN THE STATE BOARD DID
A GREAT JOB ESTABLISHING THE
PROGRAM IN MONTHS. AT THE SAME
TIME WATER MEANT THAT ON
AFFORDABLE FOR MOST LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE STATE AND A
SAFETY NET IF NEEDED TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS
OF INCOME OR ZIP CODE CAN
AFFORD. TO PAY FOR DRINKING
WATER AND AVOID WATER SHUT UP
THIS IS WHY WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO USE ANY REMAINING
RESEARCH FUNDING TO ESTABLISH
AND FUND IT A UNIVERSAL
STATEWIDE LOW INCOME RATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. SIMILAR TO
THAT PROPOSED BY SENATOR DOT IN
SB. TWO TWO TWO. YOU FOR THE- KT
TAPE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER AND WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING. WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OUR
NEXT IT WILL COME THROUGH A LOT
NUMBER FORTY FOUR GO AHEAD. HI
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR BLOOM-
STATE RUN CENTER COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS- WE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE FIVE
NINETY EDSA PER SMALL FARM
TECHNICAL ON WATER USE
EFFICIENCY BUT WE'RE MUCH MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DROUGHT AND
THAT TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION RESERVE FUND. MORE RAIN
DOESN'T FALL IT'LL BE VERY
URGENT TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
DROUGHT ASSISTANCE IF IT HAPPENS
THAT SMALL CLOSELY DISADVANTAGED
FARMERS. WHOSE WEALTH HABIT WILL
GO DRY WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE WITHOUT ASSISTANCE. AT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS GIVEN THE
GSA'S TWENTY YEARS TO IMPLEMENT
CIGNA. AND SO THERE'S VERY
LITTLE CONTROL OVER GROUNDWATER
PUMPING AT THE MOMENT. A LARGE
FARMS DEEP WELL TO DRAW DOWN THE
AQUIFERS WE CLEAR THE SMALL
FARM. WHO ARE CALLING AT THE
SANTA MONICA FARMERS MARKET WILL
BE COLLATERAL DAMAGE IN THIS
PROCESS. SO WE'RE REQUESTING
FIFTY MILLION FROM THE DROUGHT
RESERVE FUND TO GO TO CDS BATES
CALIFORNIA UNDERSERVED PRODUCER
PROGRAM WHICH IT DEMONSTRATED
THAT IT CAN GET MONEY OUT TO
THESE SMALL FARMS AND KEEP IN
MIND THAT THAT- WE'RE ALL THREE.
TWO MILLION APPROPRIATE THREE D.
W. ARE TO WORK WITH THE
COASTLINE INDUSTRY ON
IMPLEMENTING MORE DRY FARMING.
TECHNIQUES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT TOM WILL
COME FROM LINE NUMBER THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY CHAIR
MEMBERS THE GENERAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK- FORMER
COMMAND CONTINUES TO EXCEED
AVAILABLE FUNDING FOR THE
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE
PROGRAMS THAT WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR
SEVENTY MILLION. FOR THE STATE
WATER EFFICIENCY ENHANCEMENT
PROGRAM THE TWELVE EIGHT FIVE
MILLION FOR THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM. WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE AN
INCREASE TO FIFTEEN MILLION FOR
THE ALTERNATIVE MILK MANURE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. OF THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE STATE'S THEORY
THE LIVESTOCK OPERATIONS CAN'T
ARGUES DIED GESTURES BECAUSE
THEY DON'T PRODUCE ENOUGH NOR
HAVE THE CAPITAL TO JUSTIFY DIED
AFTER. BUT IN CONTRAST BEALL
TREATMENT OR MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
IS SCALE NEUTRAL IT OFFERS A
DIVERSITY OF PRACTICES THAT BOTH
REDUCE METHANE EMISSIONS AND
ALSO IPROVE. AIR AND WATER
QUALITY. FINALLY WE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMON WITH CAST HELLO WORK IT'S
ABOUT- SMALL FARMERS AND DRAW
RELEASE AND WOULD LIKE SEE.
INCREASE FUNDING- OF IT FIFTEEN
GO TO SUPPORT SPEC CUTS PROGRAM
HE GETS PAID- FOCUS ON SMALL
FARMER DROUGHT RELIEF. AS WELL
AS ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR SIGMA OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION FOR SMALL AND SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS OUR GROUNDWATER. I
HAVE. RESOURCES AND FIND IT. WE
SUPPORT. THE FARM TO SCHOOL
FUNDING THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT COMMA ALL COME FROM
LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE BUT I
DON'T START GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
BLOOM- MY NAME IS DEEP CLEANING
ON BEHALF OF PLASTER COUNTY
WATER AGENCY AND THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY MY COMMENTS ARE
GEARED TOWARDS ISSUE ONE DROUGHT
RESILIENCE AND RESPONSE. THERE'S
AN OVERWHELMING NEED FOR A MULTI
BENEFIT WATER RESILIENCY FUNDING
FUNDING THAT TRULY FOCUSES ON
ENHANCING AND STRENGTHENING OUR
WATERSHEDS IN ORDER TO EXPAND
SOME OF THE EXTREME EVENTS WE'RE
ALL WITNESSING NOW. EVEN THOUGH
WE WERE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL TO
SEE THESE TYPES OF INVESTMENTS
MADE THE GOALS WE SET OUT TO
ACHIEVE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO BE
ACCOMPLISHED WITH THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT WAS DEDICATED THESE
PURPOSES THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
IT ALSO CREATED AN ADDED
CHALLENGE THAT THE URBAN FUNDING
AND MULTI BENEFIT FUNDING WERE
COMBINED FOR THE SOLICITATION WE
WOULD RECOMMEND SEPARATING USE
AREAS DUE TO THE OVERWHELMING
DEMAND THAT WE ALL SAW- AND
OVERALL WE WOULD URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
THESE MUCH NEEDED INVESTMENT.
INTO OUR WATERSHED BEEN HOPELESS
ENTER THE CURRENT AND FUTURE.
PROLONGED DROUGHT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT TIME
WILL COME FROM LINE NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD-
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DANIELLE BLACK WHITE AND WITH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES-
CA SAND AND I WANT TO COMMENT ON
THE- WATER AND DROUGHT RESPONSE
FUNDING ITEMS. AND WE'RE VERY
SUPPORTIVE AS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL- FOR ALLOCATING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WE APPRECIATE
THAT DISTORT INVESTMENT LAST
YEAR BUT BELIEVE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING CONTINUES TO BE NEEDED
IN SEVERAL AREAS INCLUDING WATER
RECYCLING DAM SAFETY WATER USE
EFFICIENCY AND CONSERVATION.
WATER IN THE BASIN AND
CONSTITUENTS OF AMERICAN CONCERN
I'M IN ADDITION ON THE-
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FROM THE WATER
AND WASTEWATER RESEARCH PROGRAM
WE SUPPORT EXTENDING THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE PROGRAM TO
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. TO MAKE SURE THAT
MARKETMARKET RECEIVE AT THAT
THEN THEY MAY BE STRUGGLING TO
GET YOU OVER TO UTILITY BELT
THANK YOU. SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY.
YOUR THANK. X. OKAY FROM LINE
FOUR TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
HELLO THANK YOU MY NAME IS SUSAN
LITTLE AND I AM A I'M LOOK AT
THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP'S AND I'M COULD-
TESTIFYING TODAY REGARDING ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN CONCERNING THE
LEAD- SERVICE LINE FUNDS THAT
WILL BE COMING FROM. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- HE WG AND MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS ARE INCREASINGLY
CONCERNED THAT WATER SYSTEMS
HAVE BEEN GROUP REMOVING LEAD
PIPES LET FITTINGS AND GALVANIZE
LINES THAT MATTER THAT COULD
CAUSE LET SPIKES IN CONSUMERS
DRINKING WATER. AND THESE
REMOVALS HAVE OCCURRED WITHOUT
PUBLIC HEALTH MEDICATIONS SUCH
AS NOTIFICATION AND THE
PROVISION OF FILTERS AND TAP
WATER TESTING. BECAUSE OF THESE
CONCERNS NINETEEN LEGISLATORS
SENT A LETTER TO THE WATER BOARD
ASKING FOR MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE WATER SYSTEMS REMOVAL.
AND CALLING ON THE BOARD TO ONLY
ALLOW REPLACEMENTS THAT ARE DONE
IN A HEALTH PROTECTIVE MANNER.
WITH BOTH THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATELY OWNED LEADED AND
GALVANIZE PRCHMENT REMOVED AT
THE SAME TIME AND WITH THE
PROVISION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTECTIONS. THE WATER BOARD IS
NOT YET RESPONDED TO THE
LEGISLATORS LETTER. SENT AND
BECAUSE OF OUR CONTENT ON GOING
CONCERNS SINCE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF FEDERAL FUNDS WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO FUND ADDITIONAL
BUT- WE'D ASK THE LEGISLATURE.
TO RESTRICT THE USE OF THE
FUNDS. TO ENGINE ONLY UP- USE
THEM FOR FULL SERVICE REMOVED.
THAT IS TRUE. BOTH BUT GOOSE
NECK PICKED. CONNECTORS ON ALL
ON. PUBLIC AS WELL AS THE- SIDE
. REQUIRE THE FUNDED BY. AT A
REMOVE CHIPPER PUBLIC MEDICAID
MEASURES INCLUDING CUSTOMER
NOTIFICATION. POST CONSTRUCTION
TAP WATER TESTING AND THE
PROVISION OF LEAD REMOVING
FILTERS AND SIX MONTHS WORTH OF
CARTRIDGES AND TO EXPLICITLY
ALLOW STATE OR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO RECEIVE SOME OF
THE FUNDS TO PAY FOR LARGER
PUBLIC OUTREACH AND EDUCATION
CAMPAIGNS. AS WELL AS TO ENSURE
THAT MEDICATION MEASURES ARE
ADEQUATELY PROVIDED THANK YOU
FOR THOSE CONSIDERATIONS.
CONNECT COMMENT WILL COME FROM
LINE NUMBER THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS THIS IS MICHAEL JARED-
FOR THE COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH
FAMILY FARMERS IN THE CENTER FOR
FOOD SAFETY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THESE ISSUES TODAY
AFTER REVIEWING IS IMPORTANT
BUDGET PROPOSAL. CALF AND CFS
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR
THE FARM TO SCHOOL PROGRAM AND
THE ADDITIONAL STAFF WE BELIEVE
IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
PROVIDE LOCALLY GROWN FOOD FROM
SMALL AND MID SCALE FARM. THE
FARM TO SCHOOL PROGRAM OFFERS A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO INCREASE
CLIMATE SMART ACT PRACTICES IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING A
COMPREHENSIVE SYSTEMS LIKE
ORGANIC A CAPTAINCY ABOUT ALSO
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THE STATE ORGANICS PROGRAM AND
BELIEVE IT IS IMPORTANT. TO THE
FUND TO BE STRUCTURED IN A WAY
THAT SUPPORT HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED FARMERS TO ENSURE
THEY CAN PARTICIPATE AND BENEFIT
FROM THE PROGRAM WE ALSO FEEL A
STANDALONE PROGRAM AT CDFA IS
WHAT IS NECESSARY FOR THE NEEDS
OF FARMERS AND CONSUMERS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE NEXT TIME
COMICAL COME FROM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN PLEASE AHEAD. I'M
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE SYSTEM
GILBERT FOR THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SANITATION DISTRICT
COMMENTING ON ITEM ONE
SPECIFICALLY FUNDING FOR
RECYCLED WATER PROJECTS. WE'D
LIKE TO SEE MORE- FINDING MORE
AGGRESSIVE FUNDING FOR RECYCLED
WATER PROJECTS STATEWIDE THAN
CURRENTLY PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION WE THINK YOU KNOW
GIVEN THE DROUGHT AND CLIMATE
CHANGE THERE'S AN OBVIOUS NEED
FOR THAT. AND IN PARTICULAR L.
A. C. S. B. SUPPORTS M. W. D. IS
BUDGET REQUEST. TO HELP FIND ITS
PROJECT TO COVER FIVE WASTEWATER
HI THIS IS A REGIONAL PROJECTS
SO IT'S VERY CONSISTENT WITH
SECRETARY CRAWFORD'S COMMENTS
ABOUT THE NEED TO- FOR REGIONAL
WATER RESILIENCE AND IT'LL SERVE. FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. EIGHT PROJECTS
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THE TOTAL COME
FROM LINE NUMBER TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR- BLOOM AND- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO DENVER CLEANING THE
DIRECTOR OF WATER RESOURCES FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU. WE
REPRESENT OVER- THIRTY THOUSAND.
OUR MEMBERS MOST OF WHICH ARE
SMALL FARMS. IN THE SHORT TERM
AT THE COMMENT I'M GOING TO
FOCUS ON TWO THINGS WITH REGARD
TO THE DROUGHT RESILIENCE IN
RESPONSE PACKAGE- WE BELIEVE
THAT- MORE FUNDING NEEDS TO BE
PUT TOWARDS AUSTRIAN RESERVOIRS
AND RIGOROUS TOWARDS- WITHOUT MR
QUIVERS IN THESE EXTREME RAIN
EVENTS WHEN THEY DO COME. WE
CANNOT PUSH ALL THAT WATER INTO
THE- GROUND WATER ONLY- MISTER.
BENNETT COMMENTED ON- SPEEDING
UP- THAT SEGMENT TIMELINE- THERE
IS A LACK OF UNDERSTANDING OF
THE COMPLEXITY OF SIGMA- THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS NOT ONLY TO.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- RURAL
COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO URBAN
COMMUNITIES STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SCHOOL DISTRICTS-
DOCKWORKERS AND BASICALLY
EVERYONE AS IT AS IT TRICKLES
DOWN- SHUTTING DOWN OUR OUR
SURFACE WATER AND- GROUNDWATER
OVERNIGHT WILL SEVERELY IMPACT-
ALL. ALL ELEMENTS OF OUR ECONOMY
AND JUST LAST WEEK CLOSING- IS
UP A POINT. BETWEEN OCTOBER
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN- AFTER IN DELTA USES
C. B. P. AND STATE WATER PROJECT
EXPORTS WERE ACCOUNTED FOR. WE
SPILLED FORTY NINE AND A HALF
MILLION ACRE FEET. OF WATER INTO
THE PACIFIC OCEAN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT TOM WILL
COME FROM MY NUMBER FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BLOOM ON THE
COMMITTEE ALL NATIONAL PACIFIC
FOREST TRUST SPEAKING TO THE
DROUGHT RESILIENT ITEM- WE JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THT FOR ALL
OF THE GOOD THINGS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THAT PACKAGE. IT IS
QUITE LIGHT ON THE COORDINATED
INVESTMENT IN OUR SOURCE
WATERSHED THAT SUPPLIED SO MUCH
OF OUR WATER. AND POINT OUT THAT
. INVESTMENTS THAT IMPROVE
WATERSHED RESILIENCE AND METER
OUT THE FLOW OF WATER LATER INTO
THE SEASON. ARE ALSO THE SAME
SORTS OF INVESTMENT WE WANT TO
BE DOING FOR CLIMATE RESILIENCE
FOR FIRE MITIGATION AND FOR-
BIODIVERSITY PROTECTION. AT THE
WOULD IT ENCOURAGE AS YOU'RE
LOOKING AT. REVISIONS THROUGH
THE MAY REVIVE PROCESS. AND
ALLOCATION OF THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT HAS
NOT YET BEEN ALLOCATED. TO
CONSIDER A PROGRAM FOCUSED IN
THE SOURCE WATERSHEDS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA WATER SYSTEM. SIMILAR
TO THE LEGISLATION THE U. KERRY
BACK IN TWENTY SIXTEEN- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. CONNECT COMMENT
THAT'LL COME FROM MY NUMBER
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUT
THERE. ARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND ON
BEHALF OF MENTION BEFORE THE
FONG TO ITEM. NUMBER ONE THE JOB
MARKET WE HAVE TO THE POINT MADE
BY THE CHECKOUT BY WHAT PEOPLE
SAY AT ME SEVEN FIFTY NINE AND
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION.
JOPLIN WE APPROPRIATED K.
COMMUNITIES THAT RESPECT IN
CHATHAM GOT THE WRITTEN OUR
BUDGET MALAYSIA LETTER AT
JAPANESE ARE STILL WORST.
FINALLY ECHO THE MADE BY ENERGY
LA ALLIANCE AND- ON THE NUMBER
THREE IN. LANDMARKS HAS GOOD
SURE LET PERCENT. ACT THAT COULD
DRINKING DEPTH QUICKLY QUICKLY
RECOVER THAT AND THEN HELLO DUE
TO EXTREME. IN THE WATER SECTOR
AND A VOLUNTARY THE FROM THE
WASHINGTON NOT A BITTER FIVE
THANK THE UNDERLYING. TO CARE
MAIN MENU CAL CALIBRATION OF THE
MARK TWAIN READ THE OVER MOVING
WATER ACCESS I PLEDGE STRONGLY
THAT STORY ASSEMBLY FOR
REMAINING ARREARS. UNABLE TO
TAKE WATER WITH ONLY FILL THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT OF THE OUT
EARLIER TO THE RATHER THAN ONE
TIME LOW INCOME THAT THE
CALIFORNIANS WILL PREVENT UP
THERE JUST FOR THE SHUT UP
ANYTHING THAT YOU WATER THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND THE
FORWARD TO WITH ALLEGE THEY-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- THERE'S A
JOB WAITING FOR YOU YOU EVER
NEED TO DO- IF AT FOR PEOPLE IN
NEED SPEED GREATER.
ACCUTANE FREAKING ON THE
PROPOSED THAT TRUCK PACKAGE. I
WOULD LIKE TO CALL ATTENTION TO
THE NEED FOR CONTINUED FUNDING
FOR. ATMOSPHERIC WEBER THREE
THIRDS AND FOR CAPTAIN POOR.
PARK OPERATIONS ALTERNATE BE
AROUND. ZERO IS REALLY SHOWING A
LOT OF COMMENTS. IN OUR SYSTEM
WE WORKED WITH THE ARMY CORPS
AND SCRIPT TOOK BY THE TO.
MENDOCINO CANDIDATE ABLE TO
TOPPLE. INTO NOT THAT ACRE OF
WATER THIS PAST YEAR WHICH WHAT
ABOUT THE WHITE BEEN RELEASED SO
WE THINK THAT THIS. IS RIDLEY
KIT CRITICAL CONSIDERING
HISTORICALLY LOW WATER LEVELS AT
LAKE MENDOCINO. AND WE THINK
THAT- CONTINUED- FUNDING. FOR
THAT PURPOSE BUT- BENEFIT. OTHER
RESERVOIRS ACROSS THE STATE TELL
US THANK YOU AND THAT CREATES.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME. THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT COMMENT COME FROM
ONE FOUR EIGHT PLEASED AHEAD.
YEAH THIS IS JENNIFER ON OF
MOUNTAIN PENDING OF GREAT FOR
THE- L. A. AND FISHING WILDLIFE
FOR TEACHING TO AND THE IN OF
THE STATE AFTER HE REMAIN
CRITICAL TO THE LONG TERM WITH.
OF THE DEPART AND OUR MISSION WE
CAN AFFORD TO LOSE THE MOMENTUM
BEHIND THIS INVESTMENT OF
TAXPAYER FUNDING STAFFLINE IN
STAKEHOLDER ADVOCACY I WILL FLAG
THAT A MEASURE AIMED AT REDUCING
SINGLE USE PLASTIC PACKAGING AND
FOOTWEAR HAS QUALIFIED NOVEMBER
BALLOT THAT WOULD GENERATE NEW
STATE REVENUE. BUT IT PASSED BY
VOTERS WILL CONTRIBUTE TO
ADDRESSING SOME BUT DEFINITELY
NOT ALL OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
CHRONIC UNDER FUNDING ISSUE WE
WILL NEED MORE. ALONG WITH THE
NATIONAL WILDLIFE FEDERATION WE
ALSO SUPPORT AUGMENTING LAST
YEAR SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
THAT ADDRESSING HUMAN WILDLIFE
CONFLICTS THAT ARE RISING DUE TO
DROUGHT CLIMATE CHANGE HABITAT
LOSS FOR CASH MANAGEMENT AND
OTHER HUMAN CAUSED PROBLEMS. WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO ENSURE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS
SUFFICIENT AND NOTES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAD REALLY INITIATED
WHAT WE CONSIDER
TRANSFORMATIONAL EFFORTS IN THIS
SPACE WITH THE FUNDING PROVIDED
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. AND
FINALLY WHILE WEARING MY SAN
FRANCISCO SPCA IN SAN DIEGO
HUMANE SOCIETY HAT THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN BALLOON FOR YOUR
PERSISTENCE IN PURSUING A HUMANE
MODEL OF ANIMAL BLOOD BANKING IN
CALIFORNIA WE THINK IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR CDFA TO CONVENE
STAKEHOLDERS PRIOR TO NAY. TO
SHARE THEIR VISION AND TIMELINE
FOR IMPLEMENTATION ESPECIALLY
GIVEN OUR ADVOCACY FOR YOUR BILL
AND FOR THE MILLION DOLLARS
INCLUDED. IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. COM OKAY
FROM MY NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHRISTIE THOMPSON WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON
DROPPING WATER RESILIENCY I'LL
TELL METROPOLITAN DOES SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR
DROUGHT RESILIENCE RESPONSE
FIFTY HERE AND TODAY'S AGENDA
ITEM SEVENTEEN NINETEEN TWENTY
AND TWENTY FOUR. OUR ABILITY TO
CONTINUE TO ADAPT TO CLIMATE
CHANGE IS GOING TO TAKE AN EVEN
GREATER INVESTMENT OF LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL DOLLARS TODAY
CALMATTERS RAN AN OP ED BY OUR
GENERAL MANAGER ABOUT
OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST IN OUR
REGIONAL RECYCLED WATER PROGRAM
WE NEED THE STATE'S HELP TO
PREPARE FOR THE MEGA DROUGHTS
LIKE THE ONE ARE IN. SEVEN
CALIFORNIA'S WATER AGENCIES HAVE
FOURTEEN POINT FIVE BILLION IN
NEW INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
PLANNED OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
THE BUDGET SURPLUS PRESENTS A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTNER PARTNER WITH US ON THESE
PROJECTS THAT WOULD HELP
TRANSFORM SEVEN CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE WATER SUPPLY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT TIME- WILL COME FROM
ONE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL I'VE GOT MILES ON BEHALF OF
THE LANCHESTER IN CREEK COUNTY
AND THE POTENTIAL REGIONAL.
DISTRICT PERSON LIKE TO COMMENT
ON ISSUE NUMBER TEN ON THE
AGENDA. REPORTS OF FOR FUNDING.
IN MARK ADDITION AT. ANYA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
- TO FACILITATE OF SB SEVEN
NINETY YEAH ON THAT ON THE
DROUGHT PACKAGE I'D LIKE TO THE
POOR INVESTMENTS PROPOSED TO THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
INCLUDING A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE STREAMFLOW
PROGRAM AS WELL AS- FORTY
MILLION FOR RESILIENCE. PROJECTS
FOR FISHING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT TIME WILL COME
FROM MY NUMBER FORTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TEACHER
NUMBERS COLLABORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU WE
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE STATE
WATER EFFICIENCY ENHANCEMENT
PROGRAM AT CDFA- HOWEVER AS ONE
OF THE ONLYFARMER FACING WATER
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS AND WITH THE
ANTICIPATED SIGNIFICANT DROUGHT
CONTINUING. WE WOULD REQUEST
ADDITIONAL FUNDING INCLUDING
IMMEDIATE ATTRACTION SINCE FOR
ALL FARMERS IN THE REVISION I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO PROVIDE
COMMENT ON THE PROPOSED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE MULTI
BENEFIT MANY PERMITTING PROGRAM
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION. THIS IS WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S DROUGHT RESILIENCE
AND RESPONSE PACKAGE- WE WERE
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE UNDER THE
APPROVED GUIDELINES FUNDS ARE
NOT ACTUALLY ELIGIBLE FOR
FARMERS DIRECTLY AT THE WE HOPE
THAT IT FEATURED FUNDS ARE
OFFERED IN THIS BUDGET- THE
DOCTOR CAN BE MADE. WE'RE
CONCERNED WITH THE GROWING TREND
THAT SOME OF THE PROPOSED FARMER
SUPPORTING PROGRAMS IN PRACTICE
ACTUALLY REQUIRE FARMERS TO
FIRST YOU THROUGH AN NGO-
SOMETIMES IT'S INTERMEDIARIES
ARE NECESSARY BUT THEY'RE NOT.
AN ABSOLUTE INCREDIBLE COULDN'T
FAULT. AND SO THE- MAYBE ON ITS
BUT NINETEEN SOME OF THE LIMITED
. DON'T ACTUALLY STRETCHED THE
FAR. SO WE'RE ASKING LEGISLATURE
TO BE HIGH VIGILANT SB PRO. AT
THE ACT BE FARM FACING THANK YOU
FOR MUCH THE YOU. OUR NEXT TIME
OKAY FROM ONE FIFTH ONE PLEASE
CALL. GOOD AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS
ADDED UNITS ON BEHALF OF THE
SUBSTATION OF KABBA WATER
AGENCIES- JUST A COUPLE QUICK
COMMENTS REGARDING ISSUE ONE THE
GOVERNOR'S DROUGHT RESILIENCE
AND RESPONSE PACKAGE- CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO CONTINUE TO INVEST
IN DROUGHT RESILIENCE IT WAS
GREAT TO SEE THE FIVE POINT TWO
BILLION- BUT FORWARD LAST YEAR.
SPECIFIC TO THIS YEAR'S FUNDING
IN THE PROPOSED HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION FOR WATER CONSERVATION
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT
FUNDING- IT WOULD ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGE MORE- PARTICULARLY AS
WATER AGENCIES ARE GOING TO BE
REQUIRED FOR THE REDUCE INDOOR
WATER USE- A COUPLE CATEGORIES
THAT HAVE NOT CLEAN- INVESTMENT
OR OR WE BELIEVE COULD SEE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT OF THE
FIRST BEING DAM SAFETY- THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF HIGH HAZARD DAMS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA- THAT.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES HAS IDENTIFIED THEY
HAVE NOT RECEIVED FUNDING FOR
SOME TIME ND ARE IN REALLY DIRE
NEED OF. RETROSPECT REPAIRS- WE
WERE ALSO ENCOURAGE CONSIDER OF
EACH FUNDING. FOR PEACE AFTER.
PROGRAM PROJECTS WHAT COULD. I'M
CONVEYING. OF WATERGATE
INCLUDING ATMOSPHERIC REACHED.
AND ADDITIONAL IN A SEPARATE
FUND POOREST WATER I'M WAS
MENTIONED BY WATER REDUCE
EARLIER- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY COME AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING. THANK YOU.
AND AS A REMINDER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. HI OUR NEXT
TIME WILL COME FROM LINE NUMBER
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MOMENT MY APOLOGIES. BY NUMBER
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT AND ONCE IN A JOB YOU WISH
TO COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. JUST A MOMENT.
MY NUMBER FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS TRICIA
GERINGER WITH AGRICULTURAL
TEMPLE CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND FARMERS
AND FARMER AND BUSINESSES FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE COMMENTING
ON THE DROUGHT RESILIENCE AND
RESPONSE PACKAGE. I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE FUNDING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE STATE
WATER EFFICIENCY ENHANCEMENT
PROGRAM AT EDSA. ALSO SUPPORTIVE
OF DOLLARS GOING TOWARDS THE
MULTI BENEFIT PLAN REPUBLICAN
PROGRAM I ALSO WANT TO CONCUR
WITH THE FARM BUREAU COMMENTS
THAT FARMERS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
QUALIFY FOR FUNDING DIRECTLY.
WITH REGARD TO GROUND RECHARGE
AND DOLLARS THERE WHICH WE ARE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AS WE ARE ALSO
SUPPORTIVE INCREASING FUNDING
FOR THAT PROGRAM THE PLANNING
ENGINEERING ANALYSIS. INACTION
TO SUPPORT IMPLEMENTATION AB
SIGMAR AND ONCE YOU GO THE STAFF
COMMENT WHEN HE TWENTY OF THE
TOP COMMITTEE AGENDA. THAT WE
BELIEVE STORY AND SUPPLY ARE
KERR MY STANDING THE CREATE AND
GROUNDWATER UP THROUGH IN IMPACT
. IN THE GROUND WATER WE PER.
APPRECIATE THAT CAN
CONSIDERATION AND YOU SEE MARTHA
AND COME OUT WITH A WILL GREAT
YOU CAN IMPACT AND NOW AND MANY
OVER ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION. IN
A DROUGHT. I TO THE THANK YOU
FOR MISTER. AND MEMBER. THANK
YOU. MR CARE PERSON AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. GREAT
THANK YOU- I THINK- EARLIER IN
OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY ACT CUT
MISTER A- HEAR SOME OTHER- KALRA
DIFFERENT MAN TO ALL- DO YOU
THINK YOU CAN DO IT A ABOUT
THEIR SECONDS. ACTUALLY ALL
RIGHT HAVE A IT. MISTER CHAIRMAN
FOR FROM OCCURRING HERE TODAY
THANK YOU- ISSUE NOT FOR OUR
UNDER. THAT WERE DISCUSSED TODAY
. THE SCHOOL PROGRAM ON BEHALF
OF THE ALL OF CARE TAYLOR. PICKS
FOR SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
POST. AND WE DO BELIEVE THAT THE
BAY WILL BE- THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS ARE DISCUSSED-
WHEN THE ITEM WAS HEARD EARLIER
TODAY. AND WE JUST WANT TO BE ON
THE RECORD IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT BRINGS US TO THE
CONCLUSION OF TODAY'S HEARING.
AND TO APPRECIATE- ALL THE-
PUBLIC INPUT THAT WE RECEIVED
AND- TESTIMONY ON A- VARIETY OF
IMPORTANT TOPICS. WE'RE BACK
NEXT WEDNESDAY RIGHT WE WILL BE
BACK NEXT WEDNESDAY AND TELL
THEM WE'RE ADJOURNED.